Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Urlaub auf einer Yacht gemacht?
Noch nie und ich hab auch gar kein Interesse daran.
Ich auch nicht so unbedingt, aber es scheint ja doch sehr verlockend zu sein.
Ja, ich wunderte mich da so ein bisschen darüber, dass man das haben möchte und dort dann so viel Zeit verbringen will. Ich könnte jetzt verstehen, wenn jemand sagt, ich mach da mal einen Ausflug mit, bin ein Wochenende unterwegs und dann hat meine Jacht vielleicht wie hier beschrieben bei Julia Friedrichs auch noch ein U-Boot und damit kann ich dann auch mal noch ein bisschen durch die Gegend tuckern. Aber dass man das als einen Lebensinhalt betrachten möchte, dass man auf einer Jacht sich flätzt, kann ich nicht so nachvollziehen. Denn man ist ja dort mit Leuten, die einem lieb sind und mit Personal. Und da stellt sich bei mir schon die Frage, will man eigentlich die ganze Zeit nochmal andere Leute um sich herum haben? Und wer ist es eigentlich, mit dem man jetzt mehrere Wochen auf so einem Boot verbringen will? Also da fallen mir jetzt nicht zehn Leute ein, die ich jetzt die ganze Zeit bei mir haben möchte. Ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut, nicht irgendwo drauf gefangen zu sein, sondern hinzugehen und wieder weggehen zu können.
Da sieht man schon, in dem Fall wird ja weggeflogen.
Ja, stimmt.
Bist ja schnell woanders. Kannst ja schnell mal irgendwo rein düsen. Da sieht man schon, dieses Buch beschäftigt sich mit einem Thema, über das man grundsätzlich wenig weiß, aber jeder erst mal fasziniert ist. Und wir machen hier gerade dieselbe Übung wie Julia Friedrichs auch. Man überlegt sich, wie stackt man eigentlich ein? Und das Thema ist die Yacht. Also die Yacht ist so eine Art Schlüssel, das die ersten Seiten prägt. Und hier auch unsere ersten Minuten des Gesprächs. Es wird nicht dabei bleiben. Und trotzdem muss man sich ja fragen, was hat es damit auf sich? Also es gibt so eine Art Landlust, Boote exklusiv. Huya Friedrichs sitzt also zu Hause. Blätter durch diese Zeitung, in der ihr die Superjachten vorgestellt werden. Kaufpreis 50, 100, 300, 500 Millionen. Sie heißen Savanna oder A-H-P-O, Apo, Apo, außerparlamentarische Opposition. Wie oft wird sich das mal mit dem Boot rumfährt sagen? Also ich bin ja außerparlamentarische Regierung. Ich mache hier Opposition. 115 Meter lang, kommt aus Deutschland. Die Werft Lürsen stellt sie her. Ein wuchtiges weißes Schiff, sechs Etagen, Holzplanken, das große H für den Hubschrauber oben draufgemalt. 245 Quadratmeter, große Master Suite. Der muss man ja nicht bleiben. Man kann auch auf die 180 Grad Sehblick Panorama in den Panoramasalon gehen. Kostenpunkt, man kann sie kaufen oder mieten. Kostet pro Woche 2,6 Millionen Euro.
Volltanken 400.000 Liter.
Ja, und man hat auch noch nicht für die Crew bezahlt.
Ja, also man tankt für eine halbe Million Euro, um das nochmal gerade hier zu sagen.
Dieses Schiff ist zugelassen für elf Leute und hat aber 36 Leute Personal. Die müssen extra bezahlt werden. Die sind noch nicht in den 2,6 Millionen Euro Mietpreis enthalten. Und klar, man kann jetzt unendlich viele Anekdoten. Sie sagt, sie hat da so einen Ordner angelegt. Wir sagen, oh, das fand ich auch amüsant. Irgendeine Frau stellt sich Rochenhaut auf allen Möbeln. Wird ihr angefertigt? Sie sieht das dann das erste Mal und sagt, nee, doch nicht, alles wieder runter.
Oder jemand kommt auf die Idee, dass das doch schön wäre, wenn die Crew im Meerjungfrauenkostüm mal draußen im Meer schwimmt und man kann ihnen dabei zusehen, während man das dann realisiert.
Genau. So, jetzt ist es so. Sie sagt dann irgendwann im Text, stopp, ich hab mich hier vielleicht voran. Keine Ahnung, diese Metapher, diese Superjachten, die Supermetapher, vielleicht trägt die gar nicht so weit. Und ich möchte gerne ihr widersprechen. Also, ich liebe dieses Buch. Ich hab's wirklich genossen, es zu lesen. Kein öko-emanzipatorisches Blablabla irgendwie, sondern echte Zahlen, Daten, Fakten. Sie sagt jetzt, die Superjachten sind vielleicht nur eine Supermetapher. Ich will jetzt an den Kern der Menschen. Ich sage, mir ist der Kern der Menschen total scheißegal. Mir ist auch egal, wie sie heißen. Ich finde es sehr gut, dass sich jemand bemüht hat, diese Gespräche zu führen. Es ist sozusagen ein unschätzbarer Wert, diese Art Datenmaterial jetzt zu haben. Nur die Superjachten sind keine Supermetapher. Es ist keine Metapher. Diese Leute leben tatsächlich auf diesen Booten. Dieses CO2 ist echt. Das ist nicht irgendeine Illustration oder eine Kulisse, die man mal so hinbaut, damit der Leser versteht, was hier Sache ist. Sondern diese Leute leben auf diesen Booten, die pro Jahr 7000 Tonnen CO2 produzieren.
Sie zitiert ja auch einen Journalisten, Rupert Neate. Der hat ausgerechnet, dass man um 6000 Superjachten ein Jahr in Stand zu halten, so viel Geld braucht, dass man mit diesem Geld auch die Schulden aller Entwicklungsländer tilgen könnte.
Das ist keine Metapher, sondern das könnte man einfach machen. Wenn man eine Metapher suchte, könnte man sich jetzt fragen, wie verbildlichen wir uns, dass diese Superreichen, die die ganze Zeit die ökonomischen und ökologischen Ressourcen der ganzen Welt auszehren und gleichzeitig noch unser größtes Projekt, die Demokratie, die ganze Zeit blockieren, wie könnte man das beschreiben? Einseitige Nutzeniserschaft, ausbeuterische Koexistenz, Ressourcen abschöpfendes Verhalten, unfaire Profiteurkonstellation, unilateral vorteilhafte Verbindung oder einfach das sind Parasiten. Das sind Parasiten wie Zecken, Bandwürmer, Kopfläuse oder Zombieameisen, die halt einfach an dieser Welt kleben, sie einseitig auszehren und wir kriegen von ihnen nichts zurück.
Gut, jetzt sind wir natürlich gleich in der Diskussion, wo ich sagen würde, Menschen jetzt als Parasiten darzustellen, halte ich für sehr sinnlos. Ich glaube, dass man gar nicht in dieses Vokabular verfallen muss, sondern die Sache ist doch ganz klar. Also man braucht ja gar nicht mehr jetzt noch mal eine andere Umschreibung. Wenn ich höre, dass eine Tankfüllung für eine Jacht 400.000 Liter Benzin bedeutet und eine halbe Million Euro kostet, dann brauche ich doch eigentlich nicht noch mal ein weiteres Wort, noch nicht noch einen Begriff, um irgendwas zu beschreiben. Dann ist doch für jeden halbwegs klar denkenden Menschen, in Klammern vielleicht nicht für Markus Lanz, der sagt, da sind aber doch die Arbeitsplätze so wichtig, ist doch eigentlich vollkommen klar, dass das nicht geht. Also das ist ja auch nicht mehr eine Frage von naja, wann ist zu viel, zu viel? Also braucht man zehn Krawatten oder reichen auch fünf oder sollen 20 sein? Sondern hier sind wir ja in dem Reich, dass man hat, ich habe 50.000 Krawatten und brauche noch zehn weitere. Ja, also das ist ja, das ist jenseits von aller Vorstellungskraft eigentlich. Und man versucht dann immer wieder neue Bilder dafür zu finden. Man hat aber das Bild, das ist zugleich die Konkretion, dieser Ungleichheit ist nämlich die Yacht. Und die Yacht kann man sehen. Man kann sich das im Internet ansehen. Man kann aber auch mal, wenn man in Südfrankreich ist am Hafen, in Cannes oder Nizza rumlaufen, dann wird man diese Yachten sehen. Und damit sind wir doch eigentlich an einem Punkt, wo wir schon gar nicht mehr jetzt so ein hartes Vokabular in Anschlag bringen brauchen, sondern eigentlich sagte einem der gesunde Menschenverstand, dass das völlig falsch ist. Und wenn man dann erfährt, dass und sie konzentriert sich ja auf die deutschen Superreichen, also nicht auf die globale Geldelite, dass in Deutschland 3.300 Menschen 23 Prozent des Finanzvermögens besitzen. Und dass diese Menschen alle ein Vermögen von mehr als 100 Millionen US-Dollar besitzen.
Lass uns mal noch beim Begriff bleiben. Der Parasit. In diesem Buch wird ja auch kritisiert, dass es zu wenig gute Soziologie oder gar keine gibt. Niemand beobachtet das. Und sie beginnt mit einer Metapher, von der ich sage, das ist keine Metapher. Aber wir bräuchten hier durchaus mal Metaphern, denn die Zahlen, die wir gleich ausführlich nennen werden, die sind zu groß. Also einfach nur die Zahlen nennen, das ist so ein bisschen, denn wir brauchen hier Metaphern. In der Soziologie ist es durchaus in manchen auch grundbegrifflich von parasitären oder symbiotischen Verhältnissen zu sprechen. Um einfach zu markieren, haben da beide Seiten was davon oder nur die eine Seite. Wenn ich jetzt sage Parasit, sage ich nicht ein parasitäres Verhältnis, sondern ich bezeichne eine Person. Und jetzt habe ich ja im Teaser schon den Scherz gemacht, ich werde hier so über diese Menschen reden, wie Friedrich Merz über Migranten. Mit einem großen Unterschied, die Migranten können die Eigenschaften, die Merz und Söder hoch generalisieren, nicht ablegen. Sie kommen nun mal aus Syrien, sie haben nun mal eine andere Hautfarbe. Menschen, die superreich sind, nehme ich gerne wieder auf, in meinem Kreis des Menschseins, wenn sie ihr Superreichtum ablegen. Also sie haben es mit einer Eigenschaft zu tun, die sie zu Paraziten macht oder sie in ein parasitäres Verhältnis zu unserer Gesellschaft setzt, dass sie abstreifen können. Und das eröffnet politische Möglichkeiten, weil wir dann die Frage haben, wenn sie es komplett abstreifen können. Also jeder kann einfach sagen, ich verzichte auf mein Vermögen. Das eröffnet Möglichkeiten, politische Räume zu schaffen, um dieses parasitäre Verhältnis, das es nun mal ist, zu gestalten.
Ja, gegen die Beschreibung parasitäres Verhältnis, habe ich das, ich würde nur zur Vorsicht mahnen, wenn wir von Parasiten sprechen, weil das natürlich eine sehr ungute Geschichte hat, dieses Wort, wenn man sich die Nazisprache ansieht, was da mit Parasiten gemeint war. Dass dieses Verhältnis eines ist, das natürlich nur darauf aufbaut, dass man nimmt und nichts gibt, sondern dass man alles, was man abgibt, nur dafür sorgt, dass man die Welt noch verschlechtert. Das ist ja völlig klar. Und deswegen wundere ich mich jetzt ein bisschen, dass du über dieses Buch so begeistert bist und gleichzeitig so ein hartes Vokabular an den Tag legst, weil das ja etwas ist, was Julia Friedrichs gar nicht tut.
Mit Absicht.
Sie versucht ja Folgendes, und das kann ich erst einmal unter Recherche-Bedingungen nachvollziehen. Sie versucht, mit Superreichen ins Gespräch zu kommen. Natürlich kann man da jetzt nicht gleich sozialistisch mit erhobener Faust reinrennen und Klassenkampf brüllen. Dann werden die einem nicht zuhören.
Sie wurde ja auch so ausgeladen. Sie durfte mit dem Wild nicht nach Paris fliegen.
Also die sind schon sehr, wenn man nur mal infrage stellt, dass möglicherweise Erbschaften nicht nur gut sind. Dann ist man ja für die schon eine Figur, die ja im Prinzip für den Kommunismus agitiert. So, da kann ich also verstehen, dass man da Zurückhaltung übt. Was ich nicht verstehen kann, ist, dass Julia Friedrichs so viel Verständnis dann aber irgendwann bereit ist, für die Reichen aufzubringen, dass ich da in deren ganzen Gedankengänge hineingesogen werden soll, wo ich sagen muss, es interessiert mich nicht. Mich interessiert nicht, ob reiche Kinder, also wir reden hier von Leuten, die eine halbe Milliarde oder mehr besetzen oder erben werden, ob die eine schwere Kindheit hatten oder ob die genügend Spielkameraden hatten oder sonst was. Mich interessiert auch nicht, wenn jemand wie Dr. Dr. Dr. Dr. Rainer Zittlmann erzählt, dass die große Diskriminierung heute nicht mehr gegen, weiß ich nicht, wen stattfindet, sondern gegen Superreiche, dass es da einen Klassismus gibt gegen Superreiche. Dann kann ich das mal in einem Absatz aufgreifen und mal kurz hahaha dazu schreiben. Ja, aber ich finde, dass bei aller Redlichkeit, die man auch an den Tag legen muss, wenn man eine solche Recherche macht, die Redlichkeit irgendwann zu einer Umarmung wird. Und das sehe ich hier als ein Problem dieses Buches an, dass seitenweise die wirklich kruden Gedankenwelten von Rainer Zittlmann wiedergegeben werden und nur manchmal dann mit so einem zarten Fragezeichen versehen werden. Da muss ich sagen, ja, das geht so nicht. Also man muss sich nicht auf jeden Humbug einlassen, der da verzapft wird. Man kann auch einfach sagen, das ist großer Müll. Ich gebe hier mal drei Beispiele. Wir haben uns bei Wohlstand für alle auch mit Zittlmann schon mal beschäftigt vor langer Zeit. Aber man muss jetzt dem nicht so nachgehen, als hätte man da wirklich einen intelligenten, wichtigen Gesprächspartner vor sich, sodass man diese Argumentation jetzt mal ganz genau nachvollziehen muss. Es ist jetzt nicht ein Gespräch zwischen einem seriösen Klimaforscher und einem Journalisten, dass man sagen muss, ich will das mal ganz genau wissen, sondern das ist großer Humbug. Und da finde ich, ich glaube, da kann man diesen Begriff mal nennen, so eine false balance drin, dass man plötzlich auch diesen Unsinn so sehr würdigt, dass bei allem Verständnis, das aufgebracht wird, irgendwann das dann dazu führt, dass man sagt, naja, so ein bisschen recht hat Zittlmann vielleicht ja doch.
Ja, du wirst an mir erleben, ich gebe also alle Gefahren, die du siehst, dass hier irgendwas zu viel gewürdigt würde, bei mir null. Das Vorzeichen wird sofort umgedreht. Ich als Leser bin Teil, das ist ja keine Bellettristik, sondern hier geht es ja um nicht ausgedachte Wirklichkeiten, von denen wir vorher so nicht wussten. Zittelmann kannten wir, aber sie hat diesen Sebastian da aufgespürt und befragt mit einer Milliardenerbe. Wie fühlt er sich dabei? Ich gehöre nun auch nicht ins Lager, bei dem Kriegsentscheidend ist für die Bewältigung des Alltags, ob Maxi Hilscher nochmal den Olaf Scholz fragt, wie er sich denn fühlt, während die Ampel den Bach runtergeht. Aber dieses Buch ist ja nicht nur für uns Marxisten und Systemtheoretiker geschrieben, die Lehren daraus ziehen wollen. Wir wollen nicht funktionelle Argumente für eine politische Diskussion gewinnen wollen. Sondern es ist so ein bisschen...
Und da sehe ich aber die Gefahr, also dass das uns, wir können das auf einer anderen Ebene lesen. Das glaube ich sofort. Und ich sage ja nicht am Ende, auch der Zittelmann doch vielleicht ein Prima Kerl.
Aber ist nicht jede Aufmerksamkeit jetzt gut auf diesem Thema?
Ja, grundsätzlich würde ich das unterschreiben wollen. Ja, nur was ich sehe, ist, dass das so sehr ein Friedensangebot an die Reichen ist. Also wisst ihr, manches finde ich so schon schwierig. Und wir müssen mal als Gesellschaft im Ganzen darüber nachdenken. Aber wir wollen euch auch wirklich bitten, man muss schon auch, ich erwarte nicht ein Agitationsbuch. Man muss nicht auf jeder Seite noch mal schreiben, Klassenkampf oder so. Darum geht es mir überhaupt nicht. Aber ich finde, ich muss auch jetzt nicht mir 100 Arten und Wege ausdenken, wie die Reichen doch zur Einsicht kommen, dass das mit einem Milliardenvermögen und drei Privatschätzen nicht so gut ist. Das ist mir scheißegal, wie die das sehen. Da würde ich mit einer Arroganz sagen, das wird jetzt politisch beschlossen. Ob denen das passt und ob die auch eine schwere Kindheit hatten und ob die dann nachher bei Mama im Arm weinen, wenn sie eine Milliarde verlieren, es ist mir scheißegal.
Wir können ja jetzt das Gespräch zum Buch machen, das im Hinterkopf behalten, dein Einwand und danach noch eine Bilanz ziehen. Ob wir jetzt den Eindruck haben, dass wir den Verständnisgang der Autorin mitgegangen sind oder vielleicht gerade nicht?
Vermutlich gerade nicht. Schauen wir mal nach.
So, also was ist Superreichtum? Was ist Reichtum allgemein? Sie beginnen das mal beim Einkommen und das ist sehr wichtig, das mal ganz hart zu unterscheiden, Einkommen und Vermögen. Also in Deutschland macht ja die Bundesregierung einen Armuts- und Reichtungsbericht, in dem wird aufgedröselt, zweifacher, dreifacher Wert über dem normalen Einkommen, median- oder durchnetzten Einkommen, gilt also als reich. Das bedeutet aber, Alleinstehende sind schon bei 3940 Euro netto im Monat oder 5910, nämlich je nachdem, wie das Abstandsmaß dann ist, gelten sie als reich. Die oberen zehn Prozent beim Einkommen beginnen bei 3700 Euro netto. 3700 ist eine Zahl mit zwei Nullen, nicht zehn. Wenn wir von super reichen, damit auch mal so mit zehn, elf Nullen oder sowas. Also wo passt es denn hier nicht? Das ist doch wirklich verrückt. Denn hart unterschieden. Vermögen, die oberen zehn Prozent, 750.000. Wie lange müsste ein Top Ten Verdiener mit 3700 Euro, der ja auch noch lebt, sparen, um in die Top Ten der Vermögen mit 750.000 Euro aufzusteigen? Geht gar nicht. Das mal sich zu verdeutlichen ist sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig. Klare Unterscheidung. Einkommen und Vermögen. Also, man kann ein gutes Leben haben mit einem guten Gehalt. Das heißt aber noch nicht, dass man irgendwo auch nur in Sichtweite von Superreichtum ist.
Ja, und 750.000 Euro Haushaltsvermögen. Du hast gerade gesagt, hört man zu den oberen zehn Prozent. So viel kostet ja inzwischen ein Familienhaus.
Zwei Kinderzimmer.
Nicht überall, aber an sehr, sehr vielen Orten. Das heißt, nur noch die oberen zehn Prozent können also in diese Richtung gelangen. Und damit sehen wir schon mal, dass das Vermögen weg ist. Und dann ist das Vermögen weg.
Also ich meine, es wird dann gezählt.
Das ist dann in der Statistik natürlich drin. Also ein Vermögen in Form von Immobilien ist ein Vermögen. Aber man kann nicht sagen, und da habe ich noch ein paar hunderttausend sonst noch übrig für anderes.
Ich habe gestern erst oder heute Morgen so einen sehr lustigen TikTok kurz gesehen. Eine Frau liegt auf dem Sofa und sagt kurz, ich gehe gerade meinem teuersten Hobby nach. Wo denn? Ja, das fand ich sehr gut.
Sehr schön. Dann geht sie auf Olaf Scholz ein. Das Ehepaar Scholz verdiente, bevor Scholz Kanzler war, 30.000 Euro brutto zusammen. Und Scholz hatte aber sich nicht als reich empfunden, sondern irgendwo so in der Mitte. Und wir wissen aber jetzt schon, ach so, man gehört schon nach strenger Schätzung zu den reichen ab 5.900 Euro Netto. Also wir merken, diese Familie Scholz mit ihrem Einkommen ist also schon sehr, sehr reich. Das ist also das oberste Prozent beim Einkommen.
Also die liegen mindestens doppelt über dem dreifachen des normalen, also im sechstfachen. Das ist wirklich viel.
Dann gibt es noch, um das noch gerade abzuschließen, Friedrich Merz, der verdiente dann, als er bei BlackRock Deutschland war, eine Million Euro brutto im Jahr und sagte, ich bin gehobene Mittelschicht. Also der gehört ja dann zu den 0,3 Prozent der Obersten mit seinem Einkommen, wahrscheinlich so in etwa, und sagt aber immer noch gehobene Mittelschicht. Und wir reden aber hier immer noch von Leuten, die reich sind, und wir sind noch dann nicht bei den Superreich.
Genau. Und diese Klammer, also zu unterscheiden zwischen Eigentum und Vermögen, ich habe das dann mal nachgerechnet, wollte man bei einer vierprozentigen jährlichen Rendite, auf diese 5910 Euro Einkommen kommen, aber auf Arbeit verzichten. Wie viel Vermögen bräuchte man? So, und das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Also, um das Dreifache des in Deutschland gängigen, normalen Nettoeinkommens zu bekommen, bei einer vierprozentigen Rendite, was nicht sehr ambitioniert ist, reichen 1,8 Millionen Euro Vermögen. Also wenn jemand zwei Millionen Euro Vermögen hat, liegt er allein über die Rendite beim Einkommen und im Top Ten Bereich, nee, im Dreifachen über, also Faktor drei über dem normalen Einkommen und kann ein völlig befreites Leben führen. Von Arbeit befreit, von Sorgen befreit. Kann auch mal eine Rechnung beim Arzt privat bezahlen. Musst jetzt nicht auf die Versicherung zurückgreifen, um schneller dran zu sein, was auch immer. Ja, also mit zwei Millionen geht's schon los. Und wir haben in Deutschland eine Million 200.000 Millionäre. Also Bargeldmillionäre. Klar, wir haben dann noch diese Hauspreisgeschichten. Das wird jetzt erst durch die Vererbung liquidiert oder wie auch immer. Da sieht man mal, wie viel Geld da noch vorhanden ist. Also Einkommen spielt in Deutschland so fast gar keine Rolle mehr. Sie beschreibt ja auch, der Gini-Koeffizient beim Einkommen liegt bei 0,3 und beim Vermögen 0,8. Also das sind spektakuläre eigentlich nur in Afrika oder in Amerika. Also in der USA anzutreffenden Verbürgungsverteilung, wo einfach einem alles und dem Rest quasi nichts grob grundet.
Und das muss man sich noch mal ganz klar machen für alle folgenden politischen Debatten. Denn wir haben in der Politik fast immer nur Diskussionen über Einkommen und Einkommensbesteuerung. Das ist auch ein Thema, ja. Aber wir sehen gerade, da sind die Lohnabstände gar nicht so riesig. Also man kann zu den Top Ten schon gehören, wenn man dann doppelt ist oder beim Dreifachen des Durchschnittslohns. Aber das sind alles noch Berufe, die man so auf der Straße trifft.
Genau.
Also das ist nicht irgendwie eine ferne Welt. Wir haben ja noch nie jemanden gesehen, der so viel verdient. Sondern das trifft man. Die Leute kann man treffen, wenn man zum Beispiel zum Arzt geht oder wenn man an eine Universität geht und dort Professoren trifft. Sehr viele im Bereich IT und so. Diese Gelder werden also bezahlt. Das ist aber nicht das große Thema dieses Buchs, sondern es geht ja um die Superreichen. Und da fängt es eben an, wo wir über dieses Vermögen sprechen, das einfach so da ist und das genau solche Einkommen in vielfacher Höhe monatlich generiert, ohne dass jemand arbeiten muss. Und sie macht noch mal so eine Unterscheidung, die ich auch da gut finde. Ich will schon unterschreiben, dass das Buch seine Relevanz hatte und auch gerade zu Beginn sehr, sehr gut angelegt ist, weil sie noch mal sagt, was ist eigentlich so als komfortable Mittelschicht zu begreifen? Und da sagt sie, ja, das sähe ungefähr so aus. Man lebt in einer Wohnung oder in einem kleinen Haus, das über einen Kredit finanziert ist. Dazu gibt es etwas Erspartes, vielleicht auch Aktien. Man könnte es sich leisten, einmal in der Woche auswärts essen zu gehen, nicht in Imbissketten, sondern Restaurants zu Hause, stünde ein breites Angebot an Streaming-Diensten bereit. Auch ein Haustier ist möglich. Alle paar Jahre ein neues Auto, zwei Urlaube im Jahr, bei Bedarf eine Putzkraft. Dann gibt es die wohlhabende Mittelschicht. Die hat noch zusätzliche Autos, die hat vielleicht noch zwei Ferienwohnungen und die hat auch schon Personal. Also da sind schon Leute, nicht einmal die Woche vorbei und putzt, sondern da sind dauerhaft Leute da. Und dann gibt es die Superreichen. Und dann sagt sie erst mal, da sind keine Daten da. Da wissen wir gar nichts.
Und warum sind da keine Daten?
Die Bundesbank schätzt das private Vermögen auf 8 Billionen Euro. Dazu kommen dann Immobilien im Wert von 9 Billionen Euro. Und auch nochmal Unternehmen, die auch ihren Wert haben. Und da sind wir also in einem ganz anderen Reich angelangt.
Sie sagt ja hier, mein Buch handelt von Menschen, die sehr viel Geld haben. Nicht lauwarme 25 Grad, sondern näher an den 100, also Millionen, Crazy Rich. 100 Millionen, man kann ja jetzt meine Rechnung nochmal machen. Also bei 2 Millionen und 4 Prozent. Was ist jetzt mit 200 Millionen und 12 Prozent Rendite? Dann hast du pro Monat mehrere 100.000 Euro, die dir einfach zufließen. Millionen Erträge im Jahr. Du kannst hier jede Woche einen Lamborghini kaufen, weil es dich nicht stört. Du musst nur fünf Tage warten und er ist wieder eingespielt. Und zwar als Automatismus. Das kommt mir zum Beispiel im Buch ein bisschen zu kurz. Sie betonen zwar immer wieder, fragt ja auch diesen Sebastian, aber wir unterscheiden Arbeit und Kapital. Ich würde sagen Arbeit und Automatismus. Man muss immer Arbeit und Automatismus. Manche Menschen müssen einfach gar nichts machen. Und wir besprechen nachher auch, für was sie sich eigentlich noch interessieren. Und wir denken so, naja, die wollen ja gerne Lobbyismus machen oder haben gerne hohe Rendite. Nee, die interessiert nicht mal das. Also das ist so der Poente im Verlauf.
Das wird delegiert.
Genau. Man hat Leute, die machen da Leistungssport. Das eine Family Office gegen das andere. Womit? Keine Ahnung. Sie nennt mehrere Personen, die für uns wirklich relevant sind. Andreas Bornefeld ist ein Nerd im allerbesten Sinne. Er macht nämlich seit 35 Jahren aus privater Leidenschaft so eine Datensammlung über Superreiche. Ist natürlich für sie gleich ein erster Gesprächspartner, um einen Gesprächspartner zu finden. Dass da jemand einfach so dasitzt und das macht, finde ich schon grotesk. Man stört ja vielleicht auch die ein oder andere Sache mal auf und kriegt dann Ärger oder so. Man weiß ja immer nicht, diese Leute werden kein Budget haben, aber mal was nicht wollen. Wie zum Beispiel der Bofrost-Gründer Josef Bokui, der dann einfach sagt, ich will in diesen Listen nicht auftauchen. Das Manager-Magazin soll das mal schön ohne mich machen. Wir wissen also wirklich gar nichts, außer von privaten Initiativen. Sie schreibt dann die Einkommens- und Verbraucherstichprobe, kennt keine Superreichen. Der Soziögonomische Panel kennt keine Superreichen. Dem DIW ist mal eine Studie gelungen, mit Vermögenden bis 250 Millionen Euro. Der Bundesbank-Datensatz zur Langzeitstudie private Haushalte und ihre Finanzen, so langsam tauchen da Millionäre auf. Und sehr interessant, sie zitiert Monika Spitzer, die als wirtschaftsweise sehr viel Kontakt zur Politik hat und die dann in einem Zeitungsinterview gesagt hat, wir haben die Daten schlichtweg nicht, wir sprechen es in jedem Gespräch im Finanzministerium an, wir sprechen es jedes Mal im Bundeskanzleramt an, aber an der Stelle scheitern wir einfach mit Daten. Die Wirtschaftsweisen, die unsere Prognose machen über Wirtschaftswachstum, auf die Kommastelle genau und in einem Jahr und so weiter, haben keine Ahnung davon über die Mehrheit des Geldes, das in Deutschland. Wie auch immer, sie wissen es ja nicht, ist es irgendwo investiert, wird es grad konsumiert, ist es im Ausland, was auch immer. Sie wissen es einfach nicht und das finde ich, das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Man hat dann durch diese Initiativen, also in dem Falle das Netzwerk Steuergerechtigkeit und die Hans-Böckler-Stiftung mal nachgeschaut, wie die Milliardenvermögen so sind, plötzlich stellt sich heraus, es gibt 500 Milliarden Euro mehr. Zehn Prozent davon gehört einer Familie. Man hatte das einfach übersehen, dass hinter dem Pharmaunternehmen Boehringer Ingelheim eine Familie steckt, die 50 Milliarden Euro Vermögen hat. Was, oh Wunder, es wäre ja der Spitzenplatz in diesen deutschen Listen. Tauchte bisher nicht auf. Das ist einfach Cortes. Das ist so, als würde man plötzlich, ah so, nee, Leverkusen ist doch nicht Deutscher Meister. Wir haben völlig übersehen, dass in Cottbus ja auch noch 12 Fußballspieler, die jeder 30 Millionen kosten und so spielen. Und die schlagen natürlich Leverkusen so. Also man kann sich das, es gibt dafür keine Metaphern, keine Illustration. Es ist völlig bescheuert und unklar, wie sowas passieren kann.
Zumal wir wissen, wie gut die anderen Vermögen im Blick sind. Wenn es zum Beispiel um sowas geht, wie die Eltern kommen ins Altenheim und dann wird geprüft, was muss jetzt das Kind dazu beitragen. Da kannst du nicht sagen, was geht sie das an, das ich verdiene und mache und tue.
Die Bedarfsgemeinschaft. Ach so. Sie leben jetzt zweimal die Woche beim Ernst in der Wohnung. Ja, dann können sie ja seine Zahnpaste benutzen. Wir streichen ihnen drei Euro. So. Das ist ja die Hartz-IV-Gesetzgebung, ne? Ja, alles genau begutachtet.
4.000 Haushalte, die ein Vermögen von geschätzten 1,4 Billionen Euro haben und dreimal so viel wie der gesamte Bundeshaushalt sind vorhanden.
Ja, die reichsten zehn Prozent besitzen zwei Drittel von allem. Das oberste eine Prozent schnappt sich ein Drittel davon. Das oberste ein Prozent und ich würde jetzt sagen, in dieser durchökonomisierten Welt, in der wir ein Buch nach dem anderen bekommen zur Finanzialisierung von allem und so weiter und so fort. Diese 29 Prozent sind schicksalshaft für alle. Bei der Frage, kann sich vor wem noch finanzieren, ja oder nein, ist einfach entscheidend, ja, wird die Familie Piech, Porsche da jetzt was bezahlen oder nicht? Wie viel Geld haben die eigentlich? Wer ist jetzt hier in Verantwortung zu ziehen? Werke müssen geschlossen werden. Nirgendwo wurde das irgendwie diskutiert. Diese Familien sind einfach völlig außen vor, aber ein Prozent der Familien kontrollieren 29 Prozent des vollständigen Vermögens Deutschlands. Und da muss man ja noch sagen, es sind die relevanten 29 Prozent, nämlich die, die eben nicht verkonsumiert werden, sondern die von Investitionsoffensive zur Gelegenheit wie auch immer hin und her wandern und da versuchen, Chancen zu nutzen. Und wir sind völlig blind, es interessiert niemanden und es wird vor allem nicht mit der Öffentlichkeit darüber gesprochen. Die ärmere Hälfte kommt auf ein bis drei Prozent. Ja, die ärmere Hälfte. Also dieser Genie-Kooffizient von 0,8 beim Vermögen in Deutschland, das ist einfach, und sie sagt auch spektakulär, das ist einfach grotesk.
Die haben nichts oder sind verschuldet.
Also es ist wirklich schlimm, sie hat hier verschiedene Modi uns das darzustellen, Abstandsmaße, die sie immer sehr gut findet, weil die immer die Ärmeren mit ins Bild holt.
Ja, vielleicht können wir da mal ein Zitat bringen. Anfang der 1990er-Jahre war das mittlere Vermögen der reichsten 10% 50 mal höher als das der ärmeren Hälfte. Mittlerweile ist es das hundertfache. Was vor allem daran liegt, dass das Vermögen der Ärmeren trotz aller Wohlstandsgewinne, trotz einer über viele Jahre boomenden Wirtschaft, so gut wie gar nicht gewachsen ist. Ich war gestern im Westerwald und hatte dann Vortrag erhalten über Neoliberalismus und über Krisen und neue Allianzen. Jedenfalls habe ich mir das doch mal so angesehen, wie hat sich eigentlich Ducks und Dow Jones entwickelt. Und es geht so steil nach oben. Also man hat dann von Anfang der 90er Jahre bis heute 950 Prozent. Und du weißt sofort, wo das landet. Und ich habe dann drei Bilder noch gezeigt. Es gibt diesen Film Der Vater, der braut. Da hast du vielleicht mal von gehört. Den gibt es in den 50er Jahren. Da ist dieser Vater auch schon relativ vermögend, ein schönes Haus. In den 90er Jahren gibt es ein Remake. Da ist das schon ein Anwesen. Jetzt gibt es 21 nochmal ein Remake. Und jetzt hat dieser Vater eine Superjacht. Und es zeigt genau diese Entwicklung. Und bei den anderen konnte sich kein Vermögen ansparen. Welcher Diskurs ist aber jetzt da? Die Armen sind so arm, weil die gar nicht in Aktien investiert haben. Und die Sache ist nur, ja, du kannst aber nur in Aktien investieren, wenn dein Lohn entsprechend hoch ist. Das hast du ja nicht mal davon abgesehen, dass du ja da am Ast 6 auf dem du sitzt, aber du brauchst ja Geld übrig. Du kannst ja nicht mit 30 Euro ETF sparen, irgendetwas Großes ändern.
Ja genau, also ich will die Zahlen ja nochmal nennen und ich trage sie ganz langsam vor. Wir müssen sie richtig in uns reinprogrammieren. Du hast jetzt gesagt, 10 Verzehnfachungen der Aktienwerte. Diese Verzehnfachungen entfielen auf diejenigen, die Aktien halten. Das sind zur Hälfte 141 Familien in Deutschland. 141 Familien von 40 Millionen Haushalten kassieren dieses steigende Aktienvermögen.
Also das muss man sich merken, wenn jetzt die nächste Sendung mit Lanz ist. Und es geht darum, dass man Unternehmen stärker besteuern will oder dass die nicht Arbeitsplätze wegkürzen sollen. Und dann sitzt da Jan von Aaken und sagt das. Und Lanz sagt dann, ja, aber denken Sie doch auch an die vielen kleinen Aktionäre in Deutschland. Ja, no, es gibt keine kleinen Aktionäre. Diese kleinen Aktionäre sind nicht der Rede wert. Es sind diese 183.
Sie zitiert hier eine Studie von Mai Chi Dao. Die hat Wealth, Inequality and Private Savings. The case of Germany. Also ist wirklich auf uns jetzt gemützt. Die Zahlen sind imposant. 60 Prozent der Unternehmenswerte und Gewinne entfielen auf Firmen, die direkt von einzelnen Eigentümern, oft Familiendynastien gehalten wurden. Also 60 Prozent entzieht sich erst mal komplett dem Markt. Das sind einfach einzelne Leute, die sagen, wie der Fürst damals, der Zehnte gehört mir. So, alles kommt zu mir. So, bleiben also noch 40 Prozent übrig. Und selbst von den übrigen 40 Prozent der Unternehmen, die bürsennotiert sein, würden erstaunliche zwei Drittel von einer einzigen Familie kontrollieren. Also hier muss man niemanden in Schutz nehmen. Der einfache Anleger, der dann von dieser Anlagenschutz und der Tenhagen oder wie er heißt, spielt keine Rolle. Das sind arme Leute, die haben hier in diesem Bild keinen Platz. Es geht hier um die Top 60 Prozent, weil das sind einfach, da kann man die Namen auf eine oder vier Zettel schreiben. Das sind halt die Familien, denen es gehört. Und von den restlichen 40 Prozent entfällt zwei Drittel auf eine einzige Familie. Um die geht es. Also um 142 Familien, sag ich mal so. Irgendwie so grob, dass man es kann. Das heißt, es sind immer noch 40 Millionen Haushalte offen, die dem ausgeliefert sind, in diesem Zustand. Und dann ist die Frage, was bedeutet das? Sowohl was die ökologischen Grundlagen, über die wir diskutieren, als auch Demokratie. Ist die Demokratie bedroht, weil in Erfurt jetzt irgendwie 30 Prozent AfD, natürlich ist sie da bedroht. Aber wie kam es denn dazu? Wenn man solche Bücher liest, denkt man sich immer, ja, kein Wunder, dass die Journalisten auf ihre Fragen keine Antworten bekommen, die irgendwen, weil das sind halt nicht die Antworten. Man muss halt andere Fragen stellen. Da bekommt man auch Antworten, wo klar ist. Weil dann kann man sich ja wirklich mal fragen, was machen diese Superreichen mit diesem Geld? Sie haben es der Demokratie entzogen. Was machen jetzt damit? Und das, finde ich, steht in diesem Buch gut drin. Also da kann man jetzt einsteigen. Wir haben jetzt die Superjachten mit Taffa abgeräumt. Wir haben das Vermögen einmal verteilt. Bleiben, können jetzt hier einschwenken auf ihren Tenor. Ich kann nicht fassen, dass wir, wenn es um großen Reichtum geht, die banalsten Fragen nicht sicher beantworten können. Und dann dröselt sie die sozialen Fragen, die sich ergeben, auf. Also in Deutschland 3.300 Superreiche, 23 Prozent des Finanzvermögens in deren Händen, beim Anlagevermögen noch viel mehr. Denen gehört einfach alles. Was machen wir jetzt damit?
Man könnte mal mit jemandem reden.
Hans-Peter Wild zum Beispiel.
Mit Hans-Peter Wild oder mit Sebastian.
Oder mit Sebastian. Alles erst mit Hans-Peter Wild, weil der wird ja auch aus dem Film.
Wir beschreiben noch mal kurz, wer das eigentlich ist.
Sie zitiert es noch mal. Der hat damals die Capri-Sonne erfunden. Das Getränk hatte er schon von seinem Vater als Firma übernommen. Und dann hat er gesagt, ich fände es eigentlich cool, wenn Kinder, nachdem sie es ausgedrungen haben, da draufspringen und es hat ihm drei Milliarden verschafft. Die Kinder sehen das im Supermarkt und sagen, das glitzert. Ich hätte das gerne auch beim Kindergeburtstag. Wir denken immer, man muss irgendwas super krass Cooles machen. Nein, eine völlig banale, bescheuerte Idee, aber halt marketingtechnisch einfach platziert. Also sich wirklich aggressiv in die Supermärkte rein. Es muss gleich da vorne stehen. Capri-Sonne, Marke, fertig. Und er wird dann von ihr gefragt, sieht man ja dann auch im Film. Was ist das jetzt mit diesem Sie haben da drei Milliarden und so weiter? Das ist eine akademische Frage, die stellt sich mir nicht, ob man hier Verteilungsprobleme hat. Das sei ungefähr so sinnvoll, wie die Tatsache nachzugehen, warum er nur drei Milliarden habe, Chef Bezos aber 300 so ungefähr. Das ist so seine Antwort.
Ja, das zieht sich ja durch das Buch hindurch, dass sehr viele Reiche sich immer dann mit vielen reicheren vergleichen und am Ende auch armen wie eine Kirchenmaus eigentlich sind, wenn man es mal genau sieht. Und das ist erstaunlich. Also diese Befreiung, die der Reichtum ja verspricht, ist bei den Leuten ja nicht gegeben. Also es ist ja immer noch so ein Wettbewerb, immer noch ein Schielen, wie weit kann man es bringen. Also das, was so als Ellenbogen Gesellschaft beschrieben wird, das zieht sich also auch dann noch durch, wenn man von wirklich allem befreit sind. Also es gibt keine Möglichkeit mehr, sein Vermögen zu verlieren. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit mehr, es relevant auszugeben. Und doch ist die ganze Zeit noch der Blick zum Nachbarn da. Wer hat die größte Yacht?
Und dafür hat sie ja diesen tollen Gesprächspartner Sebastian, der das ja aufdröselt. Ob er sich noch mal irgendwann irgendwo ökonomisch unsicher fühlt oder so? Nö, sagt er einfach. Kenne ich nicht. Also für mich ist das immer grenzenlos. Das materielle Denken war für mich immer grenzenlos. Und sie fragt ihn eben auch, ist dein Vermögen schnell gewachsen? Und er sagt, ja. Und der Maßstab dafür ist, die Lohnzuwächse und die Inflation. Ja, mein Vermögen ist schneller gewachsen. Selbst 10 Prozent Inflation oder so. Also mein Vermögen ist schneller gewachsen. Also einfach unendliche Ressourcen.
Stellen wir mit einem Wort Sebastian vor. Das ist der Gesprächspartner, der am meisten sich öffnet gegenüber Julia Friedrichs. Er besucht sie sogar in ihrer Wohnung. Wir erfahren nicht mehr über Sebastian, also über seinen eigentlichen Hintergrund, aus welcher Familie er genau stammt, woher das Geld genau kommt. Aber wir bekommen sicherlich etwas Verfremde, damit man ihn nicht erkennen kann, damit man keine Rückschlüsse ziehen kann. Doch ein Einblick in eine Welt, die davon geprägt ist, dass seine Familie so immens reich ist, dass man einfach wie auf einem Spielplatz im Garten Klettergerüste baut, den ganzen Kindergarten oder die Schule dazu einladen kann. Es ist immer Personal vorhanden. Also es kommt einfach alles, was man haben möchte, fertig aus der Küche heraus. Nie gab es irgendetwas, was man selbst machen musste. Und dieser Sebastian ist ganz bemerkenswert, deshalb weil er sagt, bei mir ist es reines Erbe, Glück. Reines Glück in der Geburtenlotterie. Er sagt also nicht, ich bin ein genialer Unternehmer und ich habe das aber auch noch verdient, denn ich habe ja so eine Capri-Sonne erfunden. Sondern er ist derjenige, der sagt, es ist ein Überfülle da, es war schon immer da und es vermehrt sich weiter. Und für ihn ist die Frage, wie geht er damit um? Und das zieht sich jetzt durch das ganze Buch, diese Figur. Julia Friedrichs unterhält sich mit ihm über seine Kindheit und über seinen Wunsch, einer von vielen sein zu wollen, weil er natürlich bei all der Offenheit, die die Familie auch an den Tag legte und er ging auf eine öffentliche Schule, immer das Problem hatte, dass irgendwann doch über Geld gesprochen wird. Und er selbst versucht jetzt, dem zu entkommen, nicht in dem Sinne, dass er das jetzt alles verschenkt. Das könnte er ja interessanterweise auch machen. Die Frage kommt ja nicht.
Dann hätte er wahrscheinlich Probleme mit der Familie.
Dann hätte er Probleme mit der Familie. Er bleibt also in diesem ganzen Konstrukt drin, lebt aber für sich privat, ja fast minimalistisch. Also wenn er verreist, geht er ins 3-Sterne-Hotel, fährt mit der Bahn. Ja, lebt also wie jemand, der jetzt vielleicht so zu den oberen 20% der Einkommensklasse gehört. Aber trotzdem vermehrt sich sein Vermögen fortwährend.
Hier würde ich ja einen Film oder so würde sich anbieten. Ja, so unter dem Tenor Milliardär ist er schon. Jetzt will er gerne noch Selfmade werden. Er ist auf der Suche. Er hat ja normal studiert. Witzige Szene, wie dann eine Kommilitonin ihn fragt, ob er einen Anwalt kenne, weil sie irgendeine Frage klären will. Und er sagt, nimm doch einen Familienanwalt. Also bis ins Studium hinein, genau, bis ins Studium hinein, versteht er einfach, also kann sich das gar nicht vorstellen, dass ja andere anders leben. Ich finde es auch immer wieder erstaunlich. Hier in Frankfurt ja auch Geschichten von Menschen, die mit Milliardären zu tun haben, die dann so Sprüche hören wie, stell doch mal ein paar Möbel da rein. Und man denkt sich so dann aus der anderen Richtung, nee, ich kann da nicht ein paar Möbel reinstellen, weil für mich ist das nicht ein Zuruf, sondern ich brauche dann Möbel, dann muss ich die da hochtragen, dann stehen die da fünf Minuten, damit jemand ein Foto macht und dann muss ich sie wieder loswerden. Das geht einfach gar nicht, aber diese, stell doch mal ein paar Möbel rein. Also solche Sachen, die sind dann irgendwie, da sieht man dann, dass wirklich anders gedacht wird. Der Zugriff auf die Welt, auf das eigene Schicksal, ist einfach ein anderer. Ressourcengrenzen gibt es nicht. Das ist ja dann beim Sebastian besonders eindrücklich, wenn er das so erklärt, wie er sich da auch fühlt. Deswegen finde ich das schon nicht unbedeutend, da mal diesem Gefühlshaushalt nachzugehen und das eben in diesen Möglichkeiten des Kischengesprächs auch mal zu thematisieren.
Ja, wobei ich es fast lieber als Roman, glaube ich, gelesen hätte. Also nicht im Sinne von, ich brauche viel Fiktion. Aber eigentlich ist das eine interessante Idee, dass man da so einer Figur folgt, die immens reich ist, die aber eigentlich verschwinden möchte oder einer von vielen sein möchte und deshalb ein gewöhnliches Leben lebt. Also gewöhnlich in dem Sinne, also das tut, was Normalverdiener oder ein bisschen besser, sagen wir, Besserverdienende so machen würden. Man macht einen Urlaub mit den Kumpels, mit dem Fahrrad und man kann auch mal die Leute zum Essen einladen, mal mehr, dann auch nicht. Ja, also man lebt so, dass es nicht auffällt, dass man reich ist. Keine Markenklamotten, nichts dergleichen trägt er. Und das ist ja so ein Selbstversuch, der da unternommen wird. Der sagt mir ja nichts über Ungleichheitsverhältnisse weiter, aber als Lebensentwurf ist es zunächst mal interessant zu sagen, ich gehe da raus, weil wir ihr jetzt sagen würden, gut, also wenn man sich ein Vier-Sterne-Hotel leisten kann, dann geht man vielleicht doch lieber nicht in ein Drei-Sterne-Hotel. Und er kann sich aber jetzt das Grand Hotel leisten und er könnte auch gleich sagen, wir kaufen das Grand Hotel. Und er legt sich aber ins Drei-Sterne-Hotel. Das ist also so ein Selbstexperiment. Eigentlich wird das da zu so einer Survival-Angelegenheit, die er sich selbst auferlegt. Wahrscheinlich auch, wenn diese Überfülle derart da ist, dass man einen gewissen Sinnverlust spürt oder eine Sinnlehre spürt und jetzt versucht so was Sinnstiftendes zu machen, dass also das Leben wieder zu einer Challenge wird, wo es eigentlich keine Challenges mehr gibt. Man kann jederzeit jemand anrufen und sagen, mach mal, bring mir mal Möbel her, flieg mich mal da und dorthin.
Ich habe Hunger.
Der kann ja mit der Senfte abgeholt werden.
Im Grunde leben die alle wie 7-Jährige, ist mir aufgefallen. Denn 7-Jährige sitzen am Tisch und sagen, Papa, kannst du mir Trinken geben? Und dann fragt man zurück, was möchtest du denn? Und dann sagt er, Traubenschorle. Und dann bringt man sie ihm. Ja.
Und wir sind keine...
Papa, ich will ins Schwimmbad. Ja. Dann ist es automatisch implizit, dass natürlich die Eltern sich um Beförderung eintritt und alles kümmern. Ja.
Du hast vielleicht diese Sendung White Lotus gesehen. In diesem Lotus-Ressort. Die ist sehr schön. Die beginnt damit, dass der Chef-Hotelier dieses Ressorts seiner neuen Angestellten sagt, als diese Superreichen dann so da ankommen, oder das noch keine Superreichen, aber reiche Leute, um dort dann ihren Urlaub zu verleben, pass auf, behandelt sie einfach wie kleine Kinder. Das ist die Anweisung, die die neue Angestellte bekommt, behandelt sie einfach wie kleine Kinder. Und das ist ja auch der Reiz, den beschreibt Julia Friedrichs auch manchmal, den wir alle auch nachvollziehen können. Also wenn wir irgendwo einen guten Service erleben oder erleben wollen, dass wir eigentlich so in einer kindlichen Position da sind, so mach mal für mich. Und das ist ja diese große Entlastung. Und ich habe das ja auch bei mir sehr stark. Zum Beispiel werden ja auch Kinder irgendwo hingefahren, wie du weißt. Du musst dann, gut du hast kein Auto, weil Kinder werden ja viel durch die Gegend gefahren, um zum Sport oder sonst was zu können. Und ich genieße das natürlich auch, wenn ich in einer Stadt bin, wo ich mich nicht auskenne, mich nicht so genau orientieren muss und sagen, ich gehe jetzt in ein Taxi und das fährt mich jetzt wie so ein kleines Kind dahin.
Aber sie sagt ja hier ausdrücklich, eine Superjacht ist eine Privatsphäre in Hölle, weil da hocken einfach alle sehr eng aufeinander. Da streitet man sich nicht in der 180-Grad-Lounge und kann es vor seinem Personal verbergen. Nein. So. Gleichzeitig werden wir dieses Personal tatsächlich wie so ein, die Eltern kümmern sich halt um alles. Also Leute rufen beim Family-Office an, weil die Zigaretten alles sind. Und so, ja. Also solche Sachen, das, man, ich weiß noch, wie ich darüber gesprochen habe, als ich in Berlin im Adland war. Ich habe mich darüber lustig gemacht. Man schleppt seinen Koffer vom Bahnhof dahin und so weiter. Das ist alles wahnsinnig anstrengend. Man geht zu Fuß, weil, und so, es sind ja Fußwege.
Die Leute, die da sonst logieren, haben schon für.
Genau. Und dann kommt man da an und es sind zwei Stufen ins Hotel und drei Leute fragen einen, ob sie einem helfen können. Und man denkt sich so, sehe ich so aus? Sehe ich so aus, als bräuchte ich jetzt gerade eure Hilfe für mein 3-Kilo-Koffer, die zwei Treppenstufen? Nein, ich möchte gerne als erwachsene Person da begrüßt werden. Ja, und hier sehe ich so gewisse Gepaaren. Sie sagt ja auch, sie kommt aus diesem Demütigen nicht raus. Sobald sie mit einem Milliardär zu tun hat, am Telefon, im Gespräch, wie auch immer, sind das besondere Interviews. Man hat so ein devotes Verhalten irgendwie.
Und ich würde auch sagen, dass sie bis zum Schluss nicht ganz da rauskommt.
Ja, und das ist doch schrecklich eigentlich.
Das ist so eine merkwürdige Tonalität.
Also schrecklich für die Milliardäre, meine ich.
Ja, und ich finde es merkwürdig, dass sie so eine kluge, renommierte Frau ist. Sie muss ja jetzt nicht erst mal ein paar Meriten verdienen. Und deshalb verstehe ich nicht, warum man nicht dann doch irgendwann, also ich kann diese Anfangshaltung ja verstehen. Und wenn ich jetzt heute Nachmittag noch ein Treffen hätte mit jemanden, wo ich weiß, der ist Milliardär und ich würde zum ersten Mal auf dem Begegen würde ich auch denken, wie wird das so sein? Das ist jetzt ein bisschen anders, wenn ich sage, ich treffe mich heute Abend noch mit jemandem, der Lehrer ist. Dann würde ich sagen, ja, kenne ich schon. Habe ich schon ein paar Mal Leute getroffen, die im Beamt sind. So, weiß ich nicht. Jedenfalls ist es dann doch irgendwann der Punkt, wo man sagen muss, ja, die sind eigentlich wie Kinder und die sind auch nicht besonders genial. Also man kann ja eine Ehrfurcht haben vor Leuten, die wahnsinnig brillant sind. Aber das haben wir hier nicht. Wir haben es hier mit Leuten zu tun, die entweder erben oder irgendwann mal eine Capri-Sonne erfunden haben. Es sind ja keine Leute, die wirklich Großes leisten. Also man hätte ja vor jedem Nobelpreisträger hundertmal mehr Respekt als jetzt vor Leuten, die sagen, ja, ich habe da mal damals in Immobilien günstig investiert und dann bin ich Milliardär geworden.
Der Gedankengang, den sie sich ja nicht zutraut, jedenfalls nicht explizit, ist, ich habe mit diesen Menschen zu tun, sie könnten mir einfach was abgeben, sie würden es nicht merken und eigentlich wünsche ich mir das. Ja, das steckt ja da drin.
Genau, das ist ja auch.
Und das muss man ablegen. Im Kontakt mit Milliardären bitte nicht, nein, die geben dir nichts ab. Warum auch? Also erstens hast du es nicht nötig, also grundsätzlich, also klar, man kann halt immer mehr haben, aber wir haben es jetzt nicht grundsätzlich nötig. So, es sind Leute, die unendlich viel Macht haben und damit Gestaltungsspielraum, obwohl sie nicht genial sind. Das finde ich das Ärgerliche. Ja. Nicht, dass sie so viel Geld haben und ich auch gerne oder sowas, sondern diese Gestaltungsspielraum, obwohl sie nicht genial sind. Und wir haben jetzt einen Wandel in der Debatte. Dadurch, dass Elon Musk, der reichste Mann der Welt, uns zeigt, wie armselig so ein Leben sein kann. Er verbrennt gerade die ganze Welt, weil er nicht drüber hinwegkommt, dass seine Tochter nicht nach seinem Ebenbild aufwächst. Sondern sich einfach sagt, ich hätte erstens gerne ein eigenständiges Leben und zweitens, ich meine damit eigenständig. Du sollst es mir nicht sagen. Und auch die öffentliche Debatte, wie sie läuft. Ich führe ein Leben gegen die Welt so ein bisschen. Ich wandle mein Geschlecht, was auch immer. Und die verkraften es einfach nicht. Also anscheinend scheint er das einfach nicht zu verkraften. Und kommt jetzt mit diesem Vogue-Virus, gegen das er sich wehrt und sieht es einfach überall. Und zündet nicht nur die Welt damit an, sondern er verdirbt sich auch wirklich das eigene Vermögen gerade. Das sind ja wirklich im Zehnerbereich Milliardenwerte, die er da einfach vernichtet dadurch. Und diese Art von Dummheit muss da jetzt eingepreist werden, grundsätzlich. Genialität und Gestaltungsspielraum fällt da auseinander und das ist ein Problem. Zurück zum Sachbuch. Also wenn jemand diese Belletristik dazu schreibt, du würdest sie sofort im Salon vorstellen. Wir würden das dann abprüfen, ob Gefühlichkeit über diesen Weg eine Chance hat bei dir. Zurück zum Sachbuchteil. Die Soziologie kommt hier sehr schlecht weg im Buch und zwar zu Recht. Und namentlich, was ich ja sehr gut finde. Andreas Reckwitz stellt sich besonders heraus, denn er hat ja die Gesellschaft der Singularitäten beschrieben. Und wenn jemand ein singuläres Leben führt, dann ja wohl die singulären Milliardäre, die wir so haben. Er wird dann aber auf Nachfrage im Gespräch mit der Zeit gefragt, warum jetzt Superreichtum, wo ja nun wirklich mal personaler Gestaltungsspielraum und ich lebe mich hier aus, eine Rolle spielt, nicht vorkommt. Und seine Antwort ist, Superreichtum mag zwar unter Gerechtigkeitsaspekten skandalös sein, für die Sozialstruktur der westlichen Gesellschaft, aber sei sie nun wirklich nicht prägend. Und da denke ich mir, no. Wenn hier ein was prägend ist, dann nicht, dass wir gerade das Experiment Demokratie haben, ein Bildungssystem, das so halb funktioniert, wir können uns besser vorstellen, sondern dieser Entzug von Gestaltungsspielraum von Leuten, die sie sich illegitimerweise nehmen. Wenn sie uns darüber aufklären, zu sagen, ihr könnt gerne den Thüringer Landtag bestücken und die können auch Entscheidungen treffen, aber ob da was auch immer ein Opelwerk gebaut hat, entscheide ich. Wenn das transparent wäre, okay. Aber da es nicht nur so ist, wie es ist, sondern auch noch intransparent, kann man echt als Soziologe nicht sagen, dass Superreichtum die Sozialstruktur westlicher Gesellschaften nicht prägt.
Natürlich prägt es das.
Das ist einfach völlig absurd. Also lieber Soziologie.
Frankfurt ist ein Produkt dieses Superreichtums.
Absolut.
Und das kann man in jeder Stadt beobachten. Dass diese unglaublichen Renditen eingefahren werden, die dazu führen, dass man auch ein bisschen Geld verjubeln kann für eine Superjacht, hängt ja zusammen damit, dass wir kaum steigende Löhne in den letzten 30 Jahren hatten. Das ist ja ganz klar. Also das ist das eigentlich Prägende.
Genau. Und ich will noch eine Beobachtung hinterher schieben, die jetzt im Buch nicht so steht, aber die sollte man soziologisch mal für uns, für das allgemeine Publikum mal ausbreiten. Wenn wir Nachrichten bekommen zum Thema, wie geht es eigentlich gerade der Wirtschaft, dann kriegen wir die als Börsenbericht vom Börsenparkett. Und dort werden uns dann Kennziffern genannt, die für uns völlig irrelevant sind. Wie entwickelt sich der DAX? Was kostet ein Liter Öl? Oder wie auch immer. Das sind Kennziffern für die Superreichen. Wie viele Arbeitslosen zahlen? Wie viele Arbeitskräfte hat man dann noch? Wo muss man mobilisieren? Das sind Superreichen-Angelegenheiten. Das muss uns gar nicht interessieren.
die Family Offices. Denn das ist ja auch wieder interessant zu lesen, dass viele sich um gar nichts mehr kümmern. Also dieser Sebastian wird ja beispielsweise gefragt, wie das dann so aussieht mit der Vermögensverwaltung und dieser Familie. Ja, man kommt dann mal zusammen und beschließt so ein bisschen, wohin der Kurs geht.
In Gutsherrenart.
Was möchte man jetzt eigentlich in Zukunft machen? Und dann gibt es die, die das alles betreuen. Also die Family Office-Leute, die warten dann schon auf die Familie. Die kommt jetzt gleich aus diesem Raum und teilt dann mit, in welche Richtung es dann gehen soll. Kann man vielleicht doch mal Investitionen in Richtung Klimatransformation tätigen oder bleiben wir da eher noch zurückhalten? Da einigt man sich so im stillen Kämmerlein und gibt das dann als Anweisung weiter. Wie wenig er aber eigentlich noch daran interessiert ist, überhaupt zu sehen, wie sich sein Vermögen entwickelt, zeigt sich daran, dass Julia Friedrichs ihn fragt, wie oft er denn eigentlich auf sein Konto blickt. Denn das ist ja sowas, was man bei diesen kleinen Aktionären in Bitcoin Bros. und so erleben kann. Die checken ja jeden Tag 70-mal ihr Scalable Capital oder Robinhood Konto. Und er sagt, ein- bis zweimal im Jahr checke ich mein Konto.
Er gibt halt einfach Geld aus und guckt dann mal nach, wie viel es jetzt mehr geworden ist dadurch, dass er so viel Geld ausgegeben hat.
Ja.
Ja, sie zitiert ihn ja auch. Ist es nicht absurd, dass ihr da so viel Einfluss und so weiter? Und man könnte ja auch mal anders investieren. Und er sagt dann, naja, also ich habe für mich schon ermittelt, dass die Anlagestrategie durchaus entscheidend ist. Sie ist aber nun mal komplett losgelöst von allen gesellschaftlichen Aspekten. Einfach nur ein risikogewichtiges, risikogewichtetes Investment. So beschreibt er es. Er hat dann versucht, mit seiner Familie darüber zu reden, dass man ja durchaus mal in Windparks statt in Exxon-Aktien gehen kann. Seine Familie hat dann auch entschieden, die ESG-Kriterien mal so ein bisschen wahrzunehmen. Aber das absurde ist, sagt er, dass ich immer merke, dass es mir selbst und auch einigen der Familienmitgliedern so ziemlich egal ist. Das sind so große Beträge. Die sind investiert. Da arbeiten Leute für uns, um ein, zwei Prozent mehr Rendite zu machen als Vergleichswerte. Und mir und einigen in der Familie scheint es nicht wirklich wichtig.
Punkt.
Während wir uns den Kopf zerbrechen, welcher Aspekt der Diskussion um die öko-emanzipatorische Debatte und so weiter. Da ist einfach egal. Hier entscheiden Leute darüber, ob Werke von Autoherstellern weiter Motoren bauen oder nicht. Ob Kohlekrüben gekramt werden oder nicht.
Ich gehe jetzt nicht mit dir in eine neue Blüthorne-Debatte, auch wenn du das jetzt schon zweimal provoziert hast. Ich will nur deutlich machen, die unteren 50% und auch die unteren 80% und 90% wählen und haben einen Freiheitsentwurf, den man durchaus als öko-emanzipatorisches Projekt bezeichnen kann, wenngleich sie ihn nicht selbst so bezeichnen würden. Und damit einhergeht, dass eine Einschränkung von Freiheit in Bezug auf das Klima, also eine Begrenzung, als einen Freiheitsentzug, stark empfunden wird, was nicht der Realität entsprechen muss, aber so empfunden wird. Und das führt dann sogar dazu, dass man es plötzlich als eine große Einschränkung betrachtet und als eigentlich ein No-Go, wenn zum Beispiel ein Juso-Chef sagt, wir müssen Superjachten verbieten. All die Leute, die sich darüber empören, bei Twitter, bei YouTube und sonst wo, haben keine Superjacht. Denn Leute, die Superjachten haben, kommentieren nicht bei Twitter. Aber sie kämpfen dennoch und sind damit dieser Illusion sehr stark erlegen.
Ja, allerdings, diese Juso-Sachen, also sie schreibt ja so ein bisschen über die Ängste der Superreichen. Die andere große Sorge ist Vermögensverlust durch politische Einflüsse. Sie fragt danach, ja ja, Enteignung. Das Gespenst der Enteignung, irgendeine Vermögensteuer im weitesten Sinne, ganz große Angst. Also das scheint ein flächendeckendes Phänomen zu sein. Was bedeutet, wenn man die Diskussion, die politische Diskussion entsprechend organisiert, sind da durchaus Einflugsschneissen, wo man dann auch mal Widerworte hört. So, also nicht nur von INSM oder wie sie heißen, die dann so eine Plakatkampagne machen oder sowas, sondern dass man mal eine echte Diskussion hat.
Also das ist ja auch so, das wird hier mehrmals bestätigt, dass die den direkten Draht haben. Also wenn die jetzt mit dem Kanzler sprechen wollen, dann wird das möglich gemacht, dass das geschieht und die können mit den einflussreichen Leuten reden und sagen, lasst das. Es gibt zwei Ängste, sagt sie. Das eine ist das Monster unter dem Bett. Also dass man irgendjemanden mit in diese Familie aufnimmt, der dann plötzlich sich als faules Ei entpuppt. Diese Angst ist unglaublich groß. Also ein Misstrauen gegenüber allen Leuten, denen man begegnet. Möglicherweise wollen die an mein Geld oder die Ehe ist nicht eine, die auf Liebe basiert, was auch immer. Und das zweite ist tatsächlich die Politik. Und ich würde sagen, also die Demokratie, dass Leute plötzlich Mehrheiten mobilisieren könnten, bei denen es heißt Vermögensteuer 3 Prozent.
Demokratie ist für sie Bedrohung und sie finden, also gegen die AfD haben sie gar nichts. Die AfD macht ihr politisches Geschäft. Die richten sich gegen alles. Erbschaftssteuer, Vermögensteuer, das wird es mit der AfD nie geben. Also sozusagen, können wir sich auch mal überlegen, wer hat hier eigentlich eine politische Landschaft gestaltet, die für uns alles so unerklärlich ist. Also aus dieser Richtung. Family Offices sind ja so für alles Mögliche zuständig. Auch für die Organisationen von Lobbyvereinen, wie auch immer. Ich will mal diesen kleinen Vergleich machen, jetzt wo wir bei diesen Family Offices sind. Also dieser Idee von jemand kommt in die Familie rein und macht so sein eigenes Geschäft, ohne dass die Familie sich dann da weiter schützen kann. Und das ist ja vor allem, klar, man kann jetzt so heiraten und so was. Oder man übergibt die Verantwortung an einen Family Officer, der einen irgendwie betrügt. Und diese Family Offices sind ja wirklich wahnsinnig interessant. Also ich finde, da sollte man eben grundsätzlich mehr zu forschen und schreiben. Ja. Denn da geht es ja wirklich erst los, wenn ausreichendes Vermögen da ist. Also das Family Office alleine kostet sechs, siebenstellig im Jahr.
Ja, also unter 50 oder 100 Millionen hat man kein Family Office.
Man schmückt sich dann mit exklusiven Family Offices. Also es kümmert sich wirklich nur um eine Familie, um einen Vermögensbestand. Die werden dann relativ eng in die Familie aufgenommen. Sie sagt dann hier, wesentliche Aufgaben sind durchaus mal die Rolle eines Familienpsychologen. Manchmal wird ein Mediator gebraucht. Irgendwer muss Familienregeln manchmal erarbeiten. Das wird dann ausgelagert.
Bisweilen glauben die Kinder, es sei der Onkel, der Vermögensberater sei der Onkel, weil der schon so zur Familie gehört.
Genau. Der war so eng, ich dachte, das ist mein Onkel. Nein, das war nur so ein Angestellter. Sie hat hier einen schönen Widerspruch gemacht zwischen sehr viele superreiche Leute sind superreich und noch reicher geworden, weil sie etwas manifestieren. Sie kommt dann auch mal mit diesem, so wie wir es kennen von Instagram. Die Leute machen sich so Vision Boards, hängen sich das da hin und sagen dann, ich will so und so viele Nullen haben. Und direkt danach kommt ein Textteil zum Thema, das sind Family Officer, die für dieses Gehalt sorgen und nicht die Manifestationen. Und die Strategien sind dann so, wenn man so und so viel Geld hat, in Normalphasen einfach breit investieren und wenn eine Krisensituation kommt, zuschlagen. Und ich will mal eine Krisensituation beschreiben. Zinswende. Die Finanzierung von Wohneigentum ist nicht mehr möglich, weil ein Prozent, drei Prozent heißt halt, das ist gleich mal eine Verdopplung, manchmal von einer Gesamtsumme. Was bedeutet, dass im Gesamtgefüge die Hauspreise plötzlich günstiger werden, weil die Finanzierung so teuer ist für die, die die Finanzierung brauchen? In dem Momenten kommen die Family Officer, die ja Cash bezahlen können und kaufen ganze Straßenzüge. Und einfach alles wegkaufen.
Wo du das gerade sagst, ich hatte kürzlich eine kleine Unterhaltung mit jemandem, der Notar ist und ich fragte, wie das denn am Wohnungsmarkt aussieht. Und dann sagt er, ja, es ist ganz interessant, sie hätten mehrere Bauprojekte betreut, in denen es dann beispielsweise so Wohnviertel gab mit 80 Eigentumswohnungen. Und die waren eigentlich so angelegt, dass sich dann Privatleute jeweils eine Eigentumswohnung leisten können, die dann finanzieren. Dann kam die Zinswende plus Krise und Inflation. Und diese Leute mussten zum großen Teil davon wieder Abstand nehmen. Wenn sie die Verträge unterschrieben hatten, war es ein bisschen schwieriger, aber die sind da raus, weil sie das sich nicht leisten konnten. Und dann sage ich, ja, dann haben wir jetzt diese Leerstände oder was ist da. Dann sagt er nein. Dann kamen Investoren, die haben einfach 80 Wohnungen auf einmal gekauft, weil die das Geld ja cash haben. Und das würde jetzt, also wie hat er es sich ausgedrückt, er hat nicht ungleich gesagt, aber die Spreizung, so nannte er es, in der Gesellschaft extremst verstärken. Und das leuchtet sofort ein, wenn man das hier liest, wie das da eigentlich läuft.
Ja, und sie macht dann zu diesen sozialen Konstruktionen den Vergleich zu Finnland, den ich ja wahnsinnig interessant finde. Also in Finnland hat sie mit Hanna Kusela gesprochen, eine Professorin für Soziologie an der Universität. Spreche ich jetzt nicht aus, 270 Kilometer nördlich von Helsinki. Und die sprach mit 26 Superreichen, weil man die dort einfach im öffentlich einsehbaren Register findet. Ich finde jetzt nicht, dass alle Welt darüber Bescheid wissen muss, aber relevante Stellen, gerade auf Seiten der Finanzverwaltung, könnten doch durchaus mal sagen, wenn die Stadt dieses und jenes städtebauliche Projekt plant und davon ist dieses Grundstück betroffen, können wir zumindest mal sagen, wem es gehört. Ja. Statt einfach nur zu sagen, sorry, da müssen wir drum rumbauen. Das ist für uns unsichtbar. So, es gibt also öffentliche Register, in denen diese Vermögen festgehalten werden. Und jetzt ist es so, dass die Öffentlichkeit dadurch, dass sie weiß, wie die soziale, ich will nicht sagen Schieflage, aber wie die Asymmetrien so sind, kann man darauf reagieren. Was bedeutet, man hat eine andere Sozialstruktur. Öffentliche Schulen, keine privaten. Man muss seine Kinder die öffentliche Schule schicken. Wer der Kinder haben auch Schulpflicht, genauso eine öffentliche Schule. Wenn die Eltern wollen, dass das Kind ein dynastisches Mindset bekommt, soziale Segregation zu dem Alltag gehört, dann obliegt es der Aufgabe der Eltern, das den Kindern anzutrimieren. Aber es gibt keinen Automatismus. Das finde ich wirklich eine bahnbrechende Erkenntnis, wie man auch anders Sozialstruktur organisieren kann. Denn in dem Moment, wo es Aufgabe der Eltern ist, überholte, vormoderne, patriarchische, was auch immer für Modelle in den Köpfen der Kinder zu verankern, müssen sie es halt machen. Brauchen sie halt Kinderbücher von, keine Ahnung, Unser Kinderbuch ist da nicht geöffnet. Eures nicht, sondern das, was ihr geschrieben habt, hier Carsten Maschmeyer und so. Wenn man dann keine Kinderbücher hat von Carsten Maschmeyer, die einem das Mindset den Kindern eintrainieren lassen, hat man es halt nicht. Was eben bedeutet, und das ist ja zunehmend auch ein Problem in Deutschland, schreibt sie, diese Kinder erben heute Gelder, mit denen sie nichts mehr zu tun haben, außer, dass sie es besitzen. Da gibt es keine inhaltliche Verknüpfung, da übernimmt man nicht den Laden des Vaters oder irgendwas, sondern man bekommt einfach Geld. So, und ein dynastisches Mindset muss man auch in Deutschland mittlerweile den Kindern antrainieren, sondern die denken einfach, die gehen raus und heiraten irgendeine Prinzessin. Das geht doch gar nicht. Das muss doch in der Familie bleiben und so weiter und so fort. Also es wird zunehmend schwer, dieses dynastische Prinzip aufrecht zu erhalten. Und ich würde sagen, das verwundert mich. Ich hätte mir das vor 100 Jahren gewünscht, denn mit politischer Macht haben wir es ja auch irgendwann abgeschafft.
Ja, ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob das dynastische Verfahren nicht wieder funktioniert. Gerade deshalb, weil es so viele gated communities gibt. Gerade weil diese Leute sich ja an bestimmten Orten treffen. Also die gehen ja jetzt nicht in Frankfurt in die Bar, in der wir sind.
Da ist aber ein Unterschied.
Die gehen ja nach Monaco. Die lernen ja dort in der Regel, sie verlieben sich ja nicht in die Küchenhilfe, sondern da ist ja einfach die andere reiche Erbin.
Genau, aber wir haben ja einen Sebastian gesehen. Er kann dann nicht am normalen Leben teilnehmen, sondern er muss sich in diese Räume zurückziehen. Er kann nicht mit dem dynastischen Mindset einfach in die Uni gehen und studieren. Diese Verknüpfung geht da nicht. Und diese Segregation fällt dann auch irgendwann einem auf die Füße. Also wir können es nicht in mexikanische Maßstäbe treiben. Zum Beispiel bei öffentlicher Sicherheit dieser Menschen so bedroht ist, dass sie da ständig und dann immer nur noch mit Polizei ist.
Naja, die Tendenz deutet sich an, dass es immer mehr dahin geht. Also man guckt jetzt immer so nach Lateinamerika. Und vielleicht sind das eher auch schon Situationen oder Verhältnisse, die wir in zehn Jahren verstärkt hier haben werden. Also ich halte das für durchaus möglich. Diese Privatisierung läuft immer weiter voran. Dieses Sicherheitsbedürfnis scheint eines zu sein, dass es ein Dauerthema ist. Wir hören ja dann selbst irgendwelche Top-Fußballspieler, die dann sagen, ja, nein, ich würde jetzt mein Kind nicht mehr auf eine öffentliche Schule hier schicken. Das ist ja viel zu gefährlich. Wir bleiben mal lieber in unserer gated community in Spanien. Also in diese Richtung scheint es immer mehr zu gehen. Und deswegen wundert es mich eigentlich so, dass Julia Friedrichs dann Rainer Zittlmann über Dutzende Seiten zu Wort kommen lässt, der so ein Self-Made-Man ist, der in Immobilien investiert hat, darüber sehr reich geworden ist. Auch so eine journalistische Vergangenheit hat einen sehr irre Lebensweg. Mit Peter Gauweiler mal kurz Beratung von ihm bekommen, dann Immobilienseite bei der Welt geleitet, dann über autogenes Training in seinem Unterbewusstsein verankert, dass er zehn Millionen braucht. Das Motiv legt er auch offen. Natürlich wollte er Luxus, aber auch junge Frauen. Da wusste er, dass er das nur über Geld schaffen kann. Mit anderen Worten, so attraktiv ist er nicht. Das muss dann durch Spot-Money kompensiert werden. Er ist also jemand, der ganz viele Bücher geschrieben hat über die Psychologie der Superreichen und vor allem darüber, dass diese Superreichen die ganze Zeit von Neidern umgeben sind. Und auch Julia Friedrichs wirft ja vor, dass sie Neiddebatten immer wieder aufmacht. Und ich würde erst mal sagen, man kann so eine etwas flamboyante Figur natürlich in so ein Buch packen. Und das ist auch mitunter amüsant. Aber es kippt dann da, wo diese wirklich wirrenden Thesen so peinlich genau wiedergegeben werden und immer nur mit so einem Fragezeichen versehen werden, bei dem man denkt, ja, dann wische es doch einfach mal vom Tisch, dass es Unsinn ist. Also du musst ja nicht noch mit dem nach Veröffentlichung des Buches weiter befreundet sein, sage ich mal. Und das kann ich nicht verstehen, warum man nicht da mit einer größeren Härte reingeht und auch mal über den Begriff des NYTs nachdenkt. Also was ist das eine NEID-Debatte? Also sitzen wir hier und sagen, schade, dass wir keine Yacht haben, wir wollen aber eigentlich eine haben und dann neiden wir die. Nein, worum es doch bei diesen Ungleichheitsdebatten geht und auch wenn Philipp Thürmer von den Jusos sagt, ich will, dass es keine Milliardäre gibt, sondern nur noch Millionäre, mehr braucht man nicht. Dann ist das ja keine NEID-Debatte. Eine NEID-Debatte wäre ja, der ist Milliardär, ich will es auch werden. Also ich würde eher denen den Self-Made-Leuten vorwerfen. Ihr seid offenbar neidisch, ihr müsst das auch haben. Also ihr wollt auch die Yacht, nur dann fühlt ihr euch komplett. Wir wollen ja keine Yachten mehr. Also es ist ja gerade kein NEID, sondern NEID ist ja, wenn ich das eigentlich haben möchte, was der andere hat. Das ist ja genau diese Haltung. Warum hat der die schöne Frau, fragt sich Rainer Zittlmann, ich will die auch haben. Also wie kriege ich sie? Ich brauche Geld. Das ist der Diskurs des NEIDs. Aber wenn ich sage, ich brauche eine radikale Umverteilung und diese Superreichen sollte es nicht geben, die werden wir jetzt mal von ihrem Vermögen erlösen, weil sie offenbar selbst ja nicht so glücklich damit sind. Dann ist das keine NEID-Debatte und das, für dich, muss man schon klar mal herausarbeiten. Und das geschieht hier nicht.
Also ich sehe schon, du brauchst hier auf jeden Fall Belletristik.
Ne, ich brauche keine Belletristik an allen Stellen.
Wie dir deine Fragen und vor allem Urteile fällt.
Ich brauche auch keine Urteile auf jeder Seite. Ich verstehe nur nicht, warum gibt man sich diesen Thesen so ausführlich hin, wenn man dann nichts damit macht. Oder ist das eine legitime Position? Und das legt mir das Buch ja nahe, dass es eine legitime Position ist. Die Zittelmann, der ja zudem auch sehr viel rechtes Zeugs verbreitet, was jetzt hier in dem Buch so gut wie gar nicht Erwähnung findet, ist das eine legitime Position, mit der ich mich auseinandersetzen muss? Dann würde ich sagen nein. Und das wundert mich auch, weil du ja doch auch der bist, der sagt, ne, wir lachen jetzt nur noch über die FDP. Wir geben uns jetzt nicht mehr die Blöße zu sagen, ja, wie hat denn der Dürr das jetzt genau gemeint und ist da vielleicht was dran? Nein, da ist nichts dran. Und genauso ist auch bei dem, was der Zittelmann hier verzapft, nichts dran.
Also in diesem Fall würde ich sagen, ich brauche, also ich verstehe den Gedanken, dass eigentlich hier die Letzten, die es noch aus eigener Kraft geschafft haben, es geschafft haben, weil sie so neidisch waren. Also dass nicht die Armen neidisch sind auf die Reichen, sondern die so Halbreichen sind neidisch auf die Superreichen und das treibt sie dann noch mal zu was auch immer. Diesen Blüten, die wir jetzt gerade gesehen haben, diese Zittelmann Biografie ist ja auch ein Durcheinander. Wenn es Spaß macht, würde ich sagen. Aber dafür muss man halt eine bestimmte Person sein. Dass er so sagt, ich will auch im hohen Alter noch Frauen gegenüber attraktiv sein, zeigt er. Er hat sich nie ein festes soziales Netz außer so Freundschaften und die dann wahrscheinlich auf Geben und Nehmen basieren und so weiter aufgebaut, sodass er dann glaubt, er müsste im Alter immer noch auf diese jene Weise attraktiv sein. Aber hier darüber zu lachen, da bin ich natürlich immer einverstanden. Nur das wird ja in dem Buch so ein bisschen ausgeräumt. Also dieser ganze Gedanke, dass es da einen Aufstieggedanken gibt, egal von welchem Niveau zum welchen. Sie hat ja ein Zitat, ich habe diese Zahl schon so lange gesucht, aber ich finde sie nicht, aber 34% der deutschen Superreichen haben es aus eigener Kraft geschafft. Und diese 34% sind auch noch wohlwollend. Also wenn jemand ein Megastartkapital bekommt und dann daraus ein Vermögen aufbaut, gilt das schon als Selfmade. Was ja totaler Quatsch ist. Also wenn man am Anfang Geld hatte, Geld vermehrt sich von alleine, mit welcher Idee man das dann manifestiert. Also es sind alles Erben. Niemand hat es aus eigener Kraft geschafft. Und diese große Lehre, da würde ich jetzt sagen, ja, da, also ich gehe deine Kritik, die grundsätzlich, gehe ich nicht mit, aber an diesem ursprünglichen Parasitengedanken, dass Superreichtum wirklich nur möglich ist und diese großen Pluswerte, diese Vermögenswerte gehen eben mit Minuswerten einher. Nur, Julia Friedrich hat dieses Buch ja geschrieben. Wir haben es ja auch gelesen über die armen...
Working Class.
Working Class, genau, die Ärmeren, die Bahnhöfe putzen, da nicht mal in festen Anstellungen, die haben gar keinen Chef, sondern die kriegen nur von der App gesagt, geh mal morgens rein, mach das weg. Also denen wird nicht nur sozusagen finanzielles Gestaltungsspielraum wird ihnen verwehrt, sondern auch überhaupt gesellschaftliche Teilhabe, mal einen Kollegen haben, mal ein Gespräch führen dürfen, überhaupt mal eine Pause zu haben. Diese Musiklehrer, die von einem Termin zum nächsten und dann kommt Corona und keiner kümmert sich um sie und so. Also ich würde jetzt sagen, ja, man könnte ihr vorwerfen, dass das im Buch zu wenig kommt. Also diese ausgegliederte Seite, wo kommt das Vermögen her? Von wem wird das so parasitär abgezogen? Wer ist eigentlich der Wirt für die? Was ist deren Grundlage? Nur da muss man halt jetzt, würde ich sagen, dann einfach das Gesamtwerk von ihr.
Ja, das würde ich ihr jetzt auch gar nicht vorwerfen wollen. Was ich nicht verstehe, ist, dass man so viel Verständnis für die Reichen aufbringt. Dass man die ganze Zeit sich von Zittlmann nochmal erklären lassen muss, wie schlimm der Neid ist in unserer Gesellschaft. Das kann man ja einmal beschreiben. Oder man muss es, sie arbeitet es ja zum Teil dann heraus, aber dann ist sie wieder sehr vorsichtig. Also sie will sich mit Theo Müller treffen. Theo Müller händigt ihr aber erst mal ein Buch aus, das sie lesen soll, nämlich Die Gemeinwirtschaft von Ludwig von Mises. Und dann liest sie dieses Buch. Natürlich trifft er sich am Ende nicht mit ihr. Und da schreibt sie dann zu, tja und dann sind da die vielen Passagen im Buch, in denen von Mises Menschenbild so gar nicht liberal, so gar nicht freiheitlich wirkt, sondern er vielmehr von einer Art natürlichen Hierarchie, der Menschen schwatroniert. Da warnt er vor der aus seiner Sicht großen Schwäche der Demokratie, dass sie nämlich die Sorgen der weniger Bemittelten zu ernst nehmen, ihre Probleme durch Verteilung von Gütern zu lösen versuchen könnte und so zu etwas degenerieren würde, dass Mises Euchokratie nennt. Das klingt erhaben, ist aber eigentlich eine Beleidigung. Es geht um Pöbelherrschaft, also der Sieg derer, die Mises für dessen nicht würdig erachtet. Und er schreibt, dass die Menschen nicht gleichwertig sind, dass es unter ihnen von Natur aus Führer und Geführte gibt. Daran kann auch durch demokratische Einrichtungen nichts geändert werden. So, sie bringt das sehr gut hier auf den Punkt, worum es von diesem geht und was eine neoliberale Ideologie ist. Ich würde aber sagen, wenn man das ja als Background hat, dann kann man doch bei fast allen dieser Sebastian einmal ausgenommen sehen, dass das diese Haltung ist, dass man also offenbar bei den Superreichen davon ausgeht, dass es eine natürliche Hierarchie in dieser Gesellschaft gibt und dass jeder an dem Platz ist, an den er auch gehört. Und deswegen verbietet sich Umverteilung, weil es eine Ordnung ist, die von Natur, von Gott, von sonst wem so gewollt ist. Und diese zutiefst menschenverachtende und antidemokratische Haltung ist eine, der man jetzt nicht mit großem Respekt begegnen muss, dass man nochmal da genau nachfühlt, wie fühlt sich Rainer Zittlmann und sind wir vielleicht auch ein bisschen hart in unserer Betitelung der Reichen, wenn ein Joso-Chef dies oder das sagt. Da muss ich sagen, ich muss jetzt auch nicht nochmal erfahren, dass Höcke vielleicht ein treu sorgender Familienvater ist oder auch schon mal irgendwo einen klugen Gedanken niedergeschrieben hat. Das ganze Menschenbild an sich ist ein falsches und eines, das verächtigt zu machen ist. Und das, finde ich, müsste sehr klar herausgestellt werden, dass es offenbar eine Klasse von Superreichen gibt, bei der diese Hierarchie entweder explizit oder implizit immer präsent ist.
Ja, aber dadurch, dass sie es ganz deutlich sagt, alle haben geerbt oder fast alle, aber unabhängig davon sehen sich alle legitimiert, dieses Geld zu haben. Außer dieser eine Sebastian. Das wird ja so deutlich und so explizit von ihr und auch mehrfach gesagt, dass ich jetzt gar nicht das Urteil der Autorin, denn sie hat ein Buch geschrieben, das mir das sagt. Das sagt mir einiges.
Na, sie macht ein Fazit. Ich will nicht zum Ende kommen, aber ich will das Fazit nur eine Sache vorwegziehen, um mir jetzt diese Argumentation zu unterstreichen.
Aber bevor du es sagst, dieses Fazit steht wirklich ganz am Ende. Natürlich, wo ein Fazit hingehört. Ich weiß, aber man hat dann schon 350 Seiten Intos.
Aber man muss ein solches Fazit nicht schreiben. Sie zitiert erst den Wirtschaftsjournalisten Felix Rohrbeck. Er sagt in einem privaten Gespräch zu ihr, in der Welt der Vermögenen entsteht schon der Eindruck, die anderen wollen uns quasi auffressen. Und dann zitiert sie auch Eat the Rich und so. Weiter zitiert sie ihn, wir tun uns alle keinen Gefallen, wenn wir Reiche verteufeln, wenn wir einen Klassenkampf führen, in dem Sinne, dass wir keine Vermögenen wollen. Ich kann verstehen, wenn manche Reiche, die nicht etwas nur geerbt, sondern wirklich etwas aufgebaut haben, beklagen, dass die anderen gar nicht sehen, was sie für ihr Land geleistet haben. Also da ist immer so diese Idee, die tun das für ihr Land, nein, die tun das, um ihren Profit zu werden. Und es ist schon markant, dass dieses Zitat auf der vorletzten oder vorvorletzten Seite steht. Und dann schließt sie ja selbst mit den Worten, natürlich schmerzt jemanden, der nur wenig verdient, die Abgabe im Alltag. Also es geht um die Steuerbelastung, die wir so spüren, wir Normalverdienenden. Ja, trotzdem kann ich nachvollziehen, dass Superreiche ihre Steuer dramatischer erscheint, weil es um viele Hunderttausende und Millionen Euro geht. Wo ich immer sagen würde, ja, aber die haben ja auch viele Hunderttausende und Millionen verdient. Dann schreibt sie weiter, wer durch Kunsthallen schlendert oder an Zogehegen vorbei, wer an Universitäten lernt oder auf Sportplätzen kickt, der weiß, dass etliche Vermögen, der es offenkundig attraktiv finden, als Dank für ihre Gabe mit Namen verewigt zu werden. Warum also gönnen wir das nicht auch den eifrigsten Steuerzahlern? Mit einem Dank in der Steuererklärung, einem kleinen Sekt beim Bundespräsidenten oder einer Leitshow, bei dem der Name des Einzelnen kurz auf der Brandenburger Tor und der Kölner Domplatte aufflackert. Warum ergänzen wir die Liste der Reichsten nicht durch eine mit sinnhafteren Kategorien als der bloßen Geldmenge? Wer hat die besten Ideen, wer investiert am meisten? Da muss ich sagen, wir müssen jetzt nicht die wie kleine Kinder an der Hand nehmen und sagen, guck mal, du kriegst auch ein Eis, wenn wir da noch mal ein bisschen nachjustieren dürfen, ein bisschen mehr Steuern verlangen können. Das ist so ein komisches Friedensangebot. Und es ist auch so wahnsinnig verräterisch, dass sie noch mal fragt, wer investiert am meisten. Na ja, Investitionen sind ja kein neutraler Begriff. Also dann bin ich ja bei Markus Lanz. Da sage ich ja, wer Luxusjachten baut und ständig neue kauft, das sind auch Investitionen, schafft Arbeitsplätze. Also darum geht es ja nicht. Also wir müssen doch mal davon weg, dass wir jetzt immer noch sagen, was sind wir denen dankbar? Also das ist für mich nicht nachvollziehbar, dass wenn man gerade so ein Buch geschrieben hat, wo man ja noch mal deutlich aufgeschlüsselt hat für uns, wie diese Family Offices so funktionieren, dass man hier noch von Investitionen groß redet. Da wird da Geld reingesteckt, wo man noch mehr rausbekommt. Und wenn das für irgendein Unsinnsprodukt ist oder für irgendetwas, was die Präkarität noch erhöht, Stichwort, diese ganzen Start-ups, die davon leben, dass Leute für so gut wie kein Geld mit dem Fahrrad irgendwas hin und her fahren, dann hat das nichts mit tollen Investitionen zu tun, die ein Denkmal auf der Domplatte verdienen.
Absolut, dieser Kontrast ist so scharf, weil das Buch vorher so gut ist, eben dieses Friedensangebot zu hinterfragen, von dem immer jeder denkt, ich könnte jetzt einen Milliardär zu meinem Freund haben, ich will mal alles dafür tun, damit es so ist, ich will dem auf keinen Fall auf die Füße treten. So, weil ich lese das Buch unter, also sobald ich einen Milliardär sehe, trete ich dem erstmal auf die Füße. Ja, sei denn du willst was haben. Genau, davon habe ich mich ja schon frei gemacht, aber man muss es halt auch einmal explizieren. Liebe Milliardäre dieser Welt, wenn ihr mich jemals trefft, ich will kein Geld von euch, ich werde euch beschimpfen.
Ja, man kann es ja vielleicht erstmal im eigenen Nutze einmal probieren. Also einfach ein Milliardär treffen und sagen, ich würde ja nicht so einen Friedensangwun man, aber ich würde so einmal probieren, ich würde sagen, ich hätte so gerne so einen Jaguar. Und wenn der am nächsten Tag nicht dann vor meiner Tür steht, dann würde ich beschimpfen.
Also dieses Fazit, genau, dieses Fazit, dann wäre es auch wirklich persönlich enttäuscht. Ich habe ja persönlich, also mir sind die Personen wirklich komplett egal. Mir geht es hier nur um diese eine Eigenschaft, Milliardär sein. Nur um den Reichtum.
Genau. Und nämlich, sobald wir anfangen mit den Persönlichkeiten, dann tappen wir schon in deren Falle, dass sie irgendwie eine außergewöhnliche Klasse von Menschen sind, dass sie mit was weiß ich von der Natur gesegnet sind, dass sie überhaupt so reich geworden sind. Deswegen sollten wir das alles weglassen. Das Problem ist, dass sie so reich sind. Und das ist die Charaktereigenschaft, die wir brauchen und nichts weiteres.
Trotzdem klar markieren, das, worauf du abstellst, sind Selbstbeschreibungen der Milliardäre, die sie reportiert. Es sind nicht ihre Fremdbeschreibungen.
Richtig, das ist wichtig.
Wir als Leser können Fremdbeschreibungen anstellen. Und das machen wir auch. Also wir lesen zum Beispiel hier dieses Zitat von Thomas Bcher, diesem reichsten Kölner. Das kennen wir ja aus dem Film, der eben gefragt wird, was wäre denn, wenn sie jetzt ein bisschen Geld abgeben würden und so. Ne, dann wird das Geld ja nicht mehr investiert, sondern einfach verkonsumiert, dann ist es weg. Da würde ich jetzt erstmal sagen, bitte was? Geld ist dann einfach weg. Also klar kann man jetzt so eine heuristische Differenzierung zwischen Investition und Konsum machen, aber der Typ hat anscheinend noch nie Wohlstand für alle gehört. Der denkt ja noch ganz einfach. Und vor allem, die Deutschen sind kein Land der eigenen Verantwortung. Die Deutschen geben ihre Verantwortung am liebsten ab an irgendeine Institution, an den Staat. Für solche Sätze, ich brauche da keine Urteile von Julia Friedrichs zu. Ich danke ihr, dass ihr es mir zitierenfähig vorgelegt habt. Fertig.
Ja, das brauche ich auch nicht. Also da brauchen wir keine Einordnung. Oder sie unterhält sich ja mit ihm und er glaubt dann, so ein ganz tolles Beispiel mal zu geben. Und zwar, man sollte sich doch gedanklich nach Somalia versetzen. Sagt er. Eines der ärmsten Länder. Nehmen wir an, da gibt es einen Steve Jobs, der das nächste Apple erfindet. Ein Unternehmen, das dieselbe Erfolgsstory schriebe, wie das Apple, das wir kennen. Nur eben im Staate Somalia. Was würde passieren? Der somalische Steve Jobs hätte in ganz kurzer Zeit 95 Prozent der nationalen Assets von Somalia. Also fast das gesamte Vermögen. Extrem ungerecht, so Scherz, Subtext. Jetzt können sie ihm das wegnehmen. Gar kein Problem. Was haben sie davon? Der Staat würde das Geld ausgeben oder umverteilen. Und im Ergebnis wäre das Land nach kurzer Zeit so arm wie zuvor. Die Sache ist natürlich, es ist ja nicht so, dass in Somalia keine genialen Leute rumlaufen. Das Problem ist, in Somalia ist kein Geld, ist keine staatliche Infrastruktur, die überhaupt erst ermöglicht hat in den USA, dass so etwas wie Apple errichtet wurden konnte. Apples Erfolg ist auch darauf gegründet, dass USA sehr viel Geld in Universitäten gesteckt hat. All das ist nicht da. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man nur noch warten muss, dass morgen ein Kind auf die Welt kommt, das so genial ist wie Steve Jobs und dann Somalia reich macht.
Ja, die Welt wird bestimmt vom Gestaltungsspielraum, den man hatte, nicht von der Genialität.
Und da kannst du noch sehen, diese Schlichtheit, diese Geistige, die diese superreichen Leute haben.
Das finde ich schon erstaunlich.
Du kannst dich ja mit jedem normalen Menschen auf der Straße vernünftiger unterhalten als mit denen.
Ja, und das finde ich so erstaunlich. Sie trifft ja einige, die interessante Fragen stellen und sich dann auch dafür interessieren, wie der Sebastian, der ja klassenübergreifende Freundschaften sucht und so weiter. Und dann aber diese Attitüden der anderen, wie zum Beispiel dieser Wild, also der verdient sein Geld mit Capri-Sonne und alle um ihn herum. Also er hat einfach so ein Entourage an ja, mein lieber Siebenjähriger, was willst du jetzt so? Ach, zum Boot, okay, dann fliegen wir jetzt zum Boot. Dann macht man es halt. Dein Hotelzimmer, ja, wir haben natürlich das für 17.000 Euro. Sonst wären ja irgendwelche Sachen, die würden dir nicht gefallen. Deswegen nehmen wir auch immer das Beste, so ungefähr. Und dieser Wild, der also seit Jahrzehnten jetzt in dieser Welt lebt, kriegt diese Anfrage, können wir sie auf dem Flug nach Paris begleiten? Sie fliegen da ja zu ihrem Sport, zu ihrer Sportmannschaft. Das ist doch eine ihrer Leidenschaften. Können sie, wollen sie die nicht mit uns teilen? Wollen sie uns nicht mal so, ne? Und dann sieht man ihm in diesem Film, wie er ganz alleine in diesem Flugzeug sitzt und sagt, ich flieg jetzt aufs Boot. Hätten wir das nicht anders? Nee, sollen sie Fahrrad fahren oder was? Ja, also das ist so die Schöpfungshöhe seines Gedanken. Gerade ich muss zum Boot und ich brauche dafür mein Flugzeug. Und ich sitze hier gerne alleine und dann komme ich da irgendwie an.
Und Julia Friedrichs durfte nicht mit.
Genau, das ist die Frage. Warum durfte sie nicht mit? Das Angebot, jemand hat über die Working Class in Deutschland geschrieben und du bist eh schon auf dem Weg und hast auch ganz viele Sitzplätze frei, fändest du es nicht ein bisschen interessant, mit so einer Person mal zu reden? Und er sagt, nee, die darf nicht mitfliegen, denn ich habe in einem Text von diesem Zittelmann gelesen, der ihr Buch zu irgendwas gelesen hat, dass sie einen neidischen Geist hat und deswegen will ich das Gespräch nicht. So und diese Art von Ausgrenzung, sozialer Art, während man sich sachlich die ganze Welt vereinnahmt, also die verstehe ich nicht.
Das wäre die erste Konfrontation wahrscheinlich in den letzten 50 Jahren für ihn gewesen, mit jemand, der einen kritischen Gedanken äußert, gegenüber seiner Art zu sein.
Ich habe jetzt viel über die Alten Republik nachgedacht, das sind Leute, die ihr Leben nach der Arbeit gestalten müssen, aber sie leben noch 20 Jahre, das ist viel länger, die kennen das auch nicht von ihren Eltern oder was auch immer. Und meine Losung, und das sage ich doch über jede Gelegenheit auf der Bühne und auch sonst, ist, wir müssen ihnen ein Lebensabend gestalten, der sich wie Urlaub anfühlt. Und die allerwichtigste Frage des Urlaubs ist, mit wem? Erst wenn diese soziale Dimension für alle gewinnbringend abgehakt ist, kann man sich fragen, wohin, wann, was auch immer. Und dieser Typ sagt einfach, wohin und wann und mit wem? Ganz hohe Mauern. Ich sitze lieber alleine im Flugzeug, als man mit Julia Friedrichs über ihre Bücher, über die Working Class oder so zu sprechen. Und diese Kleingeistigkeit ist so grotesk, während man gleichzeitig grenzenloses Leben für sich reklamiert. Dass man wirklich daneben sitzt und sagt, das darf es per se nicht geben. Wir müssen ihm diese Eigenschaft superreicht zu sein, entreißen, auch für seine letzten Jahre. Er kann ruhiger noch was. Das erinnert mich dann so ein bisschen an diese Rentner, die dann irgendwann so, nee, den können wir jetzt nicht nochmal aus den Routinen reißen und so. Und die Forschung so, er muss nochmal umziehen. Er braucht nochmal ein neues soziales Umfeld. Er lebt zehn Jahre länger, doppelt so lang. Die Lebenserwartung steigt um das Doppelte, wenn er noch einmal kognitiv herausgefordert wird. Stattdessen, nee, also sie können jetzt auf gar keinen Fall mir rote Handtücher hinhängen. Wenn ich morgens aufwache, will ich blaue Handtücher sehen. So, und das, also diese Art von Kleingeistigkeit, die entsteht durch diesen, also soziale Kleingeistigkeit, durch sachlichen Gestaltungsspielraum. Unendlicher sachlicher Gestaltungsspielraum hat offenbar soziales Kleingeistigkeit vor sich. Es hängt irgendwie damit zusammen. Wir haben hier wieder so ein Rutger Breschmann, wir haben es jetzt nicht gehört, aber die Podcasthörer haben es gehört, so ein Rutger Breschmann Phänomen. Politiker, die extrem viel Macht haben, müssen relativ früh sich schon asozial verhalten, damit sie dann auf der großen Bühne und so. Also die Attitüten der großen Bühne, die im kleinen Ein-mal-eins in einfachen Sozialsystemen total awkward sind, müssen sie trotzdem schon ausleben, was grotesk ist. Und bei diesen Superreichen stimmt auch irgendwas nicht.
Die sind ja auch gar nicht gelassen. Das war ja auch in der Dokumentation schon zu sehen. Man kann es jetzt hier im Buch auch wieder lesen. Wenn man so reich ist, kann einem ja eigentlich nichts mehr passieren. Man kann sich also anhören, welche Klagen und Vorwürfe Julia Friedrichs hat. Man könnte einfach sagen, ja, das ist aber schade für sie. Und dann geht man raus und ist ja immer noch genauso reich. Aber nein, sie fahren ja auch sofort aus der Haut, wenn sie überhaupt mal auf so was angesprochen werden. Wie kann man es wagen, dass jetzt die Ungleichheit angesprochen wird?
Und vor allem, er macht sich selber darüber lustig, dass einige in seiner Familie einfach die ganze Nachbarschaft aufkaufen, damit sie mitentscheiden können, wer dort wohnt. Also man will sozial gar nicht mehr überrascht werden. Man will sich die ganze Welt einhegen, kostet es, was es wolle. Und das ist einfach nicht, also das ist tatsächlich einfach nicht gesund. Die Therapien sind Konfrontationen. Heilung besteht in Konfrontationen.
Ich muss gerade denken, ich hatte einen Auftritt gesehen von Elke Heidenreich in so einer österreichischen Sendung und da war es so, dass sie erzählte, in ihrer Nachbarschaft hat jemand sein Anwesen die ganze Zeit beleuchtet, auch in der Nacht. Und sie fragte ihn, warum er das dann beleuchtet. Und dann hat er gesagt, damit ich sehen kann, was ich besitze. Und dann hat sie zu ihm gesagt, sie sind ein Arschloch. Und so eine Konfrontation erleben diese Leute natürlich gar nicht.
Und übrigens die AfD wähle auch. Konfrontation ist jetzt das Thema. Wer regiert als nächstes Thüringen?
Jetzt haben wir viel über die Reichen gesprochen. Die haben Einfluss auf die Politik. Vielleicht mal ein Beispiel hier. Da geht es um Matthias Leffardt. Früher Lobbyist, der reichsten deutschen Familienunternehmer, erzählte mir, als wir uns zu einem Interview in einem Hotel in Mittelamerika trafen, wo er mittlerweile lebt, dass er drei Tage vor einer wichtigen Entscheidung zur Erbschaftssteuer drei Stunden beim damaligen CSU-Vorsitzenden und bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten Horst Seehofer in der Staatskanzlei gesessen und dessen ungeteilte Aufmerksamkeit genossen habe. Für mich war es eine Sternstunde der Politikberatung, sagt Leffardt. Und ich hatte mir eine persönliche Messlatte gesetzt, dass es auch nach dieser Reform möglich bleibt, dass ein Betrieb ohne Erbschaftssteuer übertragen werden kann, unabhängig von der Größe. Und das würde ich mit Ja beantworten. Das ist gelungen. Ein Sieg im Elfmeterschießen sei das gewesen, so Leffardt. Drei Tage nach dem Treffen legte Horst Seehofer sein Veto gegen das geplante Gesetz ein und forderte Erleichterungen für Unternehmenserben.
Also, in diesem Textteil steckt einer der gigantischsten Pointen ever. Also in diesen ganzen Zugänge zur Politik. Ich will es mal vorlesen. Julia Friedrichs hat es auch sofort erkannt. Sie hat einen Bindestrich an der richtigen Stelle. Ich werde ihn mitlesen. Ich werde kurz pausieren, wo sie den Bindestrich platziert. Und wenn ihr danach denkt, habe ich jetzt nicht ganz verstanden, ja, dann hört es euch noch mal kurz an oder liest nochmal nach. Also Thomas Christ, irgend so ein Superreicher, sagt, ich kenne in Deutschland keinen Politiker, der oder die sich durch irgendeine Spende beeinflussen lassen würde. Und ich kenne ja nahezu alle aus der Spitzenpolitik, und zwar seit vielen Jahren. Das halte ich für ausgeschlossen. Das ist so grotesk. Es ist unglaublich. So betriebsblind kann man gar nicht sein. Ich kenne alle. Ja, woher kennst du alle, weil ich Einfluss habe. Aber die lassen sich ja nicht. Nein, nein, das sind alles ganz authentische Leute. Ich kenne sie alle.
Die trinken nur gerne mit mir Kaffee.
Das ist wirklich. Man liest das und denkt sich, das kann doch echt nicht wahr sein. Ja, also man sitzt da drei Stunden beim Horst Seehofer rum, und der Sebastian sagt dann nochmal, ich wollte gar keine Termine mit den Politikern, aber die kommen halt immer. Und natürlich ganz viele, also da kann man jetzt stundenlang, ich halte mich für mächtiger als die Politiker. Habt ihr mehr Macht als die Politiker? Jaja, unendlich viel mehr. Wir haben viel mehr Gestaltungsspielraum. Wir können alles machen. Politiker sind aus Sicht der Superreichen nur eine Variable im Gefüge, während aus Sicht der Politiker Superreiche das Non plus Ultra sind. Also wenn man die nicht hinter sich hat, kann man nichts machen. Also diese Asymmetrie ist wirklich…
Wie erfolgreich das ist, kann man auch nochmal in Zahlen belegen. Es geht da um Susanne Klatten. 1996 erhielt sie als ihren Anteil an dem Unternehmensgewinn 199 Millionen DM und zahlte darauf, so ist es den Daten des Netzwerks Steuergerechtigkeit zu entnehmen, satte 61% Steuern. Im Jahr 2022 konnte sich Klatten über eine Dividende von 1,2 Milliarden Euro freuen. Darauf zahlte sie, so die Analyse, 21,4% Steuern. Berechnet man, um Ausreißereffekte zu vermeiden, den 5-Jahres-Schnitt der gezahlten Steuer landet man auf einem Level von rund 25%. Also es ist so interessant, wie man einfach nur über diesen Weg schon sie unglaublich reich gemacht hat. Und dann wird ja so ein bisschen das erklärt, das kann man natürlich nicht in allen Einzelheiten ausführen, aber sie macht es so ein bisschen begreiflich, wie das eigentlich dann funktioniert, wenn man ganz viel Geld hat und eigentlich gar keine Steuern zahlen will und vor allem auch steuerfrei vererben will, wie dann unterschiedliche Gesellschaften, Holdings, Mobilienunternehmen gegründet werden und sie erwähnt dann den Benko auch, dass also sein Unternehmenskonstrukt oder seine vielen Konstrukte, die er hatte, 46 DIN A3 Seiten füllt. Also so verflochten ist das.
Genau, also dieses, wie Sebastian seine Erbe angetreten ist, das lassen wir uns mal als allerletzten Punkt, weil da drin steckt eine Monster-Mega-Skandalöse, wirklich braun, die ist unglaublich. Noch ein Wort zum Klima. Das reichste Prozent der Weltbevölkerung verursacht 8,5 Milliarden Tonnen des Klimagases CO2, mehr als die ärmere Hälfte. Im Moment sind allein die Millionäre dabei, 72 Prozent des verbleibenden Kohlenstoffbudgets für das 1,5 Grad Ziel zu verbrennen. Man muss keinen in Thüringen davon überzeugen, jetzt auch noch mal fürs Klima zu tun oder irgendetwas. Das sind nicht die Schicksalsfragen. Beim Thema Klima ist es der Superreichtum. Über den Konsum, über die Investitionsentscheidung, über den Entzug von ökonomischen Gestaltungsspielraum, demokratischer Natur, den man allein einem Renditeverständnis unterwirft.
So, ich will gar nicht im Grundsatz widersprechen. Ich will nur etwas ergänzen. Ich habe dann auch nochmal woanders nachgeschaut, wie viel wird so verbraucht. Also das reichste Prozent in Deutschland verbraucht 83 Tonnen CO2 pro Jahr pro Kopf. Das ist mehr als 15 Mal so viel wie die ärmere Hälfte der deutschen Bevölkerung. Diese ärmere Hälfte verursacht 5,4 Tonnen CO2 durchschnittlich pro Kopf pro Jahr. Das Problem ist aber, deswegen will ich das schon nochmal aufrechterhalten, wenn die ganze Welt auf diesem Niveau der ärmeren Hälfte im Durchschnitt leben würde, wäre das immer noch zu viel. Was Bundesumweltamt und andere sagen, ist irgendwas so um eine Tonne. Manche sagen auch 1,5, manche sagen ein bisschen drunter, aber wir sehen auf jeden Fall, das ist zu viel. Also das Problem gibt es auch nach wie vor. Aber du hast natürlich völlig recht, wenn du darauf abzielst, dass die extremen Verschmutzer deutlich benannt werden können. Und das läuset ja auch sofort jedem ein, wenn solcher Wohnraum und solche Gerätschaften zur Verfügung stehen, wie sie hier geschildert werden.
In Bezug aufs Klima ist sie ja auch sehr deutlich. Also nicht nur Klima, sondern auch Ausverkauf deutscher Industrie, zum Beispiel für ein kleines Rediteversprechen nochmal KUKA als Technologieführer und so da zu verkaufen in der Robotertechnik. Sie schreibt dann, wir haben uns entschieden, die ökonomische Entscheidungsmacht in die Hände einiger weniger zu legen und ist das eigentlich okay? Also sie fragt ausdrücklich, in der Demokratie haben wir uns eigentlich darauf geeinigt, Macht zu begrenzen, zu verleihen, eingehegt durch ein kompliziertes System aus Checks and Balances. Verträgt sich die große Ballung der Vermögen mit diesem Prinzip? Und man muss ganz deutlich sagen, nein. Dass wir ökonomische Macht, also Eigentum, vererben, könnte genauso verpönt, geächtet und so weiter sein, wie das bei politischer Macht ist. Bodo Ramelow, nicht mal Bodo Ramelow, kann jetzt einfach thüringischer Ministerpräsident bleiben, geschweiden sein Sohn. In der ökonomischen Debatte ist es völlig normal, dass wir einfach sagen, ja klappt. Ramelow Sohn, wer denn sonst jetzt in der Neue Thüringer Ministerpräsident kann auch die Macht nicht einfach jemand anderem geben. Oder jemanden fragen, der darüber entscheiden soll oder was auch immer. Sie hat ja ein sehr großes Kapitel zu dieser Engelhorn der österreichischen BASF-Erbin. Und das noch mal so im Detail fand ich jetzt gar nicht so interessant, aber unter chronologischen Gesicht, also so chronistenpflichtigen Gesichtspunkten schon nicht verkehrt.
Ja, aber das wird das seitenlang davon im Bürgerrat lesen müssen. Ich finde auch das Konzept von Engelhorn zu sagen, wir machen das jetzt mal so als Experiment, vor allem unter dem Gesichtspunkt der Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie interessant, weil dann tatsächlich das dafür sorgt, dass alle mal darüber berichten und Ungleichheit und Superreiche zum Thema werden. Was dann am Ende bei diesem Rat da rauskommt, ist ja am Ende, dass man sagt, ja wir verteilen es ein bisschen und irgendwie weiß man intuitiv, an wen das wohl gehen könnte und ob man dafür den Bürgerrat als solchen benötigt. Ich fand einen einzigen Aspekt aber wirklich sensationell, als es dann um diese Engelhorn-Geschichte geht. Nämlich darum, dass ja Marlene Engelhorn diesen Leuten, die sich da im Bürgerrat betätigt haben, Geld gezahlt hat dafür. Die mussten das nicht gratis machen. Und dann wird einfach schon mal klar, über welche Verhältnisse wir generell sprechen. 1200 Euro Aufwandsentschädigung zahlt Malene Engelhorn den 50 Menschen für jedes der sechs Wochenenden. Den Teenagern wird das Geld den Führerschein bezahlen. Der jungen Mutter den Saugroboter, den sie ihrer Schwiegermutter schenken will, als Dank dafür, dass diese all die Wochenenden, die noch folgen werden, auf die Kinder aufpasst. Sepp will damit für einen Teil der Kosten aufkommen, die nach dem Tod seines Sohnes entstanden, als wären die Anwalts- und Notargebühren. Das ist so interessant, dass man da direkt sieht, weil wir ja immer diese Debatten haben, es geht nicht nur ums Geld. Für die Leute ist, 6x 1200 Euro zu bekommen an 6 Wochenenden, also mal so einen ordentlichen Zusatzlohn zu bekommen, plötzlich etwas, was sie aus vielen Miseren rausreißen kann, bzw. ihnen einfach mal eine Möglichkeit eröffnet, dass man den Führerschein machen kann. Also das ist so schön noch mal hier so auf den Punkt gebracht. Wir haben jetzt nur über diese verrückten Summen mit den vielen Nullen geredet. Und dann sind das diese paar tausend Euro, bei denen man sagen kann, das hat der Bürgerrat auf jeden Fall schon mal bewirkt, dass da jemand einen Führerschein machen kann und jemanden noch Schulden bezahlt.
Und alles, was du jetzt vorgetragen hast, sind bei den 25 Millionen, die sie da weitergeben möchte, diese Aufwandsentschädigungen sind nicht mal ein Prozent davon. Also man kommt mit diesem Geld wirklich wahnsinnig weit. Wie gesagt, zwei Millionen Euro reichen bei vier Prozent Rendite, um jeden Monat 6.000 Euro zu haben. Hier sind Leute, die haben 100-mal so viel Geld und dreimal so viel Rendite. Und die haben also jeden Monat einfach hunderte, tausende Jahresgehälter.
Also da sieht man auch dann, was Umverteilung bewirken könnte direkt. Wir haben ja jetzt eigentlich zwei Diskussionen, wenn wir jetzt auch so ein bisschen in die Historie des Podcasts blicken. Zum einen, Schuldenbremse muss weg, damit wir mehr Geld haben, um zu investieren, um alles Mögliche auf den Weg zu bringen. Das könnte ja tatsächlich passieren, dass diese Schuldenbremse bei der nächsten Regierung fällt. Was aber interessant ist, dass dieser MMT-Diskurs, will ich ihn mal nennen, glaube ich auch deshalb so stark geworden ist, weil diese Idee von Umverteilung eine ist, die man vielleicht noch ausspricht, wenn man bei den Jusos ist oder bei den jungen Grünen, dass das aber, sobald man irgendwo mitspielt im System, siehe Kevin Kühnert, kein Wort mehr davon. Also dass in Deutschland noch mal irgendeine Steuer erhoben wird und sei sie nur auf Superjachten, was nur paar Leute betrifft, ist sofort ein Tabu bei allen, klar, im Kopf.
Also schwenken wir es um.
Es ist doch Wahnsinn.
Schwenken wir es um? Von Schuldenbremse auf Superreiche?
Beides ist sinnvoll, aber zum Beispiel um konsumtive Ausgaben. Die sollte man ja nicht mit Schulden die ganze Zeit finanzieren. Aber um konsumtive Ausgaben zu stemmen, und da ist ja schon das Wort Konsum drin, um den Konsum im Sinne von Führerschein, Saugroboter und so weiter, um das wieder Leuten zu ermöglichen, um also auch ein höheres Bürgergeld zu zahlen, um ein höheres Elterngeld und all das zu zahlen, muss man den Konsum der Superreichen deutlich beschneiden, damit deren konsumtive Ausgaben mal ein bisschen nachlassen. Nicht nur das. Und da muss besteuert werden.
Nicht nur das. Also ich mache noch einen kleinen Exkurs. Ich werde ja nachher diesen Familientext vom amerikanischen Gesundheitsminister. Für mich wird es immer weniger vorstellbar, ob es überhaupt für normale Familien, also die auf normale Einkommen zugreifen, überhaupt konsumtive Ausgaben gibt. Jede Waschmaschine, jedes Obst, jedes etwas bessere Essen, was auch immer. Alles, was Eltern ein bisschen Zeit verschafft, sind investive Aufgaben in den nächsten Jahrgang. Also ich bin da gar nicht so sehr das zweite. Und da will ich jetzt auf dieses Ende hier einschwenken. Steuern. Ich bin total bereit zu sagen, Schuldenbremse von mir aus. Ich sehe das so vielleicht sogar als vernünftige Art, denn wir können umverteilen, wenn wir ordentlich besteuern. Wie wir heute besteuern, ist nicht vernünftig, denn so wie hier steht heißt es, Steuern gibt es maßgefertigt. Es kommt darauf an, zu was man selbst bereit ist und wem man dann als Dienstleister bezahlt. Aber wenn man Milliardenbeträge im Jahr bewegt, kauft man sich halt für 730.000 Euro bei Kanzlei So und So ein Steuersparmodell. Dann gründen die für einen Firmen auf den Kaimaninseln irgendwas. Dann wird Geld hin und her geschoben und am Ende 0 oder 1% Teuerlast. Das geht. So, das liegt im Reich des Möglichen. Nicht mal klattend traut sich das zu, weil wenn das publik würde, dass man bei einem Milliarden-Dividenden-Zahlung dann auch noch 0 oder 1% statt 25 bezahlt, das wäre grotesk. Nun ist es aber so. Unabhängig des jedes Jahr, jeden Monat, jeden Tag fließt da einfach Geld hin und her. Und dann sagt man sich, okay, gut, ein Fünftel davon gebe ich noch dem Staat. Da die fleißigen Arbeiter 50% zahlen, wenn es hochkommt, inklusive Umsatzsteuer noch im Supermarkt, sage ich mal so 20%, damit bin ich einverstanden. Außer man vererbt, dann will man es immer radikal so klein wie möglich haben. Auch den Sebastian hat das ja getroffen. Er redet also mit ihr darüber. Sie fragt ihn, was ist bei dir an Erbschaftssteuer angefallen? Er so, keine Ahnung, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen. Beim nächsten Gespräch, ich habe noch mal drüber nachgedacht, ich will es dir erklären. Also erklärt er ihr, wie er als Milliardenerbe oder hoher Millionenbetrag, je nachdem, wissen wir nicht genau, wie er beim Finanzamt oder wo auch immer vorstellig wurde, um eine Bedarf, eine Schonung zu beantragen. Ja, eine Schonungsbedarfsprüfung. So, in dem Moment, wo vererbt wird, muss also der Empfänger alles von sich geben. Irgendwer muss gerade das Geld irgendwo investieren, damit Herr Söder sieht, das Geld ist nicht fluide, sondern das liegt in einem Betrieb. Und wenn wir das jetzt daraus ziehen, wer der Betrieb gefährdet, also kann man da nicht ran. Aber nur für diesen einen Monat.
Man muss sich das mal so vorstellen. Ich bekomme einen Brief vom Finanzamt, Einkommenssteuer wird fällig. Genau. Dann sage ich mir, ich rufe dich an, Stefan, ich würde dir jetzt mal mein gesamtes Geld überweisen.
Dann würden wir einen Vertrag machen.
Dann sagt das Finanzamt, Sie haben gar kein Geld, um die Einkommenssteuer zu zahlen. Ach so, dann ist nicht schlimm. Dann müssen Sie die auch nicht zahlen. Und genau so funktioniert es. Also jetzt übertrieben, aber im Grunde funktioniert es so mit dieser Verschonungsbedarfsprüfung. Und dann ist die Erbschatz- und Schenkungssteuer unter einem Prozent. Und Sebastian sagt, dabei seien es auf dem Papier 30 Prozent gewesen. Die wären fertig geworden.
So, jetzt fragt sie ihn, hast du den Eindruck, dass das Gesetz extra so gebaut wurde, dass man da legal an der Steuer vorbeischlüpfen kann? Ja, er sagt einfach ja. So, die Pointe ist, wann wurde dieses Gesetz gemacht?
Ja.
Die GroKo hat es 2016 gemacht. 2016 in das Jahr ist das Jahr, in dem ganz Deutschland debattierte, ob man hier am Ende seiner Handlungsmöglichkeiten ist. So viele Migranten hat man ja noch nie gesehen und die Turnhallen.
So.
Und das ist einfach grotesk.
Ja, man kann sich das auch genau vorstellen. Also, wer ja hier auch aufgelistet wird, ich würde das jetzt nicht weiter darauf eingehen, weil man immer rechtlich da aufpassen muss. Aber man kann es dann bei Julia Friedrichs genau nachlesen. Also, Matthias Döpfner soll ja auch so geerbt haben, schon vorzeitig. Und ich kann mir genau vorstellen, dass man da auch mal telefoniert hat und gesagt hat, ja Mensch, die Friede ist ja auch nicht mehr die allerjüngste. Könnt ihr da nicht mal so langsam in die Puschen kommen?
So, jetzt ist es so. Jetzt hast du das Fazit schon genannt, weil es dir ganz wichtig war. Ich hätte jetzt gesagt, das Fazit ist mir egal. Also ich lese hier das Gesetzes von 2016, dass den Milliardären einen, ich bin leider arm, ich kann keine Steuerzahlen, Schlupfloch gibt. Und zwar richtig explizit. So, in diesem Moment, wo ich das lese, bin ich bei 100 Prozent. Ja. Ich habe kein Verständnis mehr übrig und das kann auch Julia Friedrichs nicht mal in ihren eigenen Worten aus mir rauskitzeln.
Ja.
Ich bin hier anders gepolt jetzt nach diesem Buch. Ich sage einfach, ich will kein Verständnis. Ich will auch nicht, dass jemand anderes Verständnis hat.
Von mir aus kann jetzt im Hotel Matze wer auch immer da rumklagen, dass ja Milliardäre auch und so. Das Geld fliegt einem ja nicht einfach so zu, habe ich schon gehört.
Du kennst das neue Lied von den Amigos.
Nein, das kenne ich nicht.
Amigos. Das heißt, auch im Porsche fallen Tränen.
Auch im Porsche fallen Tränen. Ja, das kann alles schön dafür belittristen.
Ja, genau. Und das ist so in dem Bereich des Kitschs kann man das machen. Und da würde ich sagen, schrammt das Buch mitunter an diesem Kitsch nah vorbei.
So genau. Dem Weg gehe ich nicht mit.
Ja.
Für mich nicht, denn ich lese hier dieses Gesetzes von 2016. Sie muss mir nicht nochmal erklären, was 2016 los war. Ich weiß es noch.
Ja, wir sind wütend.
Wir sind sehr wütend. Und ich sage, bitte kein Verständnis, sondern wir haben dafür Demokratie. Sind wir stolz auf unsere Demokratie? Verteidigen wir sie gerade gegen wen eigentlich? Hier, wir müssen die Demokratie gegen Superreiche verteidigen, wie gegen Björn Höcke. Ist einfach auf demselben Level. Es wäre noch viel mehr zu gewinnen, als jetzt einfach nur Höcke zu besiegen. So, ich habe ja schon gesagt, Höcke besiegt man, indem man seine Wähler jetzt konfrontiert. Ihr wolltet Höcke. Wir können euch leider nicht richtig Höcke geben, aber ihr könnt jetzt nochmal, ihr müsst jetzt mitentscheiden. Einfach nur rumdöhnen ist nicht, ihr müsst jetzt mitentscheiden. Und genauso eine Art von Konfrontation völlig neuen Typs will ich jetzt hier auch. Wir können uns diese Superreichen in diesem Zustand als wirkliche parasitäre Ausnutzer, Raubbauer nicht leisten. Und wir müssen dafür nicht zur Wahl, aber in fünf Jahren, es ist erst mal fünf Jahre ruhig und dann ist wieder eine Wahl. Nein, wir müssen das Problem jetzt angehen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob wir eine solche Debatte bekommen werden. Ich habe nicht den Eindruck und würde sagen, dass die Vorsicht, die Julia Friedrichs dann doch an den Tag legt. Und wir sind ja geschult darin, sage ich mal, solche Details dann rauszuklauben und darüber dann deutlich zu sprechen, was geschah da eigentlich 2016. Dass diese Haltung, die Julia Friedrichs hier an den Tag legt, diese so zarte, zögerliche, diese sanfte Umgang mit den Reichen, dass das eigentlich schon davon zeugt, dass man so weit jetzt schon ist, dass man überfreundlich sein muss, damit man vielleicht noch irgendetwas bewegen kann. Also eigentlich ist, finde ich, dieser Stil, der hier mitunter an den Tag legt, wird nicht durchgängig. Vieles ist ja auch wirklich neu, was man hier erfährt, ist auch schon eine Art Resignation. Also ich glaube, dass man inzwischen eine Diskursverschiebung schon so weit hat, dass man überhaupt mal rechtfertigen muss, warum Superjachten nicht toll sind. Dass man überhaupt mal so ganz vorsichtig andeuten soll, dass das demokratietheoretisch ein Problem sein könnte, wenn Leute so eine enorme Machtfülle haben. Dass das schon zeigt, wie verschoben dieser Diskurs schon ist. Also dass man schon, wenn man sagt, Superjachten sind nicht gut und Milliardäre sind ein Problem für die Umwelt, dass man da schon kurz vor dem Stalinismus-Verdacht steht. Das zeigt ja, wohin sich das schon alles verlagert hat. Und insofern ist dieses Buch für einen Mainstream-Diskurs sicherlich auch als Zugeständnis gedacht. Mögen viele andere dann auch diese Einzelinformationen für sich nochmal neu zusammensetzen und dann einen etwas radikaleren Entwurf daraus ableiten. Aber ich glaube, dass wir hier wahrscheinlich eher so eine Lektüre bekommen werden, eine Rezeption bekommen werden. Man blickt mal durchs Schlüsselloch. Also das geheime Leben, die geheime Welt der Superreichen wird uns gezeigt. Jedoch wird es dann doch nicht zu einer großen Umverteilung führen, denn sie ist ja auch politisch offenbar von niemandem gewollt, außer jetzt von marginalen Kräften. Und journalistisch ist es im Grunde kein großes Thema. Es dominiert ganz selten mal irgendeine Sendung und es führt dann immer zu einem ganz kurzen Aufschrei. Und danach diskutieren wir wieder, ob die Bürgergeldempfänger 5 Euro zu viel bekommen oder ob die Flüchtlinge Bezahlkarten haben sollten.
Weshalb jetzt der Appell gilt, dieses Buche richtig zu lesen? Es ist, wir müssen jetzt die Leser konfrontieren. Liebe Leser in Deutschland, die ihr noch wisst, was ein Buch ist, lest die richtig.
Ja, ja, aber es ist schon erstaunlich, dass man sich nicht selbst traut als Autorin, das ein bisschen klarer zu benennen.
Die Aufgabe des Lesers.
Nein, aber man muss aber nicht so ein Fazit schreiben, das stimmt. Ja, man muss nicht so, wir überwinden mal hier ein bisschen die Spaltung der Gesellschaft und retten die Demokratie, wenn wir uns mal alle ein bisschen lieb haben und jeder gibt noch mal was ab. Man kann auch hier schon mit ein bisschen Klassenkampf in die Sache reingehen, denn worüber natürlich noch gar nicht gesprochen wurde, was auch symptomatisch ist eigentlich. Jetzt, wenn ich auch an unseren Podcast denke und diese beiden Linien verfolge, einmal Besteuerung von Superreichen, die andere Linie Schuldenbremse. Eigentlich ist ja linke Politik eine Lohnpolitik auch. Und dass das auch so völlig weg ist, das werfe ich jetzt nicht diesem Buch vor, sondern allgemein unseren Diskursen, dass Löhne auch noch steigen könnten mal, dass sich dort entsprechendes radikal verbessert, gerade im Niedriglohnsegment. Das ist auch einfach jetzt als natürliche Ordnung, wie es ist, undenkbar geworden, dass da noch was Großes passiert. Also eigentlich sind wir gerade in einer sehr fatalen Situation und wir betrachten ein bisschen die verrückte Welt der Reichen. Aber zu ändern scheint sich momentan gar nichts.
Lest einfach wie normale Leute das Buch nicht zu Ende, sondern lest bis zur Jahreszahl 2016, schlagt es zu, sagt, der Worte sind genug gewechselt, jetzt wird es gehandelt.
Richtig. Im Neuen Salon sprechen wir über Crazy Rich, die geheime Welt der Superreichen von Julia Friedrichs. Sie bringt unglaubliche Fakten. Unerhörtes wird uns da präsentiert aus der Welt der Superreichen Deutschen, die glauben, dass es so etwas wie eine natürliche Ordnung gibt, in der die einen ganz oben stehen und das zu Recht, weil sie so klug, so erfolgreich oder einfach von irgendwas gesegnet sind. Dieses Buch macht wütend, wenngleich es nicht zu verstehen ist, dass die Autorin nicht nur gelassen bleibt, sondern irgendwann sich fast ein bisschen in das Objekt ihrer Analyse zu verlieben scheint und nicht mehr so hart mit den Superreichen ins Gericht geht, wie es eigentlich der Fall sein müsste.
Selten ließ ich mir einen Grundbegriff meiner Debattenführung so gerne aus der Hand nehmen wie diesmal. Ich will nichts mehr zur Schuldenbremse hören, denn es ist genug Geld da. Das neue Zauberwort heißt Superreiche. Wenn 1% 30% von allem gehört, dann muss man, wenn man Geld braucht, einfach dahingehen und es sich nehmen. Wir können uns diese Superreichen, der Spruch ist abgedroschen, aber richtig, nicht mehr leisten. Und das meine ich nicht nur finanziell, denn dieses Buch klärt uns auf. Wir müssen auch kognitiv einen Schritt nach vorne gehen. Das geht so nicht weiter. Dieses Buch ist sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig. In dem Falle müsstest du es wirklich auch selber lesen.
Wir nehmen die Perspektive von unten ein mit dem Roman Mein Name ist Estela, der chilenischen Autorin Alia Trabuco Serran. Sie ist mit einem Roman jetzt bei Hansa, der einen Monolog eigentlich liefert, nämlich ist da die Haushälterin Estela. Sie ist bei einer Kleinfamilie angestellt, das heißt sie lebt auch komplett dort. Sie ist in die Hauptstadt nach Santiago gezogen, um dort Geld zu verdienen, denn sie will ihre Mutter etwas unterstützen. Die Mutter ist nicht mehr so richtig gut gesundheitlich drauf. Außerdem muss ein Wellblechdach repariert werden und sie denkt, wenn sie für eine Weile dort arbeitet, dann wird sie genügend Geld zusammen haben, um dann zurückzukehren zu ihrer Mutter, um dann wieder dort leben zu können, wo sie aufgewachsen ist und dann auch einem anderen Beruf nachzugehen. Was wir jetzt erleben, ist folgende Situation. Sie scheint sich den ganzen Roman über in einem Verhörzimmer zu befinden. Genaueres erfahren wir aber nicht. Sie bricht jetzt einen Monolog und erzählt, was in diesem Haus dieser Familie, eher Arzt, sie Rechtsanwältin und eine Tochter haben sie vorgefallen ist. Und sie sagt gleich zu Anfang, das Mädchen ist tot. Und die Frage stellt sich, warum ist das Mädchen plötzlich tot? Hat sie etwas damit zu tun? Ist sie vielleicht sogar die Täterin? Und sie beschreibt nun das Leben in diesem Haus. Und diese gesprochene Sprache hat eine hohe Literarizität. Es ist also nicht das, was man als erstes unter einem Monolog verstehen würde, aber eigentlich muss man es so lesen. Und so wird in Etappen geschildert, was dort eigentlich vorgefallen ist. Und dabei gibt es ganz viele Beobachtungen darüber, wie diese herrschende Klasse funktioniert. Chile ist ja ein Land, wo man den Neoliberalismus zunächst mal gut ausprobieren konnte, unter dieser Militärjunta. Und das sind jetzt quasi die Spätfolgen davon. Denn es hat sich ja dann einfach so eine Reichenklasse herausgebildet, die ihre Dienerschaft hat. Diese Diener dann noch oft sehr schlecht behandelt. Filme, Romane erzählen ja häufig davon. Darum geht es aber dieser Autorin nicht. Also es geht nicht darum, dass wir jetzt sehen, wie fürchterlich dieser Chef immer zu ihr war oder so etwas. Nein, es wird eigentlich ein relativ guter Umgang gezeigt mit dem Personal, mit Estela. Aber trotzdem wird dabei deutlich, was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn man sein eigenes Leben aufgibt und nur noch für diese Familie lebt. Man die eigene Familie im Stich lassen muss. Man plötzlich nach vielen Tagen erfährt, dass die eigene Mutter gar nicht mehr lebt. Und dabei stellt Estela dann sehr viele Beobachtungen an, die sehr viel erzählen über den Dünkel und das Selbstverständnis der Reichen. Zum Beispiel, sagt sie über ihre Chefin, ich beobachtete sie manchmal beim Essen. Sie tat sich einen Haufen Salatplatte auf und verschlang sie im Stehen in der Küche den Blick auf den Fernsehbildschirm gerichtet. Studierendenproteste im ganzen Land, brutaler Überfall auf eine gated community, Millionen Fische an den Küsten im Süden angespült. Die Überfälle und die Gewalt der Kriminellen bereiteten ihr Sorgen. Ängstlich, sagte sie dann. Mach niemanden auf, Estela. Öffne unter keinen Umständen die Tür. Es gibt so viele Raubüberfälle, so viele Brandstiftungen. Überall wird geplündert. Ich hingegen machte mir Sorgen um meine Mutter, weshalb ich den Blick hob, wenn in den Nachrichten die Küste im Süden vorkam. Ob ich sie nicht vielleicht erst späte in ihren Gummistiefeln mit ihrer neuen Krücke, ihrem Brunnen Schacht in der Brust. Wie sie Algen als Beilage zu den Pellkartoffeln sammelte. Währenddessen schob sich die Signora jedes Salatblatt einzeln in den Mund, ohne sich auch nur den Mundwinkel zu spüren. Sie ist nicht schmutzig zu machen, tadellos, alles unter Kontrolle. Eines Tages würde sie eine distinguierte alte Dame sein, kräftig gebaut, in einem Hosenanzug und mit einem einzigen Ring am Ringfinger. Eine gediegene Frau, das ist der passende Ausdruck. Eine gediegene Frau mit einem einsamen Diamanten an der rechten Hand, ein Stein, den ihre Tochter erben würde, jenes außergewöhnliche Mädchen, das zu einer außergewöhnlichen jungen Frau werden würde, dann zu einer außergewöhnlichen erwachsenen Frau und dann ganz am Ende zu meiner Chefin. Die Kinder suchen sich immer aus, welchem Elternteil sie ähneln wollen. Denkt an euren Vater, an eure Mutter, an die weit zurückliegende Entscheidung, die ihr eines Tages getroffen habt. Und so sehr sich die Seniore auch dagegen wehrte, dieses Mädchen lachte wie sein Vater, es sprach wie sein Vater, es schaute mich sogar an wie sein Vater mit seinen sieben Jahrenquollen es bereits schier über vor Selbstvertrauen. Diese Klassenunterschiede, die sie hier beschreibt, und ich würde das nicht, weil es zum Teil in der Rezeption so vorkam, immer als Klassismus rahmen wollen, sondern wirkliche Klassenunterschiede, die natürlich auch spürbar werden und habituell sichtbar sind, das ist genial, wie die Autorin das hier herausarbeitet und auch, dass sie es schafft, eine spannende Geschichte zu erzählen, obwohl das eigentlich nur ein Monolog ist, der da gesprochen wird. Aber sie zeigt dann auch, wie dieses Verhältnis ist. Gerade dann, wenn eigentlich doch es die Chefs gut mit ihr meinen. Also wenn da der Arzt und die Rechtsanwältin sagen, nun jetzt, wo deine Mutter nicht mehr lebt, können wir dir nicht da ein bisschen Erleichterung verschaffen, nimm dir mal Zeit oder was auch immer. Und es ist ganz interessant, wie sie das dann so schildert, wie diese Begegnung dann nach der Nachricht ist. Ich schüttelte meine Schulter, um mich vom Gewicht dieser Hand zu befreien und versuchte das Gesicht meiner Mama zu finden. Die hervorstehenden Wangenknochen, die kleinen Augen, die braunen Flecken auf ihrer Stirn, die geschwungenen und feinen Augenbrauen, die viereckigen leichtgelben Zähne. Ich zog die Manchetten der Bluse glatt und drückte weiter den Stoff nach unten, zur Seite, nach außen. Ich wartete, dass er ginge, also gemeint ist der Chef, also der Arzt. Aber er bewegte sich nicht. Er war noch nicht fertig. Sicher würde er mir sagen, wie leid es ihm tat. Er würde mir den ganzen Kreislauf des Lebens erklären. Geboren werden, wachsen, sich vermehren, sterben. Er würde mit einem Satz anfangen wie Sieh mal Estela. Ich will dir etwas erklären. Und er würde mir etwas erklären. Dann würde er mir ein paar Scheine für das Begräbnis zustecken. Ich konnte ihn fast vor mir sehen, wie er in seine Brieftasche kramte, den angemessenen Betrag suchte. Nicht zu viel und nicht zu wenig. Etwas angemessenes genug für eine Frau wie mich. Nichts davon geschah. Er, der er weiter neben mir stand und mich unentwegt anschaute, packte mich bei den Schultern und umarmte mich. Ich stand still. Meine Gedanken standen ebenfalls still. Und ich fühlte ein schreckliches Brennen in meinem Mund und hinter meinen Augen. Nein, nein, das konnte nicht das Leben sein. Und das ist das Bemerkenswerte, dass sie hier nicht große Grenzüberschreitungen schildert, dass man sagt, das ist aber auch wirklich ein Schwein, dieser Chef, sondern sie zeigt, dass die Verhältnisse an sich welche sind, die man dann so zusammenfassen kann, dass das doch nicht das Leben sein kann. Und so ist es dann auch mit der Chefin, die dann zu ihr sagt, Estela Liebes. Nie zuvor hatte sie mich Liebes genannt. Sie bedeutete mir, mich zu setzen und gab mir einige in der Mitte gefaltete Scheine. Fahren den Süden, sagte sie. Und dann, es ist wichtig, dass man in diesen Momenten bei der Familie ist. Ich schaute auf das Geld in meinen Händen und sah die ganze Reise vor mir. Block um Block bis zum Bus. Zwei Busse bis zur Metro, die Metro bis zur Endhaltestelle, die lange Schlange am Fahrkartenschalter, 14 Stunden mit der Stirn gegen das Busfenster gepresst, eine Fähre um den Kanal zu überqueren, ein Sammeltaxi, 10 Minuten Fußweg durch den Schlamm, an die Tür klopfen, an die Tür klopfen, die niemand öffnete. Danke, sagte ich zu ihr, ich fahre besser irgendwann anders. Sie riet mir, den Tag freizunehmen. Und was für sie existenziell ist, was für sie alles entscheidend im Leben ist, das ist für diese Herrschaft, der sie da untergeordnet ist, einfach so, ja, das können wir so oder so regeln oder warum geht man nicht in eine Privatklinik? Sie kann sich keine Privatklinik leisten, wenn etwas ist. Und die Autoren schafft es tatsächlich, so eine Stimmung herzustellen, dass wir wirklich fühlen, wie es ist, in einem solchen Herrschaftsverhältnis angestellt zu sein. Wir erfahren aber da auch ganz grundsätzliches natürlich über Herrschaftsverhältnisse im Kapitalismus. Und wir bekommen noch mal einen besonderen Einblick, deshalb, weil wir ja auch hin und wieder schon mal diskutiert haben darüber im Podcast, dass wir ganz viele Leute haben, die Arbeit verrichten, aber die werden gar nicht als Personen wahrgenommen. Ich weiß, ich hatte mal hier eine Kurzgeschichte von Agatha Christie vorgestellt, wo es eigentlich nur darum ging, dass wenn der Mord durch ein Zimmermädchen verübt wird, niemand mehr sich an das Zimmermädchen erinnern kann, weil man sie gar nicht als Person wahrnimmt. Und hier ist es genau anders. Hier sehen wir also ein Zimmermädchen, eine Haushälterin, die sagt, mein Name ist Estela, also sich ganz klar aufsetzt und sie beginnt zu reden. Und wir müssen ihr jetzt zuhören. Und wie sie das erzählt, erleben wir sehr gut geschriebene, sehr elegante Literatur.
Sehr gut. Ich schließe direkt daran an, denn Estela offenbart hier ein Gefühl. Offenbar, sie hat eine Diskrepanzerfahrung zwischen dem gelebten und gewünschten Maß an sozialen Beziehungen. Das Bild der Familie wird ja ganz interessant dargestellt, denn sie ist die ganze Zeit von Familie konfrontiert, aber ihre Mutter stirbt und sie hat da gar keinen Zugang.
Es ist nicht ihre Familie und diese Familie, die sie da erlebt, hat zwar ein bezauberndes Mädchen, aber das wird schon darauf ausgerichtet, für den Kampf ums Dasein. So gibt es beispielsweise eine Szene, in der der Vater das Mädchen, das kaum schwimmen kann, immer wieder in den Pool wirft, damit sie sich selbst durchkämpft, damit sie schon früh lernt, was es heißt, im Leben für seine Belange einzutreten.
Ja, also gibt es hier eine Gefühlswelt, die nach dem Zitat von ihm seit 30 Jahren so gilt, um Einsamkeit zum Beispiel zu beschreiben. Daniel Perelman und Letizia Anne Pepplau. Und jetzt hat sich aber der Matthew Scheer in den New York Times gedacht, wir müssen nochmal neu über Einsamkeit nachdenken. Jetzt einfach immer nur so die 30 Jahre alten Sprüche. Ah ja, dem fehlt offenbar etwas oder sowas. Deswegen würde ich das jetzt auch nicht so unterhalten. Das ist ein Thema Einsamkeit hier, sondern dieses Verlassenwerden ist hier so ein Thema. Denn Aufhänger ist wie immer. Man macht irgendwelche Umfragen. 46 Prozent der Amerikaner sagen Einsamkeitsgefühle, Corona, dann sind es 52 Prozent. Also es ist nicht nur hohes Ausmal, sondern auch ein Trend. Und er wollte nun wissen, was hat es jetzt damit auf sich? Jenseits von Manfred Spitzer fasst auch noch mal die 30 Jahre Forschung zusammen und so. Also hat er 66 neue Fragen entwickelt. Der Weiß Burt, ein Forscher, der hier reportiert wird. Um mal diesem, ja die schildern halt sowas von Traurigkeit, Angst, Furcht, Herzschmerz, was auch immer. Es ist so multidimensional und so subjektiv, dass wir es jetzt versuchen, neu zu operationalisieren. Die Fragen lauten dann beispielsweise, haben sie das Gefühl, dass sie mehr auf Menschen zugehen, als diese auf sie zugehen? Oder gibt es Menschen in ihrem Leben, die sie nach ihrer Meinung zu Dingen fragen, die ihnen wichtig sind? Hat sich jemand mehr als nur ein paar Minuten Zeit genommen, um zu fragen, wie es ihnen geht? Also wollte jemand auch die Antwort abwarten? Wie ist das Verhältnis zur Familie? Gibt es jenseits der Familie Menschen, die ihnen so wichtig sind wie die Familie oder umgedreht und so? Und der Forscher war dann völlig überrascht, wie sehr die Menschen leiden, nämlich sehr, sehr stark. Also umso weiter man es dann ausdifferenziert in diesen Fragen und sich dann die Rohdaten anschaut, es scheint wohl wirklich sehr bedrückend zu sein. 40 Prozent der Jüngeren leiden heute unter einem Phänomen, dass sie in der sozialen Welt, die durchaus reichhaltig sein kann, also große Collegien, Fußballstadien voll, man ist immer unter Menschen, aber man fühlt selber keine Bedeutung mehr für diese Gemeinschaft, für einzelne, also man kommt sich vor wie Luft sozusagen. Man wird noch angesprochen, aber es sind nur noch, keine Ahnung, Floskel, Smalltalk, irgendwas, also Smalltalk würde ich sagen, schon ein wichtiger Aspekt. Aber ja, und dann reagieren sie selber mit Rückzug darauf. Umso mehr Sozialität man erfährt und dann nicht aus diesem, ich fühle mich hier bedeutungslos, umso mehr Rückzug, also Sozialität, also mehr Sozialität, kannst du noch mehr Rückzug führen. Ist ja durchaus auch für uns Deutsche hier. Also ich will es auch mal so ein bisschen gleich drehen auf, was ist da los in Thüringen? Diese Leute scheinen ja sehr verloren von der Welt zu sein und so. Es gibt ja auch diesen Spruch, sehr viele sind nach der Wende gegangen, haben ihr Land verlassen. Aber sehr viele fühlen sich auch von ihrem Land verlassen. Also solche Sinssprüche, die dann irgendwie kommen. Nun ist Einsamkeit ja eh schon ein großes Thema. Dieser Gesundheitsminister, wir lesen ja gleich sein Begleitschreiben zum Thema Elternschaft. Der hatte letztes Jahr 71 Seiten Ratgeber zum Thema Einsamkeit geschrieben. Nachdem seine Behörde meinte, Einsamkeit ist jetzt ein größeres Problem der öffentlichen Gesundheit als Fettleibigkeit. Und ich finde, das ist schon ein Maßstab für Amerika, wenn es plötzlich selbst die Fettleibigkeit in den Schatten stellt. Und hier wird jetzt dieses Bild gezeichnet, was ich so interessant finde, weil es politisch wichtig zu sein scheint, dieses Gefühl zu haben, sich zurückzuziehen. Von wo zieht man sich dann da zurück? Wenn wir jetzt immer sagen, es braucht mehr Begegnung. Begegnung heißt ja einzelne Menschen. Dieser Rückzug ist aber nicht nur ein Rückzug von einzelnen Menschen, sondern auch von Institutionen und Traditionen. Also man geht zum Fußball und hat aber Entfremdungsgefühle von dem Verein, auch selbst, wo man sich fragt, aber wessen der Verein? Du hast doch noch nie Kontakt mit dem Verein gehabt. Nee, stimmt, aber es ist mir irgendwie fremd geworden. Also so auch wie das immer so in sozialen Beziehungen. Man hat sich so auseinander gelebt. Ja, aber das gibt es halt immer mit Personen und mit Systemen. Also man kann sich auseinanderleben und man kann auch die Erfahrung, sich auseinander zu leben, gemeinsam machen. Und da finde ich, wird es interessant mit Thüringen, denn wir leben, wir sehen da keine einsamen Menschen, sondern die demonstrieren gemeinsam und fühlen sich aber gemeinsam verlassen. Ja, so und darüber kommt jetzt diese Einsamkeitsforschung. Also ich finde, da sollte man jetzt mal Bogen spannen, denn da scheint es dann doch irgendwie interessant zu sein. Denn jetzt ist ja die Frage, was machen wir jetzt? Können wir einfach die Uhr zurückdrehen? Den Menschen ging es ja schon mal gut. Man fragt die dann bei MAGA, wann war Amerika great? Was wollen sie zurückhaben? Und die Antworten sind grotesk, die dann kommen. Damals, als ich noch nicht gelebt habe und wir die Sklaven hatten, da war Amerika gut, als es gegründet wurde. Ja, solche Sachen kommen dann immer. Es ist selbe in Thüringen. Sie sagen jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, es ist heute schlecht, es war also mal besser. Was war besser? Diese Frage scheint unbeantwortbar zu sein. Und selbst wenn sie beantwortbar wäre, könnte man jetzt nicht sagen, okay, dann stellen wir einfach die Zustände von 1987 wieder her. Wir können ja nicht zurück. Wir haben jetzt Smartphones und die Politik funktioniert anders. Wir haben jetzt globale Fragen und so. Also wir leben einfach in einer neuen Welt.
Sigmund Baumann nennt das Retropie.
Retropie, genau. Nostalgie. Nostalgie, sagt man ja. Gerade im Osten wirft man die Nostalgie.
Und das ist ja der Unterschied zu einem faschistischen Projekt, das auf Fortschritt hinaus lief.
Genau, also ganz großer Unterschied. Dieser neue Faschismus, der macht keinen Fortschrittsraum greifendes, wir erobern jetzt die Welt oder so.
Und das Versprechen von der Nazis war ja nicht, wir gehen ins Jahr 1870 zurück.
Genau. Und grundsätzlich kann diese Gefühlswelt, die da heute so prägend ist, sich gemeinsam verlassen zu fühlen, also grundsätzlich mal als, das ist ein neues Phänomen, so wie auch Einsamkeit erst 1950 so richtig in die, überhaupt mal als Problemlage und heute haben wir da so Mediziner, die sich darum kümmern. Denn historisch gesehen gab es das gar nicht. Also 1550 bis 1800 wird man so als, wo man dann auch Literatur untersuchen kann, also Shakespeare bis echter Beginn der Moderne. Loneliness kommt quasi nicht vor. Situationen, in denen Menschen alleine sind, werden beschrieben als raus aus der Hütte, wo die 14 Familienmitglieder die ganze Zeit in einem Raum aufeinander hocken. Endlich Freiheit. So, also Einsamkeit wurde immer verbunden mit, ah ja, jetzt bin ich hier für mich mal kurz, aber nur, weil ich bin der Welt ausgeliefert, wir brauchen uns hier alle, wir haben noch nicht die großen, wir können es nicht zurückziehen wie Superreiche, die einfach alles delegieren und nur noch auf der Sachebene, sondern das greift da nicht. Also 1950 wird das überhaupt erst mal zum Thema Einsamkeit und ich würde heute sagen, ja, dieses politisch sich-verlassen-Fielen-von-der-Welt-müsste-jetzt-auch-mal-so-langsam-aufrücken. Seitdem das Forschungsthema ist, haben wir aber flächendeckend FOMO, also alles wird unter Gesichtspunkte, neue soziale Medien, der Nachbar, was auch immer, Schulleistungen, miteinander vergleichen, der andere ist besser als du, du verpasst hier was, mach mehr, halte Schritt. So, und der Homo Sapiens hat aber dafür kein Rüstzeug. Beziehungsweise die Sicherheit für sein Leben hatte er nicht durch eine besonders tolle Panzerung gegen den säbelgezahnten Tiger, sondern es war immer nur das Zusammenarbeiten, sich abschotten, gemeinsam, also diese wir die Unterscheidung, die sind so tief einprogrammiert. Das kann man jetzt als Erklärungsfolie noch mal nutzen, also die Ossis wollen sich besonders gerne in einem Wir definieren, gegen andere, aber das Wir gewinnt deswegen noch keine Kontur, denn der Säbelzahntiger ist nicht da. Also es gibt da keine Erfolgskriterien, kein Maßstab dafür, wann man jetzt sich genug zusammengerottet hat. Und der einfache Ausweg jetzt zu sagen, da müssen wir die Sozialität wiederherstellen, führt nur dazu, dass sich Menschen dann in Sozialität unwohl fühlen, die Scham greift, darüber Angst überhaupt erst mal aufgebaut wird, also nicht falsch konfrontieren, Konfrontation, ja, aber nicht die falsche Konfrontation. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie kriegt man hin, wie konfrontiert man richtig?
Sehr gespannt.
Ja, wir haben eine Welt, in der wir sozial unzufrieden sind, aber materiell sachlich eigentlich zufrieden. Und wir haben es eben schon mal besprochen, es scheint da so einen Zusammenhang zu geben. Umso mehr sachliche Entgrenzung meines sachlichen Horizontes, umso mehr bin ich irgendwie sozial alleine. Menschen haben ihre Gemeinschaft verlassen, um dann zu sagen, ich suche mein Glück in New York. Und in New York finden wir keine Sozialität, sondern nur Konkurrenz. Und eigentlich wünscht man sich zurück in dieses Dörfliche. Man will wieder nach Hause kommen. Aussies machen das die Erfahrung, man verlässt seine Heimat, kommt in diesen Westen, wo er nur hauen und stechen ist. Und allenfalls zu Weihnachten kommt man wieder zurück und trifft die alte Gemeinschaft, weil sich alle sagen, okay zu Weihnachten fahren wir nach Hause. Aber das hört auch nach Jahren auf. Also niemand, man kann nicht mehr zurück. Wo kommt also jetzt dieses neue, ich will mich nicht länger verlassen fühlen her? Und die Antwort im Text ist aus neuen Institutionen und Traditionen. Also nicht einfach nur mehr Menschen, denen man dann schamvoll gegenübersteht und so weiter, sondern man fühlt sich verlassen von, in der Systemtheorie wird ja ganz klar unterschieden, es gibt Personenvertrauen und Systemvertrauen. Auch wenn man in einer Amtsstube abheiten muss, weil man hier richtig unfair behandelt wird. Stärkt das Vertrauen in den Staat, weil man sieht ihn ja gerade handlungsfähig vor sich, auch wenn er sich gegen einrichtet. Das finde ich ein ganz interessantes Phänomen. Denn wir könnten jetzt sagen, in Thüringen die Leute wollen wieder von Bedeutung sein, unter Menschen sein, wo sie einen Mehrwert erbringen. Man könnte ihnen also Institutionen schaffen und das klingt jetzt so ein bisschen paternalistisch von oh man könnte ihnen das machen, aber sie müssen es selber machen. Das ist im Grunde der Clou, den ich jetzt noch ergänzen würde. Man braucht jetzt wieder ein Vereinsleben, in dem sich die Leute auch streiten, Sachthemen, Budgetfragen klären und feststellen, wir müssen das hier ausdiskutieren und am Ende gibt es Unterlegene für den Verein. Also nicht alle rotten sich zusammen und haben die gleiche Meinung und das ist dann der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner. Scholz muss weg, aber hier ist es nicht Merkel muss weg, egal, tauschen wir halt aus, Hauptsache die Gleichung stimmt. Es ist völlig austauschbar, sondern man braucht ein konstruktives Moment und zwar über die einfache Begegnung hinaus. Man braucht wieder eine soziale Struktur, in der man oder die gerade dadurch gestärkt wird, dass man in ihren Niederlagen erfährt, weil man sie dann handlungsfähig und, ahja, Gestaltungsspielraum gibt es, auch wenn er gerade sich nicht für mich auszahlt. Aber es kann ja auch Möglichkeiten geben für mich, da muss ich halt jetzt ein Jahr lang noch mehr, keine Ahnung, was auch immer, ja und so, also diese Wege jetzt zu machen. Und da finde ich, kann jetzt von diesem, auch bei uns im Podcast, ich gebe es ja zu, Einsamkeit ist ein sehr abgedroschenes Thema, aber hier eröffnen sich durch diese Art von Forschung und vielleicht doch nochmal neu drüber nachdenken und nicht einfach nur Begegnung und so ein Kram, sondern eine Aufgabe in Selbstwirksamkeits-Bedeutungsgefühl, Sichtbarkeit, feste Adressen, auch wenn gerade keiner da ist. Also man kann auch mal irgendwo anklopfen, wo gerade niemand ist und weiß, eigentlich ist es hier, es sind nur gerade keine Personen da und so, also dass man wieder so ein Zugehörigkeit-Zusammenkeitsgefühl hat, dass man, wie ich finde, das scheint mir dann relativ wichtig zu sein, relativ eng an wirklich die biologischen Konstitutionen einfach knüpft. Also nicht jetzt mit, keine Ahnung, ich muss immer wieder drauf rumreiten, das öko-emanzipatorische Projekt, selbst der Name auszusprechen, ist schwer.
Es ist ein akademischer Begriff, der etwas Größeres umfasst.
Aber bei der Frage, für was kämpfen wir, gegen was kämpfen wir, können wir es jetzt nicht länger mit, ja, wir kämpfen hier gegen das öko-emanzipatorische Projekt, wir finden das nämlich unausgewogen, unbalanciert. Wir kämpfen hier für das Höcke, ja, was denn eigentlich machen soll. Ja, der kann eigentlich nur Opposition machen. Wir kämpfen hier gegen die Ampel oder irgendwas, sondern es muss jetzt wieder konkretisiert, regionalisiert, runtergebrochen werden. Menschen müssen echte, hier fühle ich mich selbst in Momenten der Niederlage verstanden. Wir können ja nicht einfach auseinandergehen, nur weil wir uns streiten. Hier gibt es Höheres oder so, ja, so in die Richtung. Und das fehlt in Thüringen. Und im nächsten Text werde ich dann vorstellen, wie so eine Adresse konkret aussehen kann, auch aus der New York Times. Also wirklich hervorragende Texte. Es ist schon so ein Subthema bei meinen Textauswahlen heute, dass wir das in, ich habe wirklich gesucht. Eigentlich habe ich immer zu viel, diesmal habe ich so viel geschrieben und hatte mit Kram zu tun, dass ich so ein bisschen gesucht habe nach Literatur für den Salon. Und ich habe in der New York Times cooles Zeug gefunden und in den wirklich auch dieses, die Zeit versucht anders heranzugehen an irgendwelche Sachen und nicht die Top-Meldung da oben, sondern irgendwas anderes. Ich glaube, das geht alles gerade nicht sehr gut auf. Und ich habe die alle im Abo. Also ich bezahle jeden Monat 80 Euro. Ich bin sehr unzufrieden, muss ich schon mal sagen.
Wir lesen jetzt einen alten Text aus dem Jahr 1954. Er stammt von Franz Neumann, der zur Frankfurter Schule zu zählen ist, ein deutscher Amerikaner, der sich mit Angst und Politik auseinandergesetzt hat und sich dabei auch auf Freud bezieht und Freuds Thesen vorstellt aus dem berühmten Werk Das Unbehagen in der Kultur. Freud sagt ja da, dass das Programm, welches uns das Lustprinzip aufträgt, glücklich zu werden, ist nicht zu erfüllen. Also dieses Programm, wir werden jetzt glücklich, müssen nur ein paar Dinge befolgen, das geht nicht.
Das unendliche Begehren.
Für Freud kommt unser Leiden aus drei Quellen, der äußeren Natur, die wir nie völlig beherrschen können, der Anfälligkeit und der Sterblichkeit des Körpers und den gesellschaftlichen Institutionen. Also, dass wir da mit hadern, zum Beispiel Wutbürgern. Man kann diesen Text jetzt hier sehr gut natürlich unter dem Begriff Wutbürger noch mal rezipieren. Oder wir bekamen eine Hausarbeit dazu zugesendet. Da ging es um die Corona-Leugner. Also auch da kann dieser Text natürlich sehr weiterhelfen. Wir müssen das aber jetzt gar nicht so konkret machen, sondern vielleicht können wir erstmal ein bisschen abstrakt bleiben. Und diese Ausgangsthese von Franz Neumann, ist erstmal eine, die uns, glaube ich, allen verständlich ist. Da sagt er, Angst schränkt Entscheidungsfreiheit ein. Die Angst treibt uns dazu, schlechte Entscheidungen zu treffen, weil wir gar nicht mehr in der Entscheidungsfreiheit uns befinden. Und wo rührt das eigentlich her? Also hat das ja doch mit irgendetwas zu tun? Also wir leiden, es gibt irgendetwas, auf das wir verzichten. Was produziert jetzt eigentlich diese Angst? Zunächst einmal ist ja mit Freud festzuhalten, und Neumann unterstreicht das nochmal, dass jede Gesellschaft darauf baut, dass es Triebverzicht gibt. Also wir können nicht alle die ganze Zeit unseren Trieben nachgehen, sondern wir haben da verschiedene Möglichkeiten der Sublimation, der Domestisierung. Und das kann natürlich auch dazu umschlagen, dass daraus eine starke Angst entsteht, oder dass aus so einem Triebverzicht eine Wut entsteht. Und eine Angst. Und wenn wir von der Angst sprechen, sagt Neumann, müssen wir zwischen zwei Ängsten unterscheiden. Der Realangst und der neurotischen Angst. Die Realangst ist, wenn du mich jetzt mit der Faust bedrohst, dann ist es eine Realangst. Da kann ich nicht sagen, ja, du bist so eingebildet.
Wenn ich aber sage, das ist das, wenn ich zu den AfD-Wählern gehe.
Genau, wenn du dann mit der Faust kommst, dann ist das Realangst. Wenn ich jetzt aber der Annahme bin, dass alle Stephans Schläger sind und deswegen sollte ich Angst haben, dann ist das eine neurotische Angst.
Wir sind sehr viele.
Ja, nämlich diese Angst wird vom Ich produziert. Diese neurotische Angst jedoch kann auch ein Körnchen Wahrheit beinhalten. Also es geht jetzt nicht nur darum, dass man das völlig einbildet, imaginiert, sondern es ist meistens dann ein etwas übersteigertes von etwas, was ohnehin in der Wirklichkeit vorhanden ist.
Also Söder und Merz haben neurotische Ängste?
Ja.
Weil ja, ein Syrer hat ja drei Menschen erstochen, aber nicht alle Syrer. Ja.
Kommen wir nun zu der Konstellation. Also wir müssen das ein bisschen abkürzen. Es ist ein langer Text und auch dichter Text. Aber wir versuchen das jetzt mal zu verknüpfen mit dem, was man Libido nennt. Wir zitieren jetzt Neumann.
Ich habe einen Verdacht. Ich habe beim letzten Mal Freud Lacan kurz mobilisiert, um etwas zu illustrieren. Wohin mit dem Begehren? Und jetzt hast du dich herausgefordert gefühlt, die Konzepte, die da noch fehlten, nachzutragen.
Nein, es war ja ganz anders. Mir wurde dieser Text beim Sommersammlung ein Porn.
Aber ich nehme Libido und Neurotik gerne entgegen.
Ja, wir machen dich noch hier zum Psychoanalytiker. Neumann schreibt, der Zement, der die Masse zusammenhält, ist also eine Summe zielgehemmter Triebe. Damit, so glaube ich, ist der logische Zusammenhang zwischen Entfremdung und Massenverhalten hergestellt. Denn eine gewisse Entfremdung besteht also immer in einer Gesellschaft, weil ich nicht jedem Trieb nachgehen kann. Da es sich so bei der Identifizierung von Masse und Führer um Entfremdung handelt, stellt die Identifizierung mit einem Führer immer einen Rückfall dar, und zwar einen Zweifachen. Einmal ist die Geschichte des Menschen, die seines Heraus-treten aus der ursprünglichen Horde und seine progressive Individualisierung und die Identifizierung mit einem Führer in einer Masse ist eine Art historischer Regression. So dann aber ist diese Identifizierung ein Ersatz für die dibidinöse Objektbildung, somit eine psychische Regression, eine Ich-Beschädigung, vielleicht sogar ein Ich-Verlust. Worum es jetzt hier geht? Also dieses Verhältnis von einer Masse, die offenbar einen Führer toll findet. Und wir sehen ja einen gewissen Führerkult zum Beispiel bei der AfD sehr deutlich. Was passiert da eigentlich? Nun, die Sache ist die, dass eigentlich das etwas immer regressives ist. Also dass man sich mit einem Führer identifiziert, ist ja eigentlich eine Rückabwicklung des Fortschritts, weil der Fortschritt eigentlich war, ich gehe da aus einer Horde, die irgendwie geführt wird heraus. Ich bin als Individuum da. Ich bin natürlich in einer Massengesellschaft in dem Sinne, dass da sehr viele Menschen sind. Aber warum braucht diese Masse jetzt so einen Führer? Und da gibt es also offenbar eine Ich-Beschädigung, vielleicht sogar so etwas wie ein Ich-Verlust. Das sorgt dann dafür, dass man so eine psychische Rekression hat. Und dieses Rekredieren, finde ich, kann man auch sehr gut erleben, dass, wenn ja diese Konfrontationen jetzt durch Journalisten stattfinden mit AfD-Wählern, dann ist das ja oft, wenn sie dann auch auf Widersprüche hingewiesen werden oder darauf hingewiesen werden, aber der darf wirklich Faschist genannt werden, dann ist das ja ein Rekredieren in der Reaktion. Insofern, als man fast kindisch sagt, aber nein, das ist ja alles Quatsch und das sind die Medien und das ist ja alles Lüge und und und. Also das sind ja wie kleine Kinder, die aufstampfen und nein nein nein sagen.
Ja, der rutscht ja auch in diese Vaterrolle.
Ja.
Eigentlich sollst du dich ja von deinem Vater so ein bisschen lossagen und jugendkulturell deinen eigenen Weg dann einschlagen und so. Das findet ja heute nicht mehr statt. Nur der Vater wird ja trotzdem alt und gebrechlich. Dasselbe wird ja auch bei Tim Wals so beobachtet, dass die ganzen Millennials jetzt plötzlich wieder so den Vater im Bilde sehen.
Ja, diese Führerkonstellation, schreibt dann Neumann, die gibt es immer wieder. Aber man muss auch da die graduellen Unterschiede sehen. Und die gefährlichste Führerfigur oder die gefährlichste Konstellation ist eigentlich die der zäsaristischen Identifizierung, wie er es nennt. Er schreibt, zäsaristische Identifizierungen können dann in der Geschichte eine Rolle spielen, wenn die Situation von Massen objektiv gefährdet ist, wenn die Massen unfähig sind, den historischen Prozess zu verstehen und wenn die durch die Gefahr aktivierte Angst durch Manipulation zur neurotischen Verfolgungsangst wird. Das klingt jetzt sehr abstrakt und wir können es aber noch mal ganz konkret machen. Wir hatten hier mal über Richard David Precht und das Subkutane gesprochen. Der sagt, ja, da gibt es so eine Abstiegsangst, irgendwas ist da mit der Geopolitik und und und. Und die Leute können das nicht genau artikulieren.
Die Journalisten auch nicht.
Und die Journalisten auch nicht. Und dann wäre doch schön, man hätte eine Führerfigur, ja, so ein Cäsar, den man folgen könnte. Und das findet dann hier statt. Weiter schreibt er, so wie die Massen ihre Erlösung aus Unglück durch absolutes Einssein mit einer Person erhoffen, so schreiben sie ihr Unglück bestimmten Personen zu, die durch eine Verschwörung gegen die Massen das Unglück in der Welt gebracht haben. Also Robert Habeck zum Beispiel, wie wir wissen, hat ja Deutschland alleine in den Abgrund getrieben.
Ja, genau.
Ja, so wird es doch inzwischen bis hin zur Springerpresse rapportiert. Der Geschichtsprozess wird so personifiziert. Der Hass, das Ressentiment, die Angst vor allem, die durch große Umwälzungen erzeugt wird, werden auf bestimmte Personen konzentriert, die als teuflische Verschwörer denunziert werden. Deswegen auch immer dieses Merkel muss weg. Oder jetzt sind es dann andere.
Von wann ist der Text? Das ist ja wirklich eine Thüring 2024 Analyse.
Die Gefahr besteht ja darin, dass dieses Geschichtsbild niemals ganz falsch ist. Also wir sagen ja auch beide, Habecks Heizungsgesetz nicht gut, dass er das Lieferkettengesetz jetzt erstmal gestoppt hat und und und. Nicht gut. Also es gibt da so ein Körnchen. Also so prima ist es ja nicht gelaufen. Und das muss eigentlich da sein. Also er sagt nochmal, die Gefahr besteht ja darin, dass dieses Geschichtsbild niemals ganz falsch ist, sondern immer ein Körnchen Wahrheit enthält und auch enthalten muss, um überzeugend zu wirken. Ja, also wie auch diese Migrationsabwehr jetzt durch die Union enthält das Körnchen Wahrheit, dass man sagen kann, naja, aber es gab ja jetzt schon terroristische Vorfälle, will man dann etwa nichts dagegen tun. Und so ist es dann eine Sache, diese Angst zu intensivieren und sie politisch auszuschlachten. Das kann man, schreibt er dann, durch Manipulation tun, durch Verstärkung der Identifikation und durch eine falsche Konkretheit. Und das ist genau das, dieses Körnchen Wahrheit. Man sagt, ja, jetzt reden wir aber mal ganz genau über den Fall da in Solingen und leiten von dieser Konkretheit dann so eine falsche Konkretheit ab. Und deswegen sind also offenbar syrische Flüchtlinge alle ein Problem. Und damit kommt man dann an diesen Punkt, wo man also Politik mit der Angst betreiben kann. Und jetzt folgt noch ein längeres Zitant, das ich aber doch als wichtig erachten würde. Er sagt, das Ziel des Nationalsozialismus war klar, dass die Zusammenschweißung des Volkes mit dem Charismatischen Führen zum Zwecke der Eroberung Europas und vielleicht der Welt, sowie die Herstellung rassischer Herrschaft der Deutschen über alle anderen Völker. Aber wie das Volk integrieren, trotz aller Spaltungen in Klassen, Parteien, Regionen? Nur durch Hass gegen einen Feind. Aber wie bestimmt man den Feind? Der Bolschewismus konnte es nicht sein, weil er zu stark war. Die katholische Kirche konnte man nicht so designieren, weil man sie politisch brauchte und die Loyalitäten zu ihr zu tief verankert waren. Blieben die Juden. Sie erschienen im öffentlichen Bewusstsein als mächtig, waren aber in Wirklichkeit schwach. Sie waren relativ fremde, zugleich die konkrete Symbole eines sogenannten, und deswegen hatte ich ein Problem mit dem Begriff Parasitär, mit dem sogenannten parasitären Kapitalismus durch ihre Position in Handel und Finanz und einer angeblich dekadenten Moral durch die avantgardistische Position in Kunst und Literatur. Sie schienen die erfolgreichen Konkurrenten zu sein, sexuell und beruflich. Und das ist ja auch interessant, dass diese sexuelle Komponente noch dazukommen, weil man dann wieder ganz klar bei dieser Angst, bei dieser Libido, bei all dem eigentlich, wo die Psychoanalyse uns berichtet und wie sehr das dann Politik prägen kann. Und erstaunlich ist auch, dass er nochmal deutlich macht, dass also diese Wettbewerbsgesellschaft, in der man sich befindet, nicht notwendig zu einem solchen Führerprinzip führt, dass aber durchaus da eine gute Grundlage geschaffen ist, um diesen Wettbewerb dann immer stärker auszuweiten und dann plötzlich da so eine Gesellschaft zu produzieren, die eigentlich unter, ja fast möchte man sagen, Verfolgungsangst steht. Jetzt noch zum Schluss. Nach Freud stammt das Schuldgefühl des Menschen aus dem Oedipuskomplex. Diese selbe Aggression unterdrückt ja das Kind und erwirkt damit ein unbewusstes Schuldgefühl. Das Schuldgefühl ist das Überich des Gewissen des Menschen. Aber gerade deshalb kann die Steigerung des unbewussten Schuldgefühls den Menschen zum Verbrecher werden lassen. Es bestehen Angst und ein unbewusstes Schuldgefühl. Das Problem der Führer ist es, durch Erzeugung neurotischer Angst, die Gefährten so eng an die Führung zu binden, dass sie ohne die Identifizierung mit ihm zugrunde gehen würden. Der Führer befiehlt so die Begehung von Verbrechen. Diese sind aber nach der in der Gruppe herrschenden Moral keine Verbrechen, sondern im Grunde moralische Taten. Aber das Gewissen des Überich protestiert gegen die Moralität der Verbrechen, denn die alten Moralanschauungen können nicht so ohne weiteres ausgetilgt werden. Das Schuldgefühl wird also verdrängt und macht die Angst zu einer beinahe panischen, die nur durch restlose Verschreibung an den Führer überwunden werden kann und zu neuen Verbrechen zwingt. Und dann landet man in einer total repressiven Gesellschaft. Und wenn wir das jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen runterdämmen und jetzt mal nicht gleich an den Nationalsozialismus denken, dieses Schuldgefühl ist irgendwie in uns verankert. Und es gibt da noch die alten Moralvorstellungen. Und selbst bei dem Mann, dem wir da eben im Teaser gehört haben, der da lacht und sagt ja Weidel und Höcke und so weiter. Irgendwas ist da ja wohl noch da. Und vielleicht ist dieses Lachen, dieses Feichsen eher eine Schuldabwehr. Nämlich abgewehrt wird, dass man doch eigentlich weiß, dass die Menschen da aus wirklich schlimmen Kriegsverhältnissen zu uns kommen. Dass die nicht böse sind. Dass wir sehr viel mit unserer Lebensführung und auch mit unseren imperialen Bestrebungen dazu beigetragen haben, dass diese Leute fliehen müssen. Das wehrt man aber ab, diese Schuld, die man ja doch auch, hier könnte man es noch mal sagen, subkotan empfindet. Und um das dann besonders deutlich zu machen, um das kohärent für sich zu gestalten, muss man sich immer stärker einem Führer oder einem Höcke verschreiben, damit dieses Schuldgefühl ja nicht wieder stärker auftritt. Und ich glaube, dass das sehr viel erzählt darüber, dass wir eigentlich, wenn diese Konfrontationen stattfinden, oft so Schuldabwehr haben. Und da wäre es ja eigentlich schon daran, dass man jetzt die Psychoanalytiker, soweit es noch welche gibt, auf die Straßen bringt und die versuchen mal eine Konfrontation.
Genau. Bedeutet natürlich, man muss erstmal einen Therapieraum schaffen, dann eins zu eins und dann 1.000 Stunden pro Patient. Geht ja nicht.
Eben.
Wie treibt man ihnen jetzt trotzdem dieses subkutane Denken, das sie selber nicht reflektieren, aus der Führer, der Gegner, wir, die anderen, der ganze Kram oder auch das eine Thema? Wir können nur ein Thema schreien, weil das wird sonst zu kompliziert. So, ne? Und ich möchte hier ein Angebot machen aus der New York Times. Alles, was ich jetzt sage zu den Regionen, die ich namentlich nenne, können zu Thüringen und zu Sachsen. Es gilt eins zu eins. Ich habe es nicht genau nachgeschaut, aber eins zu eins. Also eine Demokratie mit allem, außer einer Wahl. Was bleibt eigentlich übrig, wenn in der Demokratie nicht mehr gewählt wird? Der Text ist von Michael Wines und beginnt damit, dass man sich eine spezifische Frage gestellt hat, nachdem man nämlich beobachtet hat. Eine neue Analyse amerikanischer Wahlen zeigt, dass in der Hälfte aller Rennen um parteipolitische Ämter ein Kandidat ohne Gegenkandidat antritt. Es ist also nicht wirklich eine Wahl. Es ist mehr so ein Abhaken. Man geht nochmal dahin und wählt. Er beschreibt Perry County in Missouri. Dort wird gewählt. Senatoren, Abgeordnete, Bezirksrichter, Bezirksbeauftragte, Sheriff, alle keine Gegenkandidaten. Also da wird einfach abgehakt. Es wird einfach ernannt. Was sie nicht haben, ist eine Wahl. Alle Kandidaten in den unumstrittenen Rennen sind Alpublikaner. Wenn sich da Leute zurückziehen, sind es die Demokraten, die einfach niemanden mehr aufstellen. Bei den Midterms 2022, wir denken ja immer in Midterms, dann wird der große amerikanische Kongress in Washington bestückt, um dann sozusagen das Präsidentenamt zwei Jahre vorher, zwei Jahre nachher auszugleichen. In der Hälfte aller Rennen um parteipolitische Ämter werden die Kandidaten oft mehrfach ohne Gegenkandidaten gewählt. Es geht hier um insgesamt 29.400 Wahlämter, bei denen nur bei 14.500 ein Gegenkandidat überhaupt zur Debatte steht. Teilweise ist das auch bei US-Senatoren so, wo überall ist es beim Flughafenbezirksvorstand zum Beispiel. Also einfach so posten. Auch wir lernen ja in Deutschland jetzt so allmählich, weil es da so viel Stress gibt, dass diese Schulboards immer so, das sind ja nicht nur Elternvertretungen, sondern das sind ja so politische Gremien, die dann da eben bestückt werden müssen. Das heißt hier, die Demokratie dämmert weg, während sie gleichzeitig extremistischer wird. Drei von vier Wahlen zum obersten Gerichtshof in Georgia, der noch über diesen Trump-Fall entscheiden muss. Also keine Gegenkandidaten. Gleiches Bild in Nevada, Oregon, Richterposten, Unangefochten, Wisconsin. 67 von 71 Bezirkstaatsanwälte treten dort ohne Gegenkandidaten an. In Ohio 73 von 88. In Texas nur 31 der 254 Sheriffs haben Konkurrenten bei der Neuwahl. Und das sind ja schon, da greifen wir in dein Leben ein. Also da halten wir dich an. Da nehmen wir dir das Geld ab und so. Da gibt es einfach keine Gegenkandidaten. In Illinois, Chicago, eigentlich Heimstädte. Da haben die jetzt ihren Parteitag gemacht. Da haben sie teilweise eigentlich alle wichtigen Ämter bestellt. Demokraten treten bei 500 Wahlen nicht an. Republikaner nur bei 181 nicht. Republikaner sind deswegen heute flächendeckend in Amerika verankert, weil über die anderen Vorfeldorganisationen wie die Kirche, die Vereine und so weiter. Da klüngelt man einfach aus, mach du doch mal, stell du dich mal auf. Die Demokraten haben das alles nicht. Also die sind schon verlassen worden von ihrem Land. Die sitzen alleine zu Hause. Und es gibt diese Anbahnung zum Engagement einfach gar nicht. Und wenn man dann immer hört, wie bei Lanz war es glaube ich, wo er noch mal gemeint hat, Paderborn hat im Kreisverband mehr CDU-Mitglieder als ganz Brandenburg. Da weiß man einfach, das ist irgendwie nicht gut. Also hier fehlt einfach so der unterste Anlauf. Das bedeutet, auch finanziell ist dort alles ausgetrocknet. Es gibt da gar keine Partei in diesem Sinne mehr. Sie reden hier mit L. Cross, einem politischen Analysten, ehemals Direktor des Instituts für ländlichen Journalismus. Den gibt es ja auch nicht mehr. Sobald die Basis unter 30 oder 35 Prozent Zustimmung fällt, hat man im Gerede verloren. Dann fällt man einfach raus. Dann hat man keinen Anlaufpunkt mehr. Dann weiß man, die nächste Wahl geht eh verloren. Warum soll hier jemand sich engagieren? Dann motiviert dich auch keiner mehr, dich zu motivieren. Diese Schwelle ist einfach da flächendeckend unterschritten. Weshalb im Lokalen die Republikaner auch da, wo auch im Battleground States und so durchaus noch mal die Senatoren und die Gouverneure Mehrheiten auf demokratischen Seiten gewinnen, so also da läuft einfach dann der Fernsehwahlkampf und so eine große Stile. Aber so eine Etage tiefer im kommunalen Ebenen, da haben es doch die Republikaner eigentlich überall so eine institutionelle Vorherrschaft. Und er strapaziert das dann hier so ein bisschen. Das finde ich dann sollte man sich das für Thüringen auch noch mal anschauen. Sehr viele potenzielle Kandidaten scheuen, in aussichtslose Rennen zu gehen, weil sie um ihren persönlichen Ruf oder ihr ökonomisches Fortkommen fürchten. Wenn man irgendwie lokal verankert ist mit dem Restaurant oder so, wagt man sich nicht aus der Deckung und sagt, ich weiß, hier wählen 70 Prozent Republikaner, ich bin ein Demokrat. Nee, also dann macht man einfach einen Haken dran und sagt, ich lebe halt hier im Republikanerland. So und dann ist es einfach ein Automatismus, das ist dann einfach ein Selbstläufer.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja interessant, wie das sein wird im Osten. Du hast ja gerade gesagt, wir müssen das immer eins zu eins für den Osten sehen. Wenn ich jetzt an meine Heimat denke, Koblenz und die ganzen Umkreise, da kennt man natürlich Leute, die in Parteien engagiert sind. Da sind es vorwiegend SPD und CDU. Aber da würde man ja nicht sagen, mit dem schließe ich meine Versicherung nicht mehr ab, der ist ja in der CDU oder dem gehe ich nicht mehr essen. Der ist ja ein Sozi, sowas würde ja niemals passieren.
Ja, manchmal schon, es ist so langsam, aber nicht in dem Ausmaß.
Ja, aber nicht nur in Rheinland-Pfalz, es ist ja sehr heterogen und anders strukturiert. Aber es wäre natürlich schon so, dass wenn ich jetzt wissen würde, dass mein Steuerberater eine AfD-Politiker ist, dann würde ich nicht mehr meine Steuer machen lassen oder so. Das ist ja völlig klar. Und das ist ja interessant, wie das dann im Osten sein wird, wo das ja eh alles so dünn besetzt ist und wo sehr schnell so etwas dann passieren kann, wenn dann irgendwie stattbekannte Leute in der AfD sind. Wer akzeptiert dann, dass man weiterhin trotzdem noch andere Geschäfte macht? Oder auch die Sache, ja, dieses sich aus der Deckung wagen. Wer, der dort in einem Dorf lebt, kann sich überhaupt noch bald hervortun als zum Beispiel SPD oder Grüner, um für irgendein Amt zu kandidieren, weil er dann fürchten muss, dass sein Handwerksbetrieb pleite geht, weil die sagen ja, das ist auch so eine von den Grünen. Also diese Art Spaltung, die du da jetzt beschreibst, die auf einer kommunalen Ebene stattfindet, die wird ja noch gar zu wenig diskutiert.
Ja, das Phänomen, was hier beobachtet wird, ist, dass einzelne, entweder frühere Demokraten oder Leute, die von ihren Ansichten eigentlich so ein demokratisches Verständnis haben, auf dem Republikaner-Ticket kandidieren. Weil sie dann wissen, dem Wahlvolk, das halt Republikaner wählt, könnte dann auch mal mich wählen und dann kriegt man darüber Politik gemacht. Manche haben ja kommunale Anliegen. So, und auch interessant, also diese Schwelle, 30 bis 35 Prozent, ab da wagt man sich nicht mehr aus der Deckung. Die AfD hat die jetzt von unten erreicht.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie früher, als die noch die absolute Mehrheit hatten, in Bayern die CSU, dass man da auch als, ganz egal, man musste es in der CSU machen. Als ein gefühlt Sozialist machte man das auch in der CSU.
Ja, genau. Es macht keinen Sinn, erst mal eine ganze SPD aufzubauen und am Ende so einen kleinen SPD-Vorschlag, sondern dann geht man halt in die CSU und dreht von dort den Laden um. Aber auch da in Bayern, wo die Freien Wähler als Erstes auf Landesebene zur Geltung kamen, hieß es vorher, die haben schon 600 Parlamentarier und so weiter in den Kreisen und überall. Also die waren schon ein flächendeckendes Phänomen. Ich frage mich auch sehr so ein bisschen, nicht nur was hat das mit Thüringen zu tun, sondern was hat das auch mit der Präsidentenwahl zu tun? So entkoppelt ist es ja nicht, dass man einfach sagt, das kommunale Leben ist immer egal, wenn die große Wahl ansteht, wähle ich und so weiter. Sondern irgendwie gibt es ja doch Gesprächskreise und was auch immer, die sich dann da hin und her einfach so einen Dunst vererben. Hier jedenfalls wird ganz klar gesagt, wenn diese Parteien, in dem Falle der Demokraten-Chef in Wisconsin, Ben Wickler, nicht mit Bargeld in der Hand zu potenziellen Kandidaten nach Hause geht und sagt, mach das jetzt, ich stehe hinter dir, ich organisiere mit dem Wahlkampf, passiert da nichts. Also man muss das mal so tun, als ob die Institution, die es nicht gibt, die man wiederbeleben will, schon mal vorgaukeln. Da sehe ich jetzt ehrlicherweise schon seit Jahrzehnten zum Beispiel auch die SPD in Thüringen. Auch Christoph Macchi zu meiner Zeit, vor 20 Jahren, als ich da lebte, kam nicht über 7% und so. Das war schon immer traurig und diese Entkopplung von eine bundesrepublikanisch sehr wichtige Partei ist nicht aufrecht zu erhalten. Also da hätte man sehr früher und sehr viel niederschwelliger reingehen müssen. Die Leute denken, dass sie nicht sagen können, dass sie Demokraten sind, weil sie sonst ihre Freunde verlieren. Aber wenn sie herausfinden, dass die Person, die in der Kirche oder im Supermarkt neben ihnen steht, ebenfalls ein Demokrat ist und nicht darüber spricht, dann ist das wirklich stark. Das ist jetzt Auftrag. Also ich sehe in Deutschland immer nur Journalisten, die sich so gruselnd faszinierend zeigen, dass die Ampelparteien in Sachsen alle einstellig sind. Das war's. Man hat es jetzt beobachtet. Cooler Fun-Fact so.
Fertig.
Aber was bedeutet das eigentlich? Ich glaube, solche Arten, also nicht nur den Journalismus dazu, auch mal so eine Analyse. Kommunale Wahlen in Ostdeutschland. Wer tritt denn da eigentlich so an? Haben da alle Parteien jemanden? Welche Parteien sind denn das? Also wir sind, was die ganzen Analysen, die jetzt angehen und so. Wir lesen 70 Jahre alte Bücher und die machen uns klüger, als auch eine Woche lang dieses Zeug jetzt begleitet zu haben in Deutschland. Das ist wirklich, ich finde es...
Ich merke, du hast sehr gelitten.
Ja, das ist wirklich schlimm.
Und für mich muss ich sagen, war es so ideal, ich bin um 17 Uhr am Sonntag in der Schweiz angekommen, bin ins Hotel, habe um 18 Uhr, ich gebe es zu, mal den Laptop aufgeklappt, um zu wissen, ist es wirklich so ausgegangen, wie wir alle dachten. Da habe ich gesehen, ja, es ist wieder zugeklappt. Bin dann ins Kino gegangen mit einem Bekannten, hatte am nächsten Tag die Aufzeichnung, musste mich darauf noch ein bisschen vorbereiten und hatte sonst noch Lektüren mit. Dann habe ich alles gar nicht mitbekommen, Dienstag bin ich zurück und musste schon den Salon vorbereiten.
Diese Woche war für normaler Bürger, ich will mich nicht einfach nur Wut hingeben. Ich will ja Erklärung haben. Bei den meisten Themen, die ich im Journalismus sehe, denke ich mir, mach es doch mal gegenwärtig. Hol es doch mal ins Jetzt, ins Hier. Mach es doch mal konkret. Erzähl mir doch nicht von irgendwas und so. Und dann im Kontrast dazu beim Thema Thüringen. Jetzt kommt auch mal aus dieser Gegenwart raus. Ja, ich weiß, der hat da gerade einen ganz lustigen O-Ton. Und das ist für dich als zoologischer Beobachter der ostdeutschen Natur auch wirklich beeindruckend. Aber setz doch mal diese Wahl jetzt ins Verhältnis zu 2019 und dann 2029. Warum fällt das so schwer? 10 Prozent, 20 Prozent, 30 Prozent, 40 Prozent. Und wenn man aus Muster nicht ausbricht, dann sind das die Muster. Also es liegt dann wirklich in Zahlen vor uns. Das Schicksal hat sich sogar ausgesucht, dass wir wirklich diese runden Zehner für die AfD in Thüringen haben. 10 Prozent, 20 Prozent, 30 Prozent. Weißte, und ich verstehe einfach diesen Journalismus nicht, der da so daneben steht und das ist ja wirklich. Also jetzt müssen wir erstmal wieder rufen an, komm Steffen Mauer, haben sie noch Zeit? So und dann erzählt Steffen Mauer nochmal, was er schon tausendmal erzählt hat und so. Und dann ja der Oschmann war ja auch nicht so klug. Das war ja mehr so ein Selbstbeweicherungsding im Osten nochmal für die Seele. Und das war es dann, so der Diskurs. Das macht einem wirklich zu schaffen. Also mir als Thüringer macht dieses Thüringen wirklich zu schaffen.
Kann die KI helfen? Na hoffentlich. Jedenfalls kann sie keine Kunst machen, sagt Ted Chiang im New Yorker. Der hat einen sehr schönen Essay geschrieben. Ted Chiang, manche mögen ihn kennen. Er ist Science Fiction Autor und hat die Vorlage geschrieben zu dem wunderbaren Film Arrival. Und er setzt sich jetzt mit dieser Frage auseinander. Kann die KI jetzt bald mich ablösen? Kann die Kunst produzieren? Könnten sie die künstlichen Intelligenzen besser werden als Menschen, wenn es darum geht, Fiktion zu schreiben oder Gemälde oder Filme zu machen, so wie Taschenrechner besser in Addition und Subtraktion sind?
Nun, sind sie nicht.
Taschenrechner?
Man muss sie bedienen. Ohne den Menschen kommt da nichts raus.
Und was muss man machen, wenn man etwas bedient? Man muss eine Entscheidung treffen. Und das finde ich ist ein sehr, sehr gutes Kriterium, das er hier einführt. Er sagt, wenn sie Belletristik schreiben, treffen sie bewusst oder unbewusst bei fast jedem Wort, das sie schreiben, eine Entscheidung. Vereinfacht gesagt können wir uns vorstellen, dass eine Kurzgeschichte mit 10.000 Wörtern etwa 10.000 Entscheidungen erfordert. Und wir denken gerade, wenn wir über KI und Produktion so nachdenken, über den schnellen Prompt nach. Schreib mal eine Geschichte mit zwei Kindern und einem Papagei und mach mal irgendwas mit Marx dazu. Dann könnte ich sagen, ah, da hätte ja Chet Chet Petit unser Kinderbuch schreiben können oder was. Nein, es geht ja dann um die Details, um jedes einzelne Wort, für das man sich entscheidet. Ruf der Papagei, schreit der Papagei, ächzt der Papagei. Was macht er dann eigentlich und wie reagiert wer darauf? Und da werden also die Entscheidungen gefällt. Kunst besteht also die Produktion von Kunst aus Entscheidungen. Er sagte, eine Möglichkeit besteht darin, den Durchschnitt der von anderen Autoren getroffenen Entscheidungen zu nehmen. Also wenn die KI das jetzt machen will. Wie sie durch im Internet gefundenen Texte repräsentiert werden. Dieser Durchschnitt entspricht den uninteressantesten Entscheidungen, weshalb die von der KI generierten Texte oft sehr fade sind. Eine andere Möglichkeit besteht darin, das Programm anzuweisen, den Stil eines bestimmten Autos zu imitieren, was zu einer stark abgeleiteten Geschichte führt. Ist ja klar. Ich denke, dass dasselbe Prinzip auch für die bildende Kunst gilt, auch wenn es schwieriger ist, die Entscheidungen zu quantifizieren, die ein Maler trifft. Er sagt dann, dass sich einige Kommentatoren vorstellen, dass Bildgeneratoren die visuelle Kultur ganz stark beeinflussen werden, und zwar so stark wie damals das Aufkommen der Fotografie. Und zunächst einmal erscheint das auch plausibel, aber er wendet ein, ich vermute, dass die Fotografie zu Beginn ihrer Entwicklung nicht wie ein künstlerisches Medium wirkte, weil es nicht offensichtlich war, dass man viele Entscheidungen treffen musste. Und das ist ja tatsächlich noch so, dass Unwissende noch sagen, drück doch einfach auf den Auslöser. Das hat doch nichts mit Kunst zu tun, Fotografie, das macht die Kamera doch von selbst. Aber wir wissen natürlich alle, es ist doch ein bisschen mehr, als einfach auf den Auslöser zu klicken, um ein sehr, sehr gutes Bild hinzubekommen, dass man sagt, es ist künstlerisch anspruchsvoll. Er geht dann weiter und sagt, wir können uns einen Textbildgenerator vorstellen, bei dem man im Laufe vieler Sitzungen zehntausende von Wörtern in das Textfeld eingeben kann, um eine extrem feinkörnige Kontrolle über das zu erzeugende Bild zu ermöglichen. Das wäre so etwas wie Photoshop mit einer rein textuellen Schnittstelle. Ich würde sagen, dass eine Person, die ein solches Programm benutzt, immer noch die Bezeichnung Künstler verdienen würde. Sie tut ja da etwas ganz Klares. Und er bringt dann auch den Filmregisseur Benet Miller. Der hat mit Dolly 2 versucht, Bilder zu erzeugen. Und diese sind dann auch ausgestellt worden und die konnte man auch kaufen. Allerdings hat er mehr als 100.000 Bilder generiert und hat dann am Ende 20 genommen und in die Ausstellung gelegt. Das heißt, das ist ja wieder der künstlerische Akt, der Entscheidung. Und jetzt muss man sich vorstellen, wie soll das denn sein, so eine Sitzung, du willst jetzt einen Roman schreiben. Du kannst natürlich jetzt einfach sagen, schreib 200.000 Zeichen, müssen zwei Kinder und Papagei vorkommen. Oder du sagst, ich muss jetzt schon auch das ein bisschen feinkörniger machen. Im Prinzip läuft das Ganze dann darauf aus, dass der Prompt so lang sein wird wie dein Roman. Also hast du dann im Prinzip deinen Roman auch einfach schreiben können. Dafür brauchst du nicht mehr die KI.
Man trifft halt andere Entscheidungen beim Prompten.
Nur die Frage ist, ob es wirklich dabei Kunst entsteht oder ob du nicht so feinkörnig werden musst, dass du es am Ende dann schreibst. Er sagt hier, und das finde ich nochmal einen sehr, sehr wichtigen Hinweis, man unterschätzt oft den Aufwand, der nötig ist, um zu unterhalten. Also ich kann natürlich vielleicht für eine kurze TikTok-Poarte sagen, mach mal. Aber sobald es länger funktionieren würde, sehen wir ja selbst bei fähigen Leuten, also Leute, die schon 20 Drehbücher geschrieben haben, mit guten Produzenten und guten Schauspielern, wie selten Filme gelingen. Und dann können wir uns auch denken, was es eigentlich für eine Anstrengung bedeutet, einen guten Text zu schreiben und dass das eine entscheidungsbasierte Sache ist. Jeder Text, sagt er dann auch zu uns als Leser, jeder Text, der ihre Aufmerksamkeit als Leser verdient, ist das Ergebnis der Bemühungen der Person, die ihn geschrieben hat. Die Anstrengung während des Schreibprozesses ist keine Garantie dafür, dass das Endprodukt lesenswert ist, aber ohne sie kann keine wertvolle Arbeit entstehen. Und das finde ich auch nochmal so ganz wichtig für so eine Ethik des Lesens und des Schreibens, dass sich ja Leute Mühe machen. Das heißt nicht, dass man jetzt jeden Roman feiern muss, weil man sagen kann, da hat man sich drei Jahre daran abgemüht. Aber dennoch ist von den Lesern eigentlich das auch entgegenzubringen, dass man sagt, da hat sich jemand die Mühe gemacht, das zu schreiben, ich mache mir die Mühe es zu lesen. Dann sagt er noch, die Autovervollstellung ihres Telefons kann gute und schlechte Vorschläge machen, aber in keinem Fall versucht sie, ihnen und der Person, der sie schreiben, etwas zu sagen. Die Tatsache, dass Chichi Petit zusammenhängende Sätze erzeugen kann, lässt vermuten, dass es Sprache auf eine Weise versteht, wie es die automatische Vervollstellung ihres Telefons nicht tut. Aber es hat keine Absicht mehr, zu kommunizieren. Denn darum geht es ja, dass wenn man Autor ist, hat man etwas zu sagen. Wenn man ein Bild malt, hat man etwas zu sagen. Wenn man in der Schule einen Aufsatz schreiben soll, sagt er, dann geht es ja nicht darum, dass man das mal aufschreibt, damit das mal in der Welt ist, damit der Lehrer dann was weiß oder so. Sondern es geht ja darum, das kritische Denken zu stärken. Man würde ja auch, er bringt da ein schönes Beispiel, ja nicht sagen, ach ja, also jetzt ins Fitnessstudio gehen und die Gewichte stemmen, schickt doch einfach so einen Gabelstapler rein, der kann die Gewichte doch auch mal hochheben. Das muss er ja nicht selbst machen. Also diese Übung ist ja dann das, was entscheidend ist. Und dabei geht es auch immer, wenn wir über Kommunikation nachdenken, darum, dass wir, wenn wir in der direkten Kommunikation sind, damit Chat-GPT vielleicht doch nicht so weiterkommen. Sicherlich, um jetzt das Lästige zu erledigen, ja. Also wenn ich jetzt sage, bitte noch mal dem Finanzamt die und die Dinge mitteilen. Das wird ja irgendwann sehr, sehr gut möglich sein. Aber wenn wir in der direkten Kommunikation mit Menschen sind, und wir haben ja hier das Thema Einsamkeit, da geht es um Interaktion, dann ist die Bedeutung doch relevant, sagt er. Also wir haben natürlich auch schon hier mit der Systemtheorie draufgeblickt, wie relevant ist eigentlich die Bedeutung und was wird eigentlich verstanden. Aber er sagt, es gibt schon so etwas wie Bedeutung. Und da geht es interessanterweise nicht um Originalität. Und er bringt dann ein Beispiel, nämlich wenn man sich entschuldigen will. Wenn ich mich jetzt bei dir entschuldige, dann würde ich irgendwie sowas sagen. Stefan, ich entschuldige mich bei dir. Es tut mir leid, dass ich das letzte Woche gesagt habe. Ich hoffe, ich habe es nicht verletzt. Es soll nicht wieder vorkommen. Das sind alles keine originellen Sätze. Das sind Sätze, die tausend Millionen mal gehört haben. Es hatte überhaupt nichts Individuelles, aber mit der Intention, mich tatsächlich zu entschuldigen, hat es seine Wirkung und wird von dir auch nicht aufgefasst, wie solche Sätze, die werden ja immer mal wiedergesprochen. Wenn man jemanden, ich liebe dich, sagt, sagt man nicht. Das ist aber ein bisschen abgetroschen. Das haben auch schon viele gesagt.
Partiziell war das Szenario jetzt nur, weil ich ja nie etwas tue oder erfahre, wo Entschuldigungen nötig sind.
Natürlich, ja, genau. Und das ist das Interessante, dass wir also da gar nicht auf Originalität aus sind.
Und er sagt dann, wir sind alle Produkte dessen, was vor uns war, aber erst durch das Leben in Interaktion mit anderen, bringen wir Bedeutung in die Welt. Das ist etwas, was ein Algorithmus zur automatischen Vervollständigung niemals leisten kann. Und lassen Sie sich von niemandem etwas anderes erzählen.
Ich werde nichts dagegen sagen. Denn es ist genau so, du hast es ja eben sehr gut dargestellt. Nicht die Information ist das Entscheidende, sondern die Mitteilung. Jemand meinte wirklich mich. Ja. Denn Informationen gibt es viele, gerade bei dem Thema Kunst. Menschen malen Landschaften, Sonnenuntergänge, Situation, Cafés, was auch immer. Niemand kommt auf den Gedanken zu sagen, der echte Sonnenuntergang ist Kunst. Die echte Szenerie im Café ist Kunst. Dieser Wald ist viel schönere Kunst, als der von Caspar David Friedrich, weil der ist echt. Sagt keiner. Es ist also die Mitteilung. Ein Mensch hat etwas mitgeteilt. Und sei es nur so abstrakt, wie geht. Der Text sagt ja im Grunde, Kunst geht nicht ohne Künstler. Und der Künstler muss ein Mensch sein. Das ist die Definition von Kunst. Es geht nicht darum, wem was gefällt oder wie auch immer, sondern man versteht, es ist eine Mitteilung. Und wenn dann jemand sagt, das ist ja total sinnlos, das kann ich doch auch, also diese Information kann ich doch auch herstellen. Ich kann auch so schön malen und so weiter und so fort. Ja, dann mach halt. Also wenn du die Mitteilung machst, dann ja. Und umso mehr jemand sagt, nee, aus inhaltlichen Gründen wehre ich ab, das ist keine Kunst. Aber du demonstrierst ja gerade, sie wurde mitgeteilt, sie bedeutet etwas. Du hast jetzt schon drei Sätze darauf verschwendet. Weshalb diese Diskussionen grundsätzlich, finde ich, müßig sind, was jetzt die KI kann. Sondern dann muss man es sozusagen auf die erste pragmatische Stufe runterkristallisieren. Werkzeug. Kann die KI dem Künstler und seinem Werk als Werkzeug dienen?
Ja.
Und das ist aber eine andere Frage.
Richtig, ja. So.
Und die muss aber auch noch geklärt werden. Denn, das ist ja nicht nur in Universitäten, sondern auch in Hausarbeiten abgegeben werden. Wenn du einfach nur einen Prompt reinschreibst und GPT, das erkennt jeder. Wenn du dir den Abend Zeit nimmst, dir Gedanken zu machen, Argumente zu entwickeln und du überlässt nur die Formulierung GPT, das wird schon nicht so sehr gemerkt. Und es steckt ja viel von dir drin. Der Prompt war aufwendig. Du hast nur die kleinen kognitiven Handwerksarbeiten ausgelagert. So wie Goethe um seinen Tisch lief und seinen drei Schreiberlingen gesagt hatte, schreibt mir das mal auf. Der Gedanke ist, schreibt es mir auf. Ich habe jetzt so eine KI-App, der diktierig sachten. Und die baut mir dann selber einen kurzen Punkt zusammen. Also ich rede sozusagen vor mich hin und die versucht dann zu ermitteln und macht dann aus irgendetwas drei Punkte oder sowas. Also die baut das so zusammen. Die Frage, die ich mir stelle, als Künstler hat man immer auch das Ansinnen, das Publikum auszutricksen. Was ja super interessant ist, wenn man ins Museum geht, sieht man nur das Werk. Wenn man auf eine Kunstmesse geht, sieht man auch den Künstler, der wäre möglichst hohe Preise. Er erklärt dir also noch mal, wie er das gemacht hat. Da war eine Glasfeder, die hing an einem Faden. Dann habe ich diese Farbe genommen. Hier Denny's Bild. Das sind, wie nennt man das, diese Farbpunkte. Na ja, es gab jedenfalls in den 70ern so Pigmente, besondere Pigmente, die sonnenresistent waren. Die reflektieren also auf besondere Art und Weise. Kann man jetzt erklären und dann sieht man es auch anders. Also wenn die Geschichten dazu kommen, ist es so, ne? Und das, was ich mich frage, ist, so wie heute in Hausaufgaben getrickst wird, um möglichst viel die Kunst machen zu lassen, aber am Ende, es ist meine Mitteilung. Also der Informationsaspekt wird möglichst viel generiert, aber die Mitteilung wird umso deutlich herausgestellt. Ich schreibe meinen Namen auf die Hausarbeit, ich adressiere an den Professor, die E-Mail ist handgeklöppelt, ich baue noch ein paar Fehler ein, damit er sieht, es ist wirklich alles handgemacht. Wie sehr man KI verstecken kann in einer Mitteilung, nicht nur von Künstlern, sondern auch von Schülern, die Hausarbeiten schreiben und so weiter und so fort. Und dieser Spruch, den jetzt relativ viele machen, die KI ersetzt dich nicht im Job, sondern jemand, der KI besser benutzt als du. Den halte ich für super relevant. Also man kriegt es einfach nicht mehr raus. Und die KI erlaubt uns jetzt, sehr viel mehr zu machen, aber als unsere Mitteilung zur Geltung kommen zu lassen. Also es erweitert so den Raum. Es holt den Menschen nochmal besonders hervor. Gerade in der Fotografie unser Kumpel Olli hier in Frankfurt hat jetzt auch Bilder von mir mal gesehen, die Matthias gepromtet hat, wo du wirklich Gesichtsausdrücke einfach reinprompten kannst. Also ich stehe dann so in New York und lächel da so vor mich hin. Und ich sehe wirklich aus, als käme ich gerade aus dem Milliardendeal darunter und biege jetzt so ab und so. Also man kann so richtig rein. Aber umso mehr wird es von entscheidender Bedeutung, dass noch ein Fotograf da ist, der nochmal den echten Stefan fotografiert, den echten Wolfgang. Nicht so, wie man sich gerne sieht oder wie ein Künstler das machen würde oder wie auch immer, sondern da nochmal dieses Echtheitsding rauszukitzeln. Und dann, und du hast es ja schon mal bei der Pressefotografie, nicht nachbearbeiten, sondern es muss in diesen Moment, es muss in die Prä-Production rein. Der Fotoapparat muss richtig eigenstellt sein. Und dann ein Klick, es ist das Werk. So, und das finde ich eigentlich, das sind so diese großen Fragen, da müsste man jetzt mal nachgehen. Also nicht die KI als Künstler, sondern die KI als Werkzeug, die nochmal den Künstler umso mehr, die das Podest noch viel höher macht. Es ist eigentlich erstaunlich, dass wir gerade so eine Diskussion haben, mischt sich jetzt die KI überall ein und dann stellen wir fest, die Leute wollen Taylor Swift sehen und zwar alle. Das ist auch das größte Phänomen nicht nur derzeit, sondern aller Zeiten. Mehr Leute bei dreitätsigen Konzerten als die Beatles bei einer ganzen Tour erreicht haben oder sowas. Da fallen Dimensionen auseinander und da gibt es noch ganz schön viel zu erklären. Aber es könnte eine große Zeit für den Künstler, den Menschen, Autor im weitesten Sinne, den Mitteilenden sein, für Mitteilungen. So, brechen wir alles runter auf kleinste Fragestellung. Was sollte Wolfgang jetzt essen, um gesund zu leben? Es ist wirklich nur eine Quatschliste. Ich weiß nicht mal, ob sie stimmt, aber ich fand sie irgendwie amüsant. Denn auf Platz eins liegt die Mandel. Die BBC hat also so eine komische Sache.
Aber sicherlich nicht die, die man auf der Kirmes kauft. Also nicht die, die schon mit Zucker überzogen ist.
Du kannst sie natürlich veredeln, aber dann fielen sie als high processed food aus dieser Liste raus. Mandeln, reich an einfach ungesättigten Fettsäuren, fördern sie die Herzgesundheit und können bei Diabetes helfen. Also viele Mandeln können sie vielleicht sogar Medikament sein. Platz drei der Rotbarsch. Falls du mal wieder Fisch essen willst, nimm den Rotbarsch. Proteinreicher Tiefseefisch mit niedrigem Gehalt an gesättigten Fetten. Plattfisch, ging auch. Platz fünf die Chiasamen, musst du nehmen. Platz sechs Kürbiskerne. Auf Platz acht, ich lese die Liste gerade selber zum ersten Mal, wie du feststellst, Schweinefett. Eine gute Quelle für Vitamin B. Noch gesünder als Lamm- oder Rindfett.
Aber das steht nicht ein schönes Rezept oder so dabei, sondern es geht wirklich nur um die frühen Inkredenzien.
Man kann ja auch alles noch mal drauflegen. Getrocknete Petersilie, Bohr, Fluorid, Kalzium, gut für Knochen und Zähne.
Also Petersilie mag ich gar nicht.
Brunnenkresse, Sellerie, Flocken, Mandarinen, grüne Erbsen stehen auch unter Platz 30, Hecht.
Ja, sowas ist eher was für mich.
Kabeljau, Jakobsmuscheln?
Kabeljau auch, Jakobsmuscheln auch, ja.
Grapefruit. Löwenzahnblätter, gefrorener Spinat, also wirklich frisch, kurzer Weg, kann auch direkt vom Pflücken kochen, aber Basilikum, Grünkohl, Venusmuschel, Chili Schoten, Platz 30, Brokkoli.
Ja, da freuen sich die Kinder besonders, ja.
Ja, ich werde mein Bestes tun, dass Wolfgang bei jeder Gelegenheit, ich ernehme mich nicht.
Ich bestelle, wir essen hier ein paniertes Schnitzel. Das ist eh nicht mehr zu retten.
Das können wir noch mit Salat.
Das ist eh nicht mehr zu retten, ob du da noch drei Salatblätter dazu nimmst. Aber sonst würde ich sagen, ernähre ich mich gar nicht so schlecht. Ja. Ich esse auch viel Gesundes, also ich bin da gar nicht so schlecht unterwegs. Vielleicht ein bisschen fleischlastig, das würde ich wohl sagen. Aber sonst brauchst du dir nicht allzu viel Sorgen machen. Wir machen uns lieber Sorgen um den Wohnungsmarkt ganz kurz. Ein Artikel aus der Berliner Zeitung. Oder ich leite erst mal anders ein. Vielleicht hast du auch diese Grafik aus der Financial Times gelesen. Da wurden von Gallup Daten erhoben, welche Probleme Menschen in verschiedenen Ländern haben. Und dann war das natürlich sowas wie innere Sicherheit und Infrastruktur, Schulen und dabei kam auch Housing vor. Also wie wohnt man? Und es war interessant, es waren fast allen Ländern, die befragt wurden, das Topthema. Also es ist so flächendeckend.
Und mein neues Hobby, Wohnen.
Ja, Lucas Kuete schreibt in der Berliner Zeitung, die Sorge um steigende Wohnkosten hat jetzt in entwickelten reichen Länder einen Rekordwert erreicht. Also es geht jetzt nicht nur um Deutschland. Mindestens die Hälfte der Bevölkerung in den Mitgliedsstaaten der Organisation für wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung, OECD, ist mit teuren Hypotheken und immer steigenden Mieten unzufrieden, wie eine Untersuchung des amerikanischen Meinungsforschungsinstituts Gallup Analytics ergeben hat. Demnach übertrifft die Unzufriedenheit mit Wohnkosten andere Sorgen, wie Gesundheitsversorge und Bildung. Und dann gibt es so einen Index, wie haben sich also die Mieten im Verhältnis zum Einkommen in Deutschland und in anderen Ländern entwickelt. Und das ist ganz interessant. Der liegt bei 114,13 in Deutschland. Und das sagt einem jetzt erstmal nichts. Was heißt das? Naja, im Vergleich zu 2015 haben die Forscher den Wert von 100 eingezogen. Das heißt, es gibt da einen Anstieg von 14,13 Prozent. Ja, also Verhältnis Mieten kaufen im Verhältnis zum Einkommen. Wenn man jetzt sich Länder ansieht wie USA, Norwegen, Estland oder Polen, dann gibt es da noch deutlich höhere Anstiege. Den höchsten übrigens in der Türkei, was natürlich auch mit der immensen Inflation zu tun hat dort. Die OECD-Daten zeigen, inwiefern auch die Wohnkosten gestiegen sind. Stärker gestiegen sind als das Einkommen. Er sagt, dann schaut man auf die Mietpreisentwicklung der großen deutschen Städte. Unabhängig von der Einkommensdynamik wird die Lage noch kritischer. Der aktuelle Wohnindex des Instituts der deutschen Wirtschaft IW in Köln hat ergeben, dass die Mietpreise nur in den letzten zwei Jahren im Vergleich zum ersten Quartal 2022 um fast 26,9 Prozent in die Höhe geschossen sind. Ich habe wirklich gedacht, das ist gar nicht möglich. Die müssen sich verschrieben haben. 26,9 Prozent.
Der neueste Trend ist jetzt, dass es ein Graufeld gibt durch Untermietverträge. Man kündigt nicht mehr, sondern der nächste wird dein Untermieter, wodurch du deine eh schon hohe Miete noch mal steigern kannst. Ich bin ja nur drei Monate nicht da oder irgend sowas. Dann wird das aber so auf Dauer gestellt. Und das lässt sich statistisch schwer erfassen. Und da ist dann noch die Frage, greift jetzt hier die Mietpreisbremse oder wie auch immer. Weil das sind ja Untermieter. Also es ist wirklich alles, es ist absurd.
Ja und zugleich dann außerhalb des Speckgürtels von Berlin, Leerstände im zweistelligen Bereich.
2 Millionen Wohnungen stehen leer in Deutschland. Aber halt da, wo man sie nicht braucht.
Ganz erstaunlich.
Schlimm ist das.
Wir gehen zu einer letzten Empfehlung über. Ich habe mir gedacht, jetzt haben wir schon so viel geredet, jetzt sollen die Leute doch am Ende des Podcasts sagen, wir brauchen Musik. Isabelle Faust ist eine der größten Geigerinnen unserer Zeit. Sie hat sehr viel eingespielt. Bach, Bartok, Benjamin Britten. Und ich habe auch sehr viele CDs von ihr. Und eine ist auch schon jetzt einige Monate draußen, aber immer noch neu und zwar Isabelle Faust Solo heißt diese CD bei Harmonia Mundi erschienen. Man kann das aber auch, ich habe schon nachgeguckt, bei Apple und bei Spotify hören. Was ist das Besondere an dieser CD? Es ist eine Solo CD. Also wir hören Solo Geige und wir hören Komponisten, die wahrscheinlich die meisten von uns nicht besonders gut oder gar nicht kennen. Heinrich Ignaz Franz Biber, Nicola Matei Senior und Junior, Johann Josef Vilsmaier und noch andere. Und das Besondere ist hier tatsächlich, dass wir Stücke aus einer Zeithürne, in der Bach gelebt hat, zum Teil auch noch ein bisschen davor. Und es sind so unglaublich virtuose Werke. Und man hat nur eine Geige. Und trotzdem ist da eine Vielstimmigkeit da. Also man hat nicht den Eindruck, du hast ja gerne Bombas, du willst ja 120 Leute im Orchester graben, 150 Chorsänger und noch 200 Leute statt Hysterie in der Oper.
Mehr ist mehr, hast du doch gesagt.
Das ist alles ganz schön und ich genieße das auch oft. Aber gerade diese Musik, die hier entsteht, ist so reich, so vielfältig, dass man so ergriffen davon ist. Ich empfehle, anzufangen mit der Passacaglia in G-Moll von Heinrich Ignaz Franz Biber. Und zwar ist das Grundgerüst vier Töne. Und darauf aber dann arbeitet Isabelle Faust dann alles andere an Tönen, an Vielstimmigkeit heraus. Und es ist unglaublich virtuos. Es ist so eine Geige, die aus so einer großen Kontemplation heraus anfängt, glaube ich, zu uns dann zu sprechen und zu singen und zu schreien. Es ist eine Musik, die man nicht nebenher hören kann, das sage ich gleich. Es ist aber eine Musik, auf die, wenn man sich nur ein paar Minuten darauf einlässt, man sofort kommt, dass man sagt, diese Modernität, die da erklingt, ist atemberaubend. Und die Virtuosität, mit der Isabelle Faust über diese Seiten streicht, ist hinreißend. Und ich glaube, dass das gerade für Leute, die nicht viel Klassik hören, ein sehr guter Einstieg deshalb sein kann, weil man jetzt nicht erstmal sich fünf Biografien durchlesen muss über Beethoven oder Mozart oder so, sondern diese Komponisten kennen die meisten von uns nicht besonders gut. Und ich kannte auch einige Namen gar nicht, die hier vertreten sind. Man ist erstaunt darüber, dass 300 Jahre alte Musik so frisch, so neu klingen kann. Und was aus einem Instrument alles herauszuholen ist, wie vielstimmig es sein kann, ist einfach eine Wohltat auch deshalb, weil wir gerade so viele laute, sehr eintönige, sehr dumme Stimmen im politischen Diskurs hören. Der Mensch vermag sehr viel mehr. Die Musik legt Zeugnis davon ab und deswegen diesem Musiktipp zum Schluss, Isabelle Faust, solo.
Hör ich gleich am Montag, denn am Wochenende ist hier in Frankfurt die größte Techno-Party Deutschlands.
Ja, ich wünsche dir viel Vergnügen dabei. Da gehst du hin?
Klar, ich brauch Lärm. Ich also nach diesem Thüringen-Lärm, brauch ich jetzt richtig, einen guten, also hochqualitativen Lärm.
Gut, dann die anderen können sich schon mal an den Doppel- und Trippelgriffen von Isabelle Faust weiden. Wir sehen oder hören uns dann im Live-Salon wieder. Einen schönen Monat bis dahin.
Bis dann.